[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue en direct sur
public sénat édition spéciale ce matin à
l'occasion du discours de politique
générale d'edouard philippe au sénat une
déclaration suivie d'un vote une
procédure rare à la haute assemblée et
qui sera scrutée attentivement par
l'exécutif
on sait déjà que le groupe ait l'air
majoritaire ici à décider de s'abstenir
pour éviter la division
mais ce vote ne sera pas un chèque en
blanc prévient bruno retailleau
d'autant que l'annoncé hier du report de
la réforme des institutions
après les sénatoriales en 2020 est jugée
incompréhensible par 20 la larcher le
contexte s'annonce donc tendue ce matin
on va décrypter les enjeux et le
résultat du scrutin tout au long de
cette matinée spéciale et pour
m'accompagner on retrouvera thème
traduit pour les réactions des sénateurs
en direct de la salle des conférences et
alexandre poussard en direct de la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle et il
va suivre pour nous les débats le
premier ministre va donc s'exprimer à
partir de 9h30 et je vous le disais
justement en titre l'annoncé hier de
reporter la réforme des institutions
relance le bras de fer entre l'exécutif
et la haute assemblée genre archers
refuse d'endosser la responsabilité d'un
échec de cette réforme
explications fabrice culine et j'ai
l'honneur d'engager devant l'assemblée
nationale la responsabilité du
gouvernement que je dirige sur ce
programme
merci merci monsieur milles d'écart la
réponse de gérard larcher ne s'est pas
fait attendre
le communiqué est court et la critique
est clair pour le président du sénat
cette déclaration de politique générale
n'est qu'un copié-collé de la conférence
de presse des manuels macron en avril
dernier d annoncer un calendrier mais
toujours pas de financement sur la
révision constitutionnelle
le titre est tout aussi explicite de
quoi le gouvernement at il peur
gérard larcher ne comprend pas en effet
ce qu'il qualifie de renoncement de la
part de l'exécutif pour lui le sénat
avait rendu un accord possible en
validant certaines avancées le discours
de politique générale renvoie cette
réforme
après le renouvellement de la chambre
haute en 2020
réponse en appel de gérard larcher
ce n'est pas ma vision du dialogue
démocratique pour lui l'exécutif porte
l'entière responsabilité de ce report la
ligne entre le palais du luxembourg et
l'elysée semble cette fois bel et bien
coupés et c'est le plaisir d'écrire d'un
jardin oreilles bonjour bienvenue à vous
docteur en sciences politiques et chargé
d'enseignement à la sorbonne et à
sciences po paris
on vient d'entendre gérard larcher qui
estime dans un communiqué que le
gouvernement a peur de quoi at il peur
de vendre le président du sénat il ne
comprend pas ce renoncement il dit que
la volonté d'aboutir du sénat a toujours
été constante et réaffirmé oui si vous
voulez il était clair que sur cette
réforme et sur la loi organique
il y avait une possibilité d'aboutir à
ce stade après cette possibilité elle
était aléatoire
si vous voulez il ya deux problèmes pour
le gouvernement par rapport à cette
réforme aujourd'hui
premier problème c'est le problème du
calendrier parlementaire n'était pas
possible de faire passer la loi
bioéthique qui est nécessaire
aujourd'hui pour tenir la gauche de la
majorité qui a tout de même souffert
pendant deux ans et d'un autre côté la
révision constitutionnelle
donc il fallait faire un choix faire
endosser la responsabilité de ce choix
au sénat
c'est relativement pratique et ça permet
de tenir la majorité la deuxième
contrainte
et bien c'est celle de potentiel
aboutissement de cette révision
constitutionnelle et même s'il pouvait y
avoir un accord en aval du sénat eh bien
les majorités peuvent fluctuer
il n'est pas évident qu'il y aurait eu
les trois cinquièmes au congrès donc à
partir de là se lancer dans ce processus
de révision constitutionnelle même avec
un accord qui était à portée de main
c'était tout de même dangereux c'était
tout de même à l'heure aléatoire et en
tout cas cette et chronophage et le
gouvernement aujourd'hui dans calendrier
parlementaire très clairement n'a pas de
temps pour elles il ya en effet un
risque que aujourd'hui les tensions soit
un peu plus vive
après il faut pas non plus se mentir si
cette révision constitutionnelle est
reporté c'est plutôt bon pour le
gouvernement qui encore une fois d'un
assumer plus réellement le calendrier et
c'est pas non plus tout à fait mauvais
pour les sénateurs qui n'ont jamais
réellement voulu cette révision
constitutionnelle il était prêt
probablement il consentir dans un
processus de dialogue
mais très clairement l'idée que celle ci
arrive ne les enchante et pas le
gouvernement veut attendre après les
prochaines sénatoriales il espère
peut-être aussi à voir
davantage de sénateur en marche ici pour
faire passer ce type de réforme alors
oui il peut en effet y avoir à la sortie
des prochaines sénatoriales un groupe en
marche plus important parce que les
dernières sénatoriales se sont passées
sur un corps de grands électeurs qui
avait été élu à un moment où la
république en marche n'existait pas donc
il y aura probablement pas de
raz-de-marée la république en marche
d'abord parce que le sénat est renouvelé
par moitié et parce que eh bien l'effet
des municipales est beaucoup plus
complexe a fait d'ailleurs de
renouvellement intégral c'est est évoqué
il y aura pas de renouvellement intégral
s'il ya pas d'adoption de la loi
organique
parce qu'en fait sinon la loi ordinaire
qui impose le renouvellement intégral
serait considéré comme disproportionné
par le conseil constitutionnel donc pas
loi organique pas de renouvellement
intégral là dessus si le gouvernement
devant reparler et tiré en fait avec un
pistolet à eau donc de façon générale
ces prochaines sénatoriales vont être
probablement assez lisible le problème
c'est que le groupe la république en
marche quand bien même il serait plus
important ne sera pas suffisant pour
faire adopter la réforme
la gauche qui aujourd'hui hostile la
droite est aujourd'hui plutôt timoré par
rapport à cette réforme
donc même après 2020 même avec un groupe
la république en marche plus important
il faudra compter sur l'aval des autres
groupes
il faudra rentrer encore dans un
processus de négociation qui aujourd'hui
novembre à côté aujourd'hui et bien
c'est le vote de la majorité sénatoriale
pour en parler on va retrouver alexandre
tout ça on se disait vous êtes en direct
de la tribune de presse on sait déjà que
le groupe ait l'air a décidé hier en
réunion groupe exceptionnel de
s'abstenir
et oui delphine c'est l'enjeu ce matin
d'observer comment la majorité de droite
et du centre ici au sénat va se
positionner par rapport au gouvernement
alors que le parti républicain est en
crise après la débâcle aux européennes
alors ce vote proposé au sénat après le
discours de politique générale et ben eh
bien il est perçu comme un piège par les
sénateurs les républicains qui se sont
réunis hier en groupe intégrale avec la
présence du président du sénat gérard
larcher pour définir une position claire
pour éviter la division et dessinateur
les républicains estiment avoir trouvé
la parade
écoutez bruno retailleau le président du
groupe du groupe l'est républicain
interrogé par françois vignal je vous
annonce que le groupe sera très très
très très majoritairement sur une même
position qui sera qui sera l'abstention
qui sera l'abstention ça n'est
absolument pas un chèque en blanc
puisque l'objectif du sénat le rôle du
scénar ça n'est pas de renverser le
gouvernement
d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas
constitutionnellement le pouvoir le rôle
du sénat
c'est d'améliorer les textes lorsque
nous le pouvons et très concrètement ça
signifie que ça ne sera pas
systématiquement n'ont ni
systématiquement oui c'est à dire que
nous voulons avoir notre totale liberté
pour dire que lorsque les choses vont
bien
ça va dans le bon sens et on encourage
mais lorsque les choses vont pas dans le
bon sens pour la france pour les
français ont dit non un groupe l'est
républicain au sénat qui est donc
constructif contrairement à leurs
collègues de l'assemblée nationale
puisque les députés les républicains ont
voté contre aux 4/5 contre le discours
de politique générale d'edouard philippe
alors du côté du groupe centriste au
sénat la peau mieux la position est
légèrement différente puisque les
sénateurs centristes sont partagés entre
un vote pour et une abstention
écoutez le président du groupe centriste
hervé marseille nous avons trouvé
beaucoup de choses
qui vont dans un sens que nous
souhaitons nous souhaitons que la france
se réforme ne souhaitant le succès du
gouvernement parce que ça serait le
succès de notre pays et ce serait bien
pour ses habitants
donc nous sommes favorables pour
accompagner beaucoup de ces mesures il
ya beaucoup aussi d'interrogations sur
un certain nombre d'autres points en
particulier sur la réforme
institutionnelle et puis sur les sujets
territoriaux mais là et on nous dit que
le premier ministre va apporter des
compléments d'informations et de
précisions
et au final le grand vainqueur de ce
vote ce matin devrait être l'abstention
merci beaucoup alexandre pour vos
précisions on va retourner à salle des
conférences pour une réaction
avec wotan tran huy avec le sénateur et
l'ère jean françois husson
on vient d'entendre ce sera donc
l'abstention pour tout le groupe ce
matin
oui effectivement jean françois husson
mais pourquoi l'abstention pour tout le
groupe at elle été décidé hier pourquoi
pas un vote contre l'abstention parce
qu'il faut entendre le vote des français
il faut regarder également la position
du gouvernement je dirais même la
posture qui a été adoptée hier dans la
glaise déclaration de politique générale
du gouvernement qui est finalement
l'annoncent d'un véritable virage comme
souvent d'ailleurs au bout de deux ans
d'exercice du pouvoir dans les
septennats et un quinquennat
sur quoi vous entendez un véritable
virage par le 7 c'est donc d'abord il ya
un premier virage l'explosion des
colères et partie de la crise des gilet
jaune
j'avais moi même alerté dès novembre
2010 est sûre le risque géré de
d'enflammer le pays
la réponse a été cinglante le
gouvernement pour l'instant lève le
crayon sur la taxe carbone invite en
tous les cas je l'invite au dialogue sur
les ambitions écologiques de ce que j'ai
entendu hier
il ya là le début de quelque chose mais
honnêtement parler des couverts en
plastique
quand on est une ambition a lâché dans
l'administration ça reste faible
honnêtement voilà c'est vraiment tout
petit alors en rajoute à ça la politique
contre les mégots c'est vraiment pas la
hauteur mais j'entends et moi j'entends
sur tout le gouvernement a besoin de
mettre tous les acteurs autour de la
table il a une occasion unique à la fois
je dirais de proposer un échange avec
les français et de s'appuyer sur les
corps intermédiaires les syndicats
les deux assemblées qu'il regarde bien
l'attitude du sénat qui est une attitude
qui vise à la réussite de la france
d'accord donc c'est la droite
constructive c'est pas une droite un
petit peu mal tout de même
non non vous allez vous vous à
l'occasion de voir il ya absolument
aucune mauvaise il y aura des exigences
et de la responsabilité
on est attendus tous les français nous
attendent sur la responsabilité la
réussite pour chacun que la
mondialisation soit perçue comme eu plus
une opportunité qu'une machine à broyer
des emplois des initiatives on a une
exigence des français nous devons être
collectivement la hauteur et nous y
prendrons toutes d'autre part vous êtes
déjà décidé sur la position du groupe
mais vous n'avez pas entendu le discours
de ce matin on annonce tout de même et
bien un nouvel acte de décentralisation
qu'attendez vous du premier ministre sur
ce point mais il serait temps mais
surtout il va falloir donner de
véritables gages de la sincérité
j'entends beaucoup parler le mot
confiance est utilisé sur tous les
projets de loi mais aujourd'hui il faut
répondre au sentiment de défiance
donc j'attends et puis je crois qu'il ya
des véritables gages à donner
les élus locaux sont prêts ils ont été
méprisés pendant deux ans le sénat a
plutôt été balayée d'un revers de main
voilà donc au mépris
il faut aujourd'hui l'écoutent le
dialogue c'est indispensable
il ya eu un début d'ouverture hier
lorsque les dents philippe dit qu'il
veut des mesures pour favoriser
l'engagement des mers qu'il veut
s'accorder avec les élus et leurs
représentants sur la meilleure méthode
pour clarifier le mille feuille
territorial
je le cite ce sont là encore des
annonces ou un changement de méthode qui
vous satisfait alors c'est une annonce
j'attends de voir parce que jusqu'à
maintenant la commune était plutôt vu
par le mépris comme le dernier échelon
de ceux qui voudraient s'accrocher je
rappelle juste la commune si aujourd'hui
plus de 500 mille élus locaux bénévoles
alors l'engagement pour la france il
commençait prend racine dans nos
territoires
alors vous attendez de voir des acteurs
donc oui oui parce qu'il ya de luan et à
loin de la coupe aux lèvres honnêtement
oui nos pas de chèque en blanc mais bien
l'abstention pour le groupe jean
françois husson
merci beaucoup atteint pour cette
première réaction et olivier babeau nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour
bienvenue vous êtes président de
l'institut sapience professeur à
l'université de bordeaux on voit ici la
droite sénatoriale qui a fait ce choix
ce tension bruno retailleau le disais il
ya de bonnes choses dans ce qui a été
annoncé hier je cite la fournit régimes
spéciaux
la réforme de l'assurance chômage mais
il ya aussi l'absence de pistes
notamment dans la bonne gestion des
deniers publics ça ça va dans le mauvais
sens c'est toujours cette interrogation
avec cette annonce sur la baisse des
impôts comment à financer c'est toujours
le point faible du gouvernement
oui vous avez à la fois on pourrait dire
un diagnostic économique qui est le même
que celui de la droite et que
personnellement je trouve plutôt le bon
on a un problème d'incitation au travail
et donc on essaye de redonner ces
incitations de toutes les façons
possibles
c'est pour aider à l'idée de l'assurance
chômage où on va durcir un petit peu
d'ailleurs il n'a pas répété parce qu'on
disait pas en demain va hier à redon est
peut-être aujourd'hui on ne dit pas une
nouvelle qui fâchent mais donc on essaye
de durcir les conditions d'accès à
l'assurance chômage
on va aussi rendre dégressif les plus
grandes et les plus grandes allocations
chômage pour les pour les plus hauts les
peaux les plus hauts revenus donc pour
essayer de rendre plus incitatif le
retour à l'emploi
on essaie de ordre de réforme est
réellement les retraites et on le fait
avec cette subtilité effectivement que
les jours ont vu mais c'est que pour
sortir du totem on va créer un nouveau
concept qui est l'âge déquilibre dont on
sait très bien en fait qui va être
effectivement plus tardif et qui va être
plus intéressant de partir plus tard
mais donc on aura symboliquement laissé
les soixante deux ans et prix l'âge des
équilibres et puis derrière quand même
le pendant le revers de la médaille
c'est qu'en effet on continue à attendre
les économies comme on attend godot
c'est à dire qu on en parle beaucoup on
imagine qu'il va y avoir quelques niches
fiscales qui vont être traités mais ça
fait un moment qu'on cherche en réalité
on n'a pas trouvé grand chose à chaque
fois qu'on parle d'une niche tout d'un
coup on dit ah mais oui mais celle ci
elle est peut-être un intérêt où on a
bien compris que le gazole sur les sur
les chantiers évidemment elle est plus
taxé avec probablement d'ailleurs une
conséquence sur les consommateurs est ça
qui va mais on est très très loin très
très loin du compte et en même temps
j'entends des le ministre bruno le maire
ce matin sur une
radio du service public qui expliquait
que ce ne serait ni le déficit ni ni
évidemment des augmentations d'impôts
donc à ce moment-là ça veut dire que
c'est une baisse des dépenses et cette
baisse des dépenses on la cherche
toujours les pièges et là la droite
sénatoriale ça traduit cette position
l'abstention disait c'est contraire à ce
qui s'est passé à l'assemblée nationale
hier où le groupe ait l'air a voté
contre
oui mais les enjeux du vote au sénat
sont un peu différent parce que d'abord
c'est pas un vote de confiance
c'est une déclaration du premier
ministre et donc ça n'engage pas à
soutenir le gouvernement
donc à partir de là la position
politique est moins forte et on peu
avant en effet comme le fait bruno
retailleau argué de cette position
sénatoriales traditionnel pas
d'opposition systématique et pas
d'approbation non plus systématique
l'opposition constructive de l'aps et
voilà on s'abstient et donc du coup on
attend de voir et on jugera sur pièce au
cas par cas
donc du point de vue institutionnel ça a
du sens et ça a du sens du point de vue
électoral il faut pas non plus
maintenant tirs qu'est-ce qui a tué un
peu la liste de droite aux européennes
c'est l'effet vote utile vote utile pour
l'assemblée nationale d'un côté vote
utile pour allèrent même de l'autre donc
vous avez toute une partie du centre qui
a voté à l'erreur même par défaut contre
marine le pen en se disant si elle est
en tête bien un problème et toute une
partie des électeurs de droite plutôt
conservatrice qui ont dit pour voter
macron pour voter contre macron il faut
voter pour le parti capable d'arriver en
tête donc le rn donc si vous voulez
arriver à exister pour l air au milieu
de ça il faut une position d'opposition
parce que sinon eh bien vous confirmer
cette stratégie là les lecteurs plutôt
anti macron va dire m'a regardé il vote
la confiance ou l'abstention
donc ils sont d'accord avec l europe lrm
donc autant voter est reine et d'un
autre côté les électeurs centristes se
dit autant voter directement pour aller
rm que voter pour elles air donc pour
contrer cet effet vote utile il fallait
une position claire à l'assemblée là
c'est pas tout à fait le même cas au
sénat d'abord parce que vous avez une
publicité de ce vote qui va être moins
grande que celui d'hier et parce que les
électeurs sénatoriaux les grands
électeurs sénatoriaux ne sont pas tout à
fait dans les mêmes dispositions et les
municipales qui arrive le corps des
électeurs de droite est beau
ou de grandes et grands électeurs de
droite est beaucoup plus de centre-droit
que d'une droite on va dire plus
classique plus conservatrices plus dur
donc à partir de là l'adresse ne peut
pas être la même la position ne peut pas
être la même
et comme les institutions permettent
justement de justifier ça et bien
c'était probablement la position des
meilleurs en plus avec la vertu de ne
pas rompre l'unité du groupe
on va continuer ce décryptage mais avant
cela on retourne celle des conférences
pour une nouvelle réaction avec vous à
terme tran huy avec le sénateur
socialiste jean louis durand oui j'ai re
me dira qu attendez-vous tout simplement
de l'allocution du premier ministre ce
matin qui doit être différente de celle
d'hier est notamment portée et bien sûr
la question de la décentralisation
on attend des clarifications on attend
un peu de sincérité dans le propos parce
qu'on a été assez déçu du discours
d'hier on savait cette majorité faible
sur la question sociale décevantes sur
la question écologique parfois
inquiétantes sur les questions
démocratiques
il est temps peut-être d'apporter des
réponses concrètes décevantes sur la
question écologique cependant edouard
philippe a commencé hier son discours en
parlant environnement vous ne croyez pas
en la conversion écologique du
gouvernement
les critiques les plus dures viennent de
la partie écologique
du mouvement présidentiel nicolas hulot
est parti beaucoup ont été déçus
on n'a pas eu de gaz jusqu'à présent
mais y adhérer dit sur la rénovation
énergétique sur l'arrêt des plastiques
dans l'administration ce genre de choses
alors anti-gaspillage lutter contre
plastique c'est fantastique mais il faut
des moyens aussi pour ça donc on va
attendre de voir quels sont les crédits
qui sont affectés à ces nouvelles
politiques et le degré de sincérité du
gouvernement sur ces sujets hier edouard
philippe a dit l'accord semble proche
avec le sénat sur la révision
constitutionnelle et part de la
réduction d'un quart du nombre de
parlementaires de l'assouplissement du
cumul de mandats dans le temps pour les
maires de petites villes
ça ce sont de bonnes choses vous pensez
que ça fait réellement satisfaire le
scénario et je crois qu'il ya pas de
d'objections de fond le point d'accord
est assez proche ce que j'ai senti c'est
une très très grande prudence du premier
ministre on sait pas d'ailleurs
quel est le niveau ii d'entente dans
l'attelage présidentielle premier
ministre sur le sujet et elle m'a
président du sénat on a surtout
l'impression qu' on a surtout
l'impression qu'il s'agit de faire
porter au sénat une forme de
conservatisme sur des mesures qui
seraient dites populaires
moi je crois que le sénat est prêt à
prendre sa part à ce cette évolution
institutionnelle pour peu qu'on soit
écouté pour que le projet soit équilibré
philippe il a dit qu'on n'entendrait pas
la révision constitutionnelle sans
l'accord du sénat
oui c'est ça mais c'est une façon de
dire comme le sénat ne veut pas on va
différer et puis j'ai trouvé cette
sollicitude sur la bonne utilisation du
temps parlementaire assez malvenu on
travaille dans de mauvaises conditions
on aide les productions c'est dur
accélérer le travail parlementaire et
malmené souvent qu'on se préoccupe de
savoir s'il est bien utilisé ce temps
parlementaire m'amuse un petit peu il
n'a également pas évoqué hier
l'hypothèse du renouvellement total du
sénat en 2021 on en parlait déjà depuis
plusieurs jours ils restent sur un
renouvellement classique en 2020 et dit
que la révision constitutionnelle va
attendre le prochain renouvellement
on peut aussi dire que d'un certain côté
cette volonté de brusquer le sénat est
de changer les règles en cours de route
oui je si c'est cette lecture qu'il faut
faire deux
des photos du premier ministre alors
tant mieux j'espère que on est bien sur
cette logique et ce n'est pas une façon
différée en nous faisant passer pour
d'affreux conservateur je crois que la
réforme est proche nous sommes de bonne
volonté
tous ici au sénat donc allons-y pour
conclure comment interpréter le fait
qu'il y ait un vote aujourd'hui au sénat
on sait que c'est une procédure assez
rare pour votre groupe c'est assez clair
vous allez tous voté contre
je pense qu'on sera sur une position
unanime nous verrons à la fin c'est le
grand mercato qui continue voilà on est
dans des transferts la saison est finie
la prochaine commence et on voit que la
droite d'ailleurs choisi de se protéger
en s'abstenant pour ne pas donner prise
à d'éventuelles défections
voilà donc j'essaie de la politique à
l'ancien et le nouveau monde en est
aussi capable
eh bien merci beaucoup jérôme durain
d'avoir répondu à mes questions merci à
vous au tam alors que l'on voit à
edouard philippe qui fait son entrée au
sénat le premier ministre accompagné du
ministre des collectivités sébastien
lecornu il va donc s'exprimer dans une
dizaine de minutes discours à suivre en
intégralité sur notre antenne un
discours on le rappelle qui sera suivi
d'un vote et c'est une procédure assez
rare
olivier babeau j'aurais qu'on revienne
sur cette urgence écologique a été
décrété hier il ya besoin justement
d'accélérer et ça sera le cas dans les
12 prochains mois justement toutes ces
mesures écologiques est en train lui
parlais à l'instant d'une conversion la
prise de conscience est tardive mais
nécessaire oui alors les mauvais esprits
sans doute diront que l'accélération
écologique est dû aussi à l'accélération
écologique dans les urnes donc le
résultat des européennes évidemment à
changer la donne on voit tout d'un coup
la réémergence un peu inattendue d'un
vote vert fort peut-être une prise de
conscience forte
ça veut pas dire qu'ils avaient pas eu
des mesures qui avait déjà été fait mais
maintenant dis donc elles sont mises en
avant on a bien vu hier que j'avais des
mesures qui ce sont des mesures qui ont
été mises en avant tout de suite alors
effectivement elles peuvent faire un
petit peu rires par le côté un peu
dérisoire y aura plus de deux gobelets
en plastique dans les administrations
publiques on peut s'en féliciter
par ailleurs on annonce évidemment le
continuation du recul du nucléaire au
profit d'un néo lien en mer
dont on se demande en réalité s'il va
pouvoir être capable de prédire de
pallier la différence énergétique mais
disons que la volonté la volonté elle
est là elle est clairement allait
clairement affichée il y as sans doute
de dans une volonté électorale de capter
une partie de cet électorat qui est
important et puis sans doute vous
pourrez dire une volonté sans doute
honnêtes gens qu'on peut leur donner ce
crédit d'essayer de progresser il faut
rappeler que la france et fait partie
quand même des pays les plus vertueux
dans le monde donc on va continuer à ton
dieu oui si vous voulez qu'est ce qui
s'est passé aux européennes emmanuel
macron a changé d'électorat c'est à dire
que l'électorat de centre-droit qui
avaient voté fillon présidentielle est
venu voter la république en marche
électorat de centre gauche qui avec il
avait en grande partie porté au pouvoir
cet électorat social démocrate l'a
abandonné et a choisi en fait de se
reporter d'abord et avant tout sur les
verts l'objectif du gouvernement c'est
de maintenir cette base de centre-droit
et d'ailleurs il ya eu des éléments sur
l'immigration l'identité exacte ra pour
tenter de bétonner cette base là encore
et il faut aller récupérer ses électeurs
de centre gauche qui sont partis comment
est-ce qu'on va récupérer ses électeurs
de centre gauche
il ya deux grands cyniques qui ont été
envoyés hier premier signe en effet
cette question de l'écologie auquel cet
électorat est particulièrement sensible
et la manifester dans votre verre
deuxième élément la loi bioéthique avec
la question de la paix m et ses
ouvertures sociétal qui encore une fois
sont importantes pour cet électorat donc
là le discours d'hier était assez bien
équilibré on peut s'interroger sur le
caractère révolutionnaire des mesures ou
sur le coup sûr le souffle du discours
mais en tout cas l'objectif d'un point
de vue électoral était extrêmement
claire centre-droit centre gauche c'est
ce qui a fait la victoire d'emmanuel
macron au second tour et c'est ce qui
peut faire demain sa base électorale
renouvelée et renforcée avant de
continuer par olivier babeau on retourne
pour une dernière action avant le
discours d'edouard philippe avec vous et
entre amis avec le sénateur centriste
loïc hervé on est en train de parler et
bien du discours de politique générale
du premier ministre hier à l'assemblée
nationale est ce que vous avez été
convaincu par son intervention vous
savez que nous avons eues au sénat ici
lu par le ministre d'état françois de
rugy
c'est un discours de politique générale
d'eau
on connaissait les grandes lignes
puisqu'il reprend en somme ce que le
président la république avait annoncé
lors de sa conférence de presse moi je
me réjouis des différentes inflexion
qu'ont pu être donnée domaine écologique
et puis on verra ce matin ici au sénat
l'évolution majeure que nous attendons
sur la question de la relation aux
territoires le sénat la maison des
territoires acte de décentralisation le
nouvel de réalisation la relation avec
les maires les questions financières
dans les relations avec les
collectivités territoriales sont des
sujets sur lequel nous interpellons le
gouvernement depuis deux ans maintenant
et donc sur lequel nous attendons nous
sénateurs des réponses très précises
quelle va être la position du groupe il
ya donc eu une réunion hier il ya un
certain nombre de votes pour déjà vous
savez que le groupe s'inscrit dans la
majorité sénatoriale
quant à son appartenance à la majorité
présidentielle eh bien nous avons
différentes nuances des sénateurs qui
depuis toujours s'estime membres de la
majorité présidentielle je pense aux à
nos collègues du modem quant à la
majeure partie des sénateurs du groupe
union centriste
ils s'abstiendront je pense tout à
l'heure étant un peu plus distant de
l'appartenance stricte la majorité
présidentielle mais ce sera une
abstention bienveillante
oui on ne parle tout de même de 15 à 20
personnes qu'ils voteraient pour
au sein du groupe c'est beaucoup pour
des membres de la majorité sénatoriale
jeu ses collègues là sont des collègues
qu'ils veulent
donnez un acte de confiance au
gouvernement je n'en fais pas partie moi
même je m'abstiendrai mais ses collègues
veulent dire que il s'est passé quelque
chose entre la fin du grand débat la
conférence du président de presse du
président de la république
et puis le discours de politique
générale hier à l'assemblée nationale
avec son son annexe aujourd'hui au sénat
puisque le premier ministre sera devant
nous pour parler notamment des
territoires effectivement vous qui a
très engagé sur la notamment la question
du statut de l'élu hier et bien edouard
philippe a dit qu'il voulait des mesures
pour favoriser l'engagement des mers
s'accorder avec les huiles représentants
sur une meilleure méthode pour réformer
sur le millefeuille territorial
tout ça ce sont en tout cas des bonnes
intentions pour vous franchement c'est
le moment parce que on est à moins d'un
an des élections municipales
donc ça va être déjà de même très
compliqué de modifier toutes les règles
électorales puisqu'on ne peut pas le
faire mais quand en termes de statut de
l'élu en termes de relation aux élus en
termes de d'organisation territoriale du
pays
le faire aussi à quelques mois des
municipales ça va être compliqué mais en
disons que c'est une bonne chose et 10
et ayant un a priori de confiance sur
ces choses que nous attendons depuis
très longtemps
le sénat a rédigé des rapports sur ce
sujet je suis la commission des lois je
connais bien bien la chose beaucoup de
collègues sont engagés sur cette
question là moi aussi je m'y intéresse
est vraiment faut avancer parce que si
on veut que la démocratie française vit
notamment à son échelon le plus local
plus proche de nos concitoyens il faut
vraiment encourager et vous aller
scruter le discours de ce matin ont une
dernière question politique que pensez
vous du fait que le groupe ait l'air et
choisit très majoritairement de
s'abstenir
mais je crois que le groupe je crois que
je crois que le groupe l'est républicain
et le président du sénat en particulier
ne veulent pas
donnez un a priori de défiance à ces
initiatives qui sont prises en direction
ne veulent pas être comptés non plus
voyez aussi ça vient aussi ça parce que
enfin rappelons quand même qu'il n'ya
pas du 17 années de discours ou du
prénom la république au congrès que ça
se transforme en discours de politique
générale du premier ministre avec un
vote au sénat ce qui est chose très rare
donc vous avez on sait faire un peu de
politique est immense et on sait ce que
ça veut pouvoir dire eh bien merci
beaucoup loïc hervé d'avoir répondu à
mes questions
merci à vous tam pour cette nouvelle
réaction olivier babeau on voit que les
attentes ici au sénat sont un peu
différentes et c'est naturel de celle
des députés il ya cette question de la
décentralisation du statut de l'élu
avec un projet de loin qui va être
présenté et détaillé certainement ce
matin par edouard philippe pour
notamment et bien encourager les
vocations pour justement faire revenir
les maires vers ce mandat oui il ya un
vrai suspense ce matin soit on a si son
écoute pour dire la même chose qui hier
mais différemment
soit on a vraiment les briques
manquantes du discours d'hier est donc
les deux faisant un tout cohérent et
c'est ce qu'on attendrait c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement va nous
parler de la réforme territoriale alors
c'est vrai que pour les français ça
paraît peut-être pas grand-chose mais en
fait c'est au moins c'est la clef de
tout c'est moins une triple clé c'est
une clé autour du problème de la
désertification dont on sait que l a pu
entraîner le problème des gilet jaune
c'est une clé aussi pour la cohésion
sociale parce qu'on a bien constaté que
depuis deux mandats ce qui a manqué
c'est justement ces corps intermédiaires
qui avait disparu avec on pourrait dire
en grande partie
c est lui qui faisait jusque-là l'espèce
deux d'entre deux les médias entre les
gens les gens au des territoires puis
william tous les citoyens et puis les
centres de décision et à ce titre là
d'ailleurs le cumul des mandats a été
une bêtise absolue en 100 rencontres
puisque on a des mères qui ne sont plus
député-maire opus sénateur-maire et
s'ils ont perdu une partie de la roja
est aussi on pourrait dire deux pas de
leur pertinence mais de du poids qu'ils
pouvaient avoir aux yeux des gens donc
l'enjeu c'est d'une façon ou d'une autre
avec cette réforme de retrouver ce lien
effectivement de recréer aussi des
vocations parce qu'on a une crise des
vocations l'espagne a pas que le pape
dans l'église catholique
la crise des vocations elle est très
forte elle est dramatique aujourd'hui il
faut le dire être un politique sauf si
vous êtes un moine soldat
ça n'est plus
attractif vous gagnez extrêmement peu
d'argent pour le niveau de
responsabilité que vous avez vous avez
surtout des problèmes vous avez très
très peu de reconnaissance c'est très
difficile donc l'enjeu est absolument
fondamental c'est probablement la partie
du discours paradoxalement qui est la
plus importante aujourd'hui
ça passe par la création d'un statut de
l'élu benjamin morel on sait que le
sénat travaille sur cette question
depuis des années le kervella l'a
rappelé alors il va falloir voir en
effet on peut pas trop appréhender ce
que va dire edouard philippe
on devrait en fait avoir deux projets de
loi l'un en effet sur l'engagement des
mères qui est vraiment important qui est
vraiment attendu et qui est essentiel
parce que justement cet échelon de base
de la démocratie aujourd'hui a été
profondément malmené par la loi notre
excellent terrain le président de la
république l'a reconnu il en a beaucoup
parlé avec les maires durant le grand
débat donc là il va falloir voir en quoi
exactement vont consister les réponses
ces réponses elles sont attendues mais
elles sont un peu tardive parce que
comme c'était dit on a des municipales
bientôt me falloir voir qu'est-ce qui va
pouvoir entrer en application avant et
après et ensuite il ya cette question d'
acte iii de la décentralisation qui est
pas forcément évidente parce que si je
ne m'abuse edouard philippe n'a pas
parlé comme ça hier il a parlé de
simplification du millefeuille
c'est quand même un peu différent et
dans cet acte iii de la décentralisation
qui n'en a pas le nom est en fait deux
éléments il ya des éléments qui ne sont
pas de la décentralisation ni qui sont
en fait de la déconcentration
ça commence à apparaître avec des
circulaires et cetera là aussi il ya
beaucoup d'inconnues parce que dire on
va supprimer des fonctionnaires à paris
et on va les rétabli on va les établir
en province c'est pas évident d'abord
parce qu'il n'a pas d'armée de
fonctionnaires qui écrivent des normes à
paris qu'on pourrait re déployés sur le
territoire
donc c'est plus compliqué ensuite la
simplification du millefeuille sans
supprimer un échelon
qu'est ce que ça va pouvoir dire et
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir négocier des
associations des nous lie à l'envrer
suspense également
compétences claires pour les
collectivités olivier babeau avec aussi
des financements clair ce sont un petit
peu les pistes
dévoilée hier par et d'infini oui une
des réponses qu'on pourrait attendre
c'est peut-être que à travers la réforme
territoriale on permette enfin ce
redéploiement de l'état qui est la seule
vraie clé des économies durables au delà
des coups de rabot qu'on essaye de faire
sur des niches fiscales à droite ou à
gauche mais ça nécessiterait vraiment
une remise à plat du fonctionnement ou
contrairement à ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
maintenant on ne met pas des gens en
province pour finalement les maintenir
voire les augmenter encore au niveau de
l'état c'est très difficile cette
question du millefeuille il faut le dire
qu'en france elle reste totalement
entière la dernière réforme des régions
a été absolument catastrophique
de ce point de vue là disons le les
français évidemment ne le savent pas
c'était catastrophique on a fait encore
une fois c'est sous monsieur hollande si
je ne m'abuse
on est encore une fois agrandi
millefeuille le le réduire est-ce qu'on
va arriver
ce coup-ci enfin à la longue des choses
et 6-4 en amour elle puisque l art c
vient d'arriver il a ouvert la séance on
écoute tout de suite la déclaration de
politique générale du jour appelle une
déclaration de politique générale du
gouvernement suivie d'un débat et d'un
vote
nous sommes en application de l'article
49 quatrième alinéa de notre
constitution
je rappelle qu'après la déclaration de
monsieur le premier ministre
la parole sera donnée un orateur de
chaque groupe puis nous procéderons vote
sur la déclaration de politique générale
par un scrutin public à la tribune
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président du sénat le
times et messieurs les sénateurs si
juste
si j'utilise aujourd'hui l'alinéa 4 de
l'article 49 de la constitution pour
vous demander l'approbation de la
déclaration de politique générale c'est
pour exprimer mon respect du
bicaméralisme du bicamérisme qui fonde
nos institutions est ma grande
considération chambre haute
cette procédure est rare dans l'histoire
de la vème république
j'ai choisi de l'utiliser par souci de
clarté de responsabilité dans un moment
de bascule de notre vie politique qui
nous invite à dépasser des clivages
anciens le 5 juillet 2017
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous présentais ma première déclaration
de politique générale
la plupart des engagements que j'y
prenais conformément au programme du
président de la république sont tenues
ou en cours d'accomplissement notre
conviction qu'il y a urgence à faire
avancer le pays n'a pas changé notre
détermination s'est même accru les
français se sont exprimés lors des
élections présidentielle et législatives
de 2010 est et plus récemment lors des
élections européennes
et je n'oublie pas que les grands
électeurs se sont pour leur part exprimé
en septembre 2017
mais nous savons tous que nos
concitoyens ne s'exprime pas seulement
les jours d'élection la démocratie ce
n'est pas seulement glissé son bulletin
dans une urne
quelles que soient nos affinités
partisanes quelles que soient les
sensibilités politiques que vous
incarnez et que vous représentez vous
avez pu mesurer comme nous tous ces
derniers mois à quel point nos
concitoyens sont préoccupés et souvent
en colère chez beaucoup d'entre eux
s'expriment un violent rejet des
injustices territoriales et fiscales des
complexités administratives des ratés de
notre système de solidarité
un sentiment de colère face à la vie
chère une société bloquée dans
l'ascenseur social qui ne fonctionne
plus pour beaucoup la politique est
devenue synonyme d'incompréhension et de
dépossession nos compatriotes demandent
plus de proximité plus de participation
le président malhuret dans une
intervention remarquée l'a dit comme
d'habitude avec des termes précis et
sans complaisance
en même temps que leur incompréhension
et leur colère beaucoup expriment leur
aspiration à l'engagement pour leur
valeur pour leur ville pour leurs
enfants ou pour la planète vivre
dignement de son travail respirer un air
pur avoir accès à une alimentation de
qualité pouvoir se déplacer quand on
habite à la campagne pratiquer une
activité sportive ou culturelle
voilà qui a du sens pour nos concitoyens
créer des emplois et des richesses tout
en gardant la sagesse de valoriser aussi
et peut-être surtout ce qui n'a pas de
prix l'éducation le patrimoine
artistique la transmission des valeurs
l'accompagnement des malades ou des
personnes âgées voilà ce qui préoccupe
aussi nos concitoyens voilà ce qui
réconcilie le politique la politique et
la proximité voilà ce qui peut nous
réconcilier durablement avec les
français nous qui nous sommes engagés
quels que soient les idées ou les
valeurs que nous portons pour améliorer
leur vie quotidienne
je ne vous révèlerai pas la déclaration
de politique générale que j'ai prononcé
hier à l'assemblée nationale vous l'avez
parfaitement entendu grâce au ministre
d'état françois de rugy
je mesure la surprise qui a été la vôtre
est sans doute la sienne lorsque vous
l'avez entendu vous dire qu'il venait de
la droite qu'il avait été salarié d'une
grande entreprise du nucléaire
je le remercie d'avoir porté ma voix
devant vous ap en sachant se prendre la
distance nécessaire entre celui qui
écrivait celui utilisé
vous avez donc compris que nous
engagions l'acte 2 du quinquennat du
président de la république cet acte ii
s'inscrit dans la continuité du premier
acte mais s'en distingue très fortement
par la méthode nous ne renions rien
sommes fiers des avancées qui ont été
acquises depuis deux ans pour libérer le
travail tout en renforçant les filets de
sécurité qui protège nos concitoyens les
plus vulnérables nous sommes fiers aussi
d'avoir consenti un effort sans
précédent en décembre en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens
c'était nécessaire pour redonner de la
confiance et de l'oxygène à beaucoup de
français
cet effort se poursuivre
répondre à l'urgence écologique et le
premier axe de notre feuille de route
j'ai présenté hier mon plan de bataille
pour les prochains mois nous allons
accélérer la transformation
environnemental de notre économie de nos
transports rendre plus accessible et
plus incitative les aides à la
rénovation énergétique en finir avec un
consumérisme qui consiste à jeter a
gaspillé avec une insouciance
inconsidérés et qui met en danger la
qualité de notre alimentation et de la
biodiversité
certains nous reprocheront toujours de
ne pas aller assez vite ou assez loin
mais hier j'ai présenté nombre de
mesures qui transforme nos modes de
production de transport de consommation
de vie michel serres qui aimait nos
terroirs et qui aimait la mère qui fut
un grand penseur de l'écologie défend
des d'ailleurs une idéologie de la
courbe et non de la rupture
nous sommes convaincus nous aussi que
respecter la nature comprendre les
enjeux de notre époque c'est respecter
le temps des transformations sûr et
durable
plus que des soubresauts hâtif et
irréfléchie je ne crois pas à l'écologie
du grand soir je crois à l' écologie qui
agrège qui embarque qui change les actes
et pas du coup pas uniquement la une des
journaux
de surcroît réparer la planète en
habillement le lien social ne mène nulle
part
c'est pourquoi la seconde urgence qui
nous anime est de réduire les injustices
fiscales sociales et territoriales
la cartographie de ces injustices
coïncide d'ailleurs en partie car au
centre de la carte il ya le coeur
battant du pays la france de ce qu'on
appelle par commodité des classes
moyennes et sucker on entend qu'il
s'essouffle beaucoup de villes comme
cahors limoges des pierres sont hautains
membres'' où les abîmes reste des villes
à taille humaine dynamique mais sont
fragilisés par la déprise démographique
l'attraction des grandes métropoles et
le départ de certains services publics
notre programme action coeur de ville
contribuera bientôt à renouveler le
paysage urbain de 222 de ces villes dans
toutes nos régions
à angoulême l'ancienne clinique
sainte-marthe désaffectée depuis 1999
sera transformé en logements ainsi qu'un
îlot de cinq immeubles vacants et muret
à cahors la reconquête du centre-ville
se traduira notamment par la
construction d'un nouveau cinéma
l'accès à l'art au numérique ne doit pas
être un privilège parmi d'autres qui
fracturent est notre territoire
beaucoup de territoires ruraux se
battent s'équipant numérique valorisent
leurs atouts mais s'estiment délaissées
décroché dans la rapide transformation
du monde partout en france des femmes et
des hommes peinent à boucler leurs fins
de mois
dans leurs contributions sur la
plateforme du grand débat et qui étaient
nombreux à dénoncer le coût de la vie
que nous lisons parfois comme un coup
avec un p qui nous met à terre pour ces
hommes et ces femmes
nous voulons que les impôts pèse moins
que le travail paye mieux c'est pour eux
que nous baisserons l'impôt sur le
revenu de 5 milliards et que nous
supprimerons la totalité de la taxe
d'habitation pour les 12 millions de
foyers qui correspondent à la première
tranche de l'ir rpp cela représente un
gain de 350 euros en moyenne pour les 5
millions de foyers de la tranche
suivante ce sera en moyenne 180 euros au
total les impôts des ménages prêts
seront de près de 27 milliards d'euros
durant ce quinquennat
ces baisses seront votées dans le projet
de loi de finances et seront effectives
dès le 1er janvier 2020 vous mesurez
autant que moi
le coût de ces mesures rien n'est jamais
gratuit rien je transigeraient
malaisément avec l'idée de transmettre à
mes enfants mes dettes y compris celles
qui viennent de mes parents
c'est pourquoi l'annnonce de ces baisses
d'impôts exige une discipline
il n'y a pas d'autre solution pour
financer les baisses d'impôts que de
trouver des économies et de travailler
plus nous avons en matière de finances
publiques
un bilan qui nous donne une légitimité
en 2017
au prix d'un effort remarqué et contesté
parfois dès notre arrivée nous avons
enfin ramener la dette le déficit sous
la barre des 3% en 2018
nous avons stabilisé la dette et je le
dis mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
pour la première fois depuis 40 ans les
dépenses publiques ont reculé en volume
ces chiffres certains considèrent qu'ils
sont insuffisants
mais je les renverrait à leur propre
bilan
les gouvernements
auxquelles ils ont participé où les
majorités qui ont soutenu de tel
gouvernement ont elles aussi fortement
augmenté les dépenses publiques et je
les renverrait à leurs contradictions
car après avoir promis 500 mille
suppressions de fonctionnaires ou la
suppression de l'intégralité des emplois
aidés ils n'ont pas été les derniers à
critiquer les mesures courageuses que
nous avons prises en la matière en
parallèle de la nécessaire maîtrise des
dépenses publiques
il nous faut travailler davantage
revaloriser le travail implique de
rénover profondément notre système
d'assurance chômage
le plein emploi n'est ni une utopie ni
un néologisme allemand c'est un objectif
réaliste auquel on a trop longtemps
renoncé faute de vision et de courage
avec la ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud nous détaillerons la semaine
prochaine la manière dont nous voulons
réformer l'assurance chômage pour
inciter au retour à l'emploi durable
nous voulons responsabilité
responsabiliser les entreprises qui
abusent des contrats courts à travers un
mécanisme de bonus malus sur les cinq à
dix secteurs qui utilisent le plus dans
notre économie
ces contrats courts nous voulons
permettre aux démissionnaires et aux
travailleurs indépendants de se lancer
dans de nouveaux projets nous voulons
que le travail paye toujours mieux que
l'inactivité
nous assumons la dégressivité de
l'indemnisation pour les salariés dont
les revenus sont les plus élevés car ce
sont ceux qui retrouvent le plus
facilement un emploi
cette affaire d'équité et de justice
dans une société de liberté et de
responsabilité
tout cela n'a de sens mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que si nous
renforçons l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi
nous y dédieront une part des économies
dégagées et nous associerons les
partenaires sociaux et les acteurs de
terrain pour trouver des solutions
concrètes et efficaces
c'est l'objet même de la mobilisation
territoriales que le gouvernement
conduit avec les élus locaux et les
partenaires sociaux
retisser le lien social implique aussi
de renforcer la solidarité entre les
générations
nous le savons tous nous l'expérimentons
dans nos vies personnelles
la dépendance est l'un des aspects pas
le plus réjouissant de cette révolution
de la longévité qui bouleverse
silencieusement de société nous avons
trop tarder
toulouse-ii confrontés parce que les
budgets en jeu sans ig hantait sq
peut-être aussi par une forme de déni
c'est évidemment notre regard qui doit
changer
celui que nous portons sur la place des
personnes âgées dans notre société nous
devons accompagner leur volonté de
vieillir à domicile entendre les
familles qui supporte une charge
financière importante et qui sont prises
en tenaille entre leurs obligations
d'enfants et celle de parents voir de
grands parents entendre les personnels
dont le métier doit être revalorisé et
imaginer des solutions qui s'applique
dans un monde qui vieillit certes dans
une france qui vit mais dans une france
qui se transforme et où les solidarités
familiales sont très différentes dans la
façon dont elles se mettent en oeuvre
aujourd'hui de ce qu'elle était il ya 50
ou il ya 60 ans nous devons donc trouver
les instruments de financement de
revalorisation d'investissement et
d'accompagnement nécessaires à adapter
notre pays à cet enjeu la ministre des
solidarités de la santé présentera à la
fin de l'année un projet de loi qui
définira la stratégie et la
programmation des moyens nécessaires
pour prendre en charge la dépendance dès
le prochain projet de loi de finances
pardon dès le prochain projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale nous
enclencheront une première étape avec
des mesures favorisant le maintien à
domicile et des investissements dans les
ehpad
cela fait dix ans que l'on parle et que
parfois l'on promet cette grande réforme
de dignité et de fraternité nous voulons
la conduire et elle constituera à n'en
pas douter un grand marqueur social de
ce quinquennat
l'autre grand défi de notre génération
c'est la mise en place d'un système
universel de retraite
le haut commissaire jean paul delevoye
après avoir engagé des consultations
très intense dès le mois de janvier 2018
présentera au mois de juillet ces
recommandations
il garantira les mêmes droits et les
mêmes règles pour tous quels que soient
les statuts
un système illisible et rarement un
système juste
ce système sera plus redistributif car
il réduira l'écart entre les pensions
les plus modestes et celle des plus
aisés il réduira l'écart entre celle des
hommes et celle des femmes et nous
serons particulièrement vigilants à ceux
qui ont exercé des métiers pénibles et
qui se retrouve parfois en situation
d'invalidité
disons la vérité aux français il faudra
travailler plus longtemps c'est une des
clés de la réussite du pays et les
français sont lucides les français sont
lucides déjà l'âge légal l'âge moyen de
départ à la retraite est supérieur à
l'âge légal parce que nos compatriotes
savent que grâce à leur travail ils
peuvent bénéficier d'une meilleure
pension et ils ont raison
nous maintiendrons donc la possibilité
d'un départ à 62 ans
mais nous définirons comme je l'aï
indiqué hier à nash d'équilibré des
incitations à travailler plus longtemps
soyons enfin lucide sur l'état financier
de nos rites de nos régimes de retraite
contrairement à ce que l'on a pu croire
il y a quelques années le système de
retraite n'est pas encore à l'équilibré
les dernières projections du conseil
d'orientation des retraites font
apparaître un besoin de financement de 9
milliards en 2020 de 2,16 milliards en
au delà le système ne reviendrait pas à
l' équilibre avant les années 2040 2050
sous des hypothèses de croissance
favorables et à cette échéance les
hypothèses de croissance sont ce
qu'elles sont cela montre la nécessité
et c'est à dire des hypothèses
cela montre la nécessité d'être
attentifs dans la construction du
système universel et de le faire sur des
bases financières solides protis et le
lien social c'est assurer l'ordre et la
sécurité dans le pays soutenir nos
forces de sécurité à l'intérieur et nos
soldats à l'extérieur retisser le lien
social c'est regarder en face les
phénomènes qui inquiète les français
pour leur montrer que nous pouvons
garder le contrôle
c'est renforcer la laïcité c'est
maîtriser les flux migratoires
j'ai annoncé que le parlement débattra
en septembre retisser le lien social
s'est renforcé un modèle qui n'est plus
toujours adaptée aux évolutions de notre
société
je pense aux nouvelles solidarités pour
les familles monoparentales aux aidants
je pense au projet de revenu universel
d'activité
qui simplifiera le système dead et
mettra un terme au scandale du non
recours je ne reviendrai pas sur les
mesures par lesquelles nous misons sur
l'égalité des chances dès le plus jeune
âge dès que commencent les
apprentissages fondamentaux miser sur
l'égalité des chances notamment dans les
quartiers c'est ce que nous faisons en
augmentant le nombre de places en crèche
en limitant le nombre d'élèves par
classe en créant des sites et éducatif
d'excellence et des campus connecter la
création d'une loi de programmation pour
la recherche qui prendra effet à partir
de 2021 et qui sera discutée en 2020
répond à cette même conviction on
n'investira jamais assez sur
l'intelligence et sur la liberté
c'est pourquoi l'une des priorités de
l'acte 2 du quinquennat sera de lutter
contre toutes les formes d'assignation à
résidence
notamment territoriale et c'est le point
que je développerai aujourd'hui devant
vous car je n'ai pas abordé hier devant
l'assemblée nationale
je voulais en sorte en quelque sorte
réservé puisque vous êtes l'émanation
des territoires des villages et des
villes de france
les 96 heures pendant lesquelles le
président de la république a échangé
avec des maires de france de grand bourg
de grands bourgtheroulde dans l'eure à
qods and encore marqueront l'histoire de
ce quinquennat
elles ont placé les maires dans la
lumière en mettant au jour ce que nous
savons leur dévouement et leur
sensibilité mais aussi leur
découragement nous ne pourrons pas
transformer le pays sans les mères sans
les élus locaux la démocratie n'est
qu'une coquille vide et que nous disent
les maires ils l'ont dit et répété il
paye le prix de baisses de dotations et
celui de la loi notre notamment qui a pu
conduire à la création
d'intercommunalité de taille xxl et à
des grandes régions qui sont parfois
encore contester et non pas encore pas
forcément contribué à rapprocher les
citoyens des lieux de décisions j'en
citerai un seul de grand-bourg tu roules
quand est-ce qu'on arrête la machine à
broyer la proximité
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jeu
j'ai peut-être mes chers collègues
oublier de citer la date à laquelle ont
été adoptés les dispositifs législatifs
que je viens de mentionner
je crois que chacun s'en souvient
parfaitement
cette exigence de proximité c'est une
rupture dans les politiques publiques
penet depuis longtemps et elle engage
autant les collectivités territoriales
que l'état s'agissant des collectivités
territoriales nous avons trois défis
d'abord conforter les maires au moment
où la crise de l'engagement est aiguë
pour la première fois pour la première
fois de nombreuses listes aux prochaines
élections municipales seront peut-être
incomplète et parfois qui sait nous
manqueront de candidats cette crise de
l'engagement nous devons y répondre
plus qu'un statut les maires veulent
d'abord un cadre clair d'exercice de
leurs mandats et plus de libertés
locales pour mieux mener leurs projets
ce cadre il doit être dans la loire pour
ne pas dépendre des situations locales
il doit garantir une véritable formation
une protection juridique un
accompagnement professionnel et familial
le sénat a déjà formulé des propositions
nous les reprendrons très largement
il s'agit aussi de lutter contre ce
sentiment de dépossession des mères et
de refaire droit aux libertés locales
des marges de manoeuvre doivent être
recherchées sur les effets de seuil qui
pénalise bien souvent les communes de
petite taille sur le renforcement des
pouvoirs de police du maire sur la
surpression d'obligations ou de contrôle
qui sont parfois superflus il s'agit
enfin de retrouver un équilibre au sein
du bloc local entre les communes et
leurs intercommunalités
ces dernières sont indispensables pour
porter les projets collectifs
c'est bien souvent à l'échelle d'une
intercommunalité que se gère les
questions d'économie circulaire de
réseaux de logements de mixité sociale
d'infrastructures et de mobilité
mais force est de constater que si le
maire est toujours à portée
d'engueulades pour reprendre
l'expression chère au président du sénat
il n'a plus toujours à portée de main
les leviers de décision et d'action
les récentes faire les récentes réformes
dont la loi notre ont parfois créer des
irritations qu'il convient aujourd'hui
de corriger autour du triptyque
compétences périmètre gouvernance j'ai
demandé à sébastien lecornu de
travailler avec le sénat avec l'ensemble
des présidents des groupes du sénat et
avec les associations d'élus pour
déposer avant la fin du mois de juillet
un projet de loi engagement
proximité conformément à l'article 39 de
la constitution votre haute assemblée en
sera saisi en premier dès la rentrée le
deuxième défi c'est de préparer un
nouvel acte de décentralisation
le président de la république en
conclusion du grand débat nous a invités
à la fois à achever les transferts de
compétences déjà entamés en supprimant
les doublons et à examiner de nouveaux
transferts dans les domaines du logement
des transports de la transition
écologique
j'ai chargé chaque ligne bourreau de
préparer cette importante réforme
dans un premier temps d'ici juillet la
ministre recevra l'ensemble des
associations
d'abord séparément puis tous ensemble en
associant les parlementaires à partir de
la rentrée de septembre dans chaque
région
ce dialogue se poursuivra localement
chaque préfet de région sera le garant
dans le cadre des conférences
territoriales de l'action publique qui
réunissent tous les élus l'état fixera
un cadre mais dans chaque région nous
ouvriront la voie à la différenciation
pour définir avec chaque territoire une
réponse adaptée sur mesure dans le cadre
d'un droit clair mais adaptable
c'est la voie que nous avons choisie
avec la bretagne ou avec les deux
départements du bas-rhin et du haut-rhin
qui formeront bientôt la collectivité
européenne d'alsace c'est la voie que
nous avons choisie pour la compétence
rsa avec la guyane et mayotte ou encore
la réunion c'est aussi bien sur la voie
que nous avons choisie pour la corse
la révision constitutionnelle consacre
sa spécificité et je me rendrai début
juillet certaines des évolutions qui
émergeront de ces consultations locales
pourront être mises en oeuvre à droit
constant c'est à dire sans attendre
d'autres nécessiteront d'adapter la loi
elles viendront nourrir un projet de loi
décentralisation et différenciation que
jacqueline gourault présentera à la fin
du premier semestre 2020 le cadre sera
donc définie avant les échéances
électorales de 2021 pour y arriver
et parce que la situation au fil des
réformes successives est devenu
compliqué il faut partir de principes
clairs se rappeler par le président de
la république
d'abord la proximité voire la
subsidiarité
quel est le bon échelon le plus en
capacité de répondre à la mise en oeuvre
des politiques publiques ou de conduire
certains investissements et ce bon
échelon n'est pas toujours partout le
même
ensuite la responsabilité politique on
ne peut plus continuer à détacher les
compétences et une fille nés les
résultats des élections en votant pour
un maire le citoyen c'est très bien cela
engage son vote en votant pour le
président de la république le citoyen
c'est très bien c'est pourquoi son vote
s'engage entre les deux reconnaissons
que c'est parfois encore un peu plus
flou enfin qui décident paye et qui paye
commande mais qui commanda sud c'est
toute la question des ressources des
collectivités
et c'est le troisième défi nous devons
être capable de préciser aux élus avant
le prochain mandat municipal
le cadre financier dans lequel ils
exerceront leurs fonctions depuis deux
ans la dgf est stable globalement et
nous avons augmenté la péréquation pour
les communes rurales et urbaines les
plus fragiles nous préserverons cet
acquis s'agissant de la fiscalité nous
inscrirons dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2020 les modalités de
suppression complète de la taxe
d'habitation et de sa compensation
depuis le 2017 grâce aux travaux menés
en particulier par alain richard
les enjeux et les options de cette
réforme sont connus ils ont été
largement débattues le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs fait connaître dès le mois de
juillet 2018 les principes qui lui
paraissent les plus appropriées aucune
commune ne perdra de ressources
chaque contribuable bénéficiera à plein
de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
aux termes de la réforme la fiscalité
locale devrait être plus clair pour le
contribuable
c'est sur ces bases que gérald darmanin
et jacqueline gourault reprendront dès
la semaine prochaine les concertations
avec les associations collectivités
territoriales je souhaite que ces
concertations soit le plus approfondi
possible la pente limité
c'est aussi la sphère de l'état
rapprocher la décision des territoires
et de nos concitoyens passe par une
action méthodique de déconcentration
tous azimuts la décision individuelle
prises au niveau national doit devenir
l'exception est l'exception la plus rare
nous avons engagé un travail et je le
dis mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un travail de fourmi
6pour décision après décision se poser
cette question qu'est ce qui empêche que
cette décision puisse être prise au
niveau local ce travail aboutit à ce que
d'ici la fin de l'année plus des 95% des
décisions individuelles seront
effectivement prises dans les
territoires tout au long du second
semestre 2010 9
nous allons publier les textes
réglementaires qui met en musique cette
ambition il nous faut ensuite inversé
les logiques à l'oeuvre depuis 15 ans là
où on a concentré les forces au niveau
régional je souhaite renforcer le niveau
départemental et quand tous les réseaux
de services publics se sont
progressivement rétracter je souhaite
reconstruire un vrai maillage cohérent
de présence des services publics
j'ai signé hier l'instruction qui engage
la réorganisation des services
territoriaux de l'état pour supprimer
les doublons clarifie les
responsabilités mettre en cohérence nos
priorités avec nos organisations et
comme je l'évoquais à l'instant pour
mettre les préfets de département en
capacité d'agir au plus près des
territoires construire avec les conseils
départementaux le service public de
l'insertion déployer le service national
universel accompagner les petites
collectivités dans leurs projets
d'ingénierie
nous aurons aussi pour cela de nouveaux
outils je pense à la banque des
territoires qui a déjà commencé à
déployer ses financements
je pense à la une c'est et qui va
progressivement jouer un rôle majeur
dans la cohésion des territoires
cette instruction et fixent également le
cadre pour superviser la réorganisation
des implantations de service public
le président de la république l'a
annoncé dans sa conférence de presse du
25 avril plus de fermetures d'écoles ou
d'hôpital sans accord du maire le
corollaire de cela c'est la nécessité de
mettre fin à des stratégies de
réorganisation sur les territoires
qu'ils sont
les coordonnées entre les ministères par
contre les ministères entre eux et entre
les ministères et les opérateurs
dorénavant les préfets de région
animeront avec les préfets de
département les chefs de services
régionaux de détail l'ensemble des
patrons d'opérateurs une instance
spécifiquement dédiés à des
réorganisations pour construire une
vraie stratégie la partager avec
l'ensemble des élus locaux et acteurs
professionnels concernés la dernière
brique de cette stratégie de proximité
des services publics
c'est bien entendu france service l'idée
simple construire un guichet unique avec
des agents polyvalents capables de
répondre aux besoins de nos concitoyens
dans leurs démarches administratives
la réalisation nous le savons est plus
complexe
depuis plusieurs années les maisons de
services au public ont tenté d'apporter
cette forme de réponse avec un succès
variable
quel que soit l'engagement de celles et
ceux qui font vivre ces structures nous
devons changer d'échelle et changer de
logique partir des besoins de nos
concitoyens partir des besoins des
territoires dépassé les frontières des
administrations oublier que nous sommes
l'état le département la ceppm ou la caf
ça veut dire des choses simples des
horaires d'ouverture élargis des agents
polyvalents forme et capable d'offrir
immédiatement des réponses ou
d'accompagner vers la bonne porte
d'entrée dès le 1er janvier 2020
je souhaite que 300 maisons france
services soient pleinement opérationnels
et le président de la république comme
le gouvernement se sont engagés à ce que
d'ici la fin du quinquennat nous
puissions disposer au moins d'une de ses
maisons à août à haut niveau de service
par canton j'ai commencé mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs part évoqué
l'urgence climatique avant de m'attarder
sur l'urgence de proximité mais ces deux
urgences coïncide en grande partie comme
le prouve l'exemple des outre mer depuis
deux ans on a bien vu que nos
compatriotes ultramarins sont aux
avant-postes des cyclones ou de
l'élévation des océans causée par le
dérèglement climatique
nous en sommes tellement conscient
depuis le début du quinquennat que cette
double préoccupation définit les cinq
objets pardon les cinq objectifs du
livre bleu outremer
rendu public le 28 juin 2018 nous avons
repris ses cinq objectifs dans la
feuille de route du gouvernement pour
les outre-mer 0 vulnérabilités zero
exclusion zéro déchet zéro carbone zéro
paulo agricole j'évoquais tout à l'heure
l'impératif de différenciation intégrer
les spécificités de chaque territoire
pour adapter nos politiques publiques
c'est le réflexe outre-mer que nous
avons musclées depuis le début du
quinquennat
je voudrais enfin mentionner la
situation spécifique de la nouvelle
calédonie dont certains simplifiée
combien elle me tient à coeur
nous sommes engagés à respecter la
signature de l'état sur l'accord de
nouméa et je continuerai à privilégier
la voie de nouméa c'est à dire celle du
dialogue et des résultats rendus en
toute transparence
lorsque le cycle électoral récemment
engagée aura été conclu je retrouverai
avec plaisir les représentants des
partis politiques de nouvelle-calédonie
les représentants des forces politiques
pour évoquer avec eux la suite
dernier point que j'aborderai ce matin
la réforme des institutions
le président de la république a proposé
aux français de réviser la constitution
du 4 octobre 58 pour l'adapter aux
bouleversements de notre démocratie il
ya un an nous avions présenté un projet
de loi constitutionnelle et deux projets
de loi complémentaire organique et
ordinaire
les circonstances ont reporté leurs
examens mais ces derniers mois nous ont
confortés dans la détermination à
rénover notre démocratie représentative
s'engager dans la révision
constitutionnelle sans l'accord du sénat
n'est tout simplement pas possible et
n'aurait donc aucun sens c'est pourquoi
depuis un an nous avons discuté et
essayer de trouver un compromis
les textes que nous nous apprêtons à
déposer sur le bureau de l'assemblée
nationale reprennent le coeur des
engagements du président de la
république y compris
l'inscription de la lutte contre le
changement climatique à l'article 1er de
notre constitution
ils sont recentrés sur trois priorités
les territoires avec l'autorisation de
la différenciation l'assouplissement du
cadre relatif à la corse ainsi qu outre
mer la participation citoyenne avec un
nouveau titre dans la constitution la
transformation du 16e en conseil de la
participation citoyenne la possibilité
de former des conventions de citoyens
tirés au sort
la facilitation du recours au référendum
d'initiative partagée et l'extension du
champ de l'article 11 la justice enfin
avec l'indépendance du parquet et la
suppression de la cour de justice de la
république
en parallèle des gestes ont été faits
pour parvenir à un consensus
les dispositions relatives au
fonctionnement des assemblées ont été
retirés nous avons considéré qu'il
appartenait aux assemblées elles mêmes
de décider de leurs efforts les
dispositions relatives au cumul des
mandats dans le temps ont été assouplies
pour en exclure les maires de communes
de petite taille et prévoir une engrais
une entrée en vigueur progressive
le président de la république a accepté
de revoir sa proposition de baisse d'un
tiers du nombre de parlementaires pour
viser une réduction d'un quart qui
permettent une juste représentation
territoriale et l'introduction d'une
dose significative de proportionnelle à
l'assemblée
concrètement aujourd'hui il me semble
que nous ne sommes pas éloigné d'un
accord sur le projet de loi
constitutionnelle mais pas sur le projet
de loi organique et en particulier mais
pas seulement sur la question du nombre
de parlementaires le sénat a été très
clair sur le fait qu'il n'y aurait
d'accord sur rien s'il n'y avait pas
d'accord sur tout et c'est parfaitement
respectable comme est parfaitement
respectable je crois la position du
gouvernement qui ne souhaitent pas à
mobiliser du temps parlementaire si in
fine et ils s'exposaient aux désaccords
du cerf nous ne renonçons donc pas nos
ambitions qui nous le pensons sont
conformes à la demande de nos
concitoyens nous attendrons le moment
propice et la manifestation de volonté
du ciel nous pouvons aussi voté
seulement la proportionnelle à
l'assemblée sans changer le nombre de
députés chacun jugera dans quelle mesure
il tient à résoudre les points de
désaccord qui demeure chacun jugera dans
quelle mesure ils considèrent que cette
réforme constitutionnelle peut être un
instrument de renouveau démocratique et
de réconciliation nationale nous sommes
prêts et nous sommes ouverts mais trois
textes sont prêts cette réforme
institutionnelle nous ne pourrons pas là
réussir sans vous mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
je le disais l'assemblée l'époque exige
une forme de dépassement en vous
demandant d'approuver cette déclaration
de politique
général je ne vous demande ni un blanc
seing pour la politique de mon
gouvernement
ni évidemment quelconque ralliement la
majorité je vous demande de dépasser des
clivages et des différences que je
respecte mais qui ne me semble plus
aujourd'hui les plus importants je vous
ai exposé une feuille de route
d'ambition écologique de justice sociale
de valorisation du travail de
renforcement des maires de réforme de
l'état beaucoup de ces thèmes me semble
largement consensuel sur ses bancs je
forme le voeu qu'il n'aurait eu ce
qu'ils nous réunissent et qui nous
permettent de nous dépasser et je sais
que sur chacun des textes en particulier
au delà de la déclaration générale le
travail accompli entre le gouvernement
et le sénat sera riche et sérieux pour
toutes ces raisons j'ai l'honneur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs en application
des dispositions de l'article 49 alinéa
4 de la constitution de vous demander
l'approbation de cette déclaration de
politique générale
et je vous remercie monsieur le premier
ministre
nous allons revenir mes chers collègues
vos interventions des orateurs des gros
politique dans le débat
la parole est d'abord au président hervé
marseille et la diminue il avait la
parole monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues la vie politique est
faite de cycles
ce que nous vivons depuis quelques
années sont de plus en plus rapides
imprévisible et violent cela nous
appellent tous à beaucoup d'humilité
cette double déclaration de politique
générale fait suite à deux années
d'exercice du pouvoir et un scrutin
européen riche d'enseignements notamment
après des mois de crise que nous avons
traversée
quel a été le message des électeurs
une majorité a d'abord dit oui à
l'europe qu'elle soit une europe
présenté par on marche par l'est
républicain par les centristes par les
écologistes ou les socialistes ou et une
europe qui protège ses habitants ou et
une europe qui sait qu'elle doit se
réformer en se renforçant
les français ont ensuite dit oui aux
réformes en tout cas la liste soutenue
par le président de la république n'a
pas enregistré de désaveu manifeste
d'ailleurs si son score est proche de
celui de l'élection présidentielle cela
était possible par l'apport de voix
nouvelles venus notamment du centre
droit ces électeurs ont salué
l'engagement et le pragmatisme du
gouvernement et condamner les
oppositions stériles
enfin les électeurs ont clairement
affirmé leur forte préoccupation
environnementale
ces constats monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez souhaité
naturellement qu'ils inspirent la
nouvelle étape de votre action
après vos propos d'hier et de ce matin
engageant l'acte ii du quinquennat je
distinguerai la forme et le fond sur la
forme nous ne pouvons que saluer votre
volonté d'améliorer les méthodes de
travail en particulier avec le parlement
et les élus locaux un cycle retour
à une répartition des rôles plus
conforme à la constitution entre le
président de la république et vous même
sur le fond vous avez fixé les objectifs
et le calendrier des prochains mois vous
avez présenté ou confirmés les réformes
que vous envisagez sans les énumérer
sans y revenir je constate que nous
n'avons pas à leur égard d'opposition de
principe ou de crispation sur aucune
d'entre elles parfois même nous les
appelons de nos voeux et pour certaines
de longue date
je crois que le pays les attend et je
crois que le pays en a besoin
brièvement jean commenterai 2 nous
partageons évidemment l'objectif de
simplification du système de retraite
nous partageons la philosophie générale
d'un système plus équitable c'est
naturel puisque cela est conforme à
notre proposition historique de
transformation vers un régime par points
nous serons toutefois vigilant bien sûr
sur le maintien des niveaux de pension
et nous veillerons à ce que les règles
et les droits des familles ne soit pas
altérée nous souhaitons aussi une
gouvernance équilibrée entre l'état les
partenaires sociaux et la représentation
nationale concernant la révision de la
constitution
vous l'avez longuement abordé disons le
clairement nous souhaitons le bon
aboutissement de cette révision
mon groupe comme le sénat j'en suis
certain est décidé à jouer pleinement
son rôle de constituants sans manoeuvres
dilatoires sans arrière pensée sans
proposition autre que constructive
d'autant plus que le nouveau projet
abandonne nous l'avait confirmé la
refonte de la procédure parlementaire
qui pouvait appeler de nombreuses
réserves concernant les textes organique
et ordinaire associés la question du
nombre de parlementaires pour populaire
qu'elle soit ne constitue pas me
semble-t-il la bonne entrée en matière
la crise des gilets jaunes la montre et
l'angle incontournable et bien sûr celui
de la proximité
cette réforme doit être absolument
maintenir le lien entre les citoyens et
leurs élus nationaux sauf à délégitimer
un peu plus la démocratie représentative
je doute que nous puissions nous offrir
ce luxe en dépit de nos approches
différentes notre divergence se résume
désormais à peu de chose vous l'avez
rappelé comment raisonnablement
l'invoquer pour justifier le report de
l'examen de ces textes importants en
revanche ne comprenons pas votre
insistance à porter atteinte à une des
spécificités du sénat la permanence de
la haute assemblée associé à son
renouvellement partiel
principe d'ailleurs constitutionnel
éléments de démocratie apaisée
je suis convaincu que vous nous entendre
et d'autant plus facilement que cette
disposition n'a pas d'incidence sur l'
architecture de la révision monsieur le
premier ministre nous avons vocation à
accompagner les réformes que vous
présentez voire à les soutenir pour
autant à nos yeux ce soutien ne
constitue pas bien sûr un alignement un
soutien ne peut pas être unilatérale
il se conçoit dans le cadre d'un
dialogue responsable entre élus soucieux
de l'intérêt général au cours des deux
années qui se sont écoulées nous avons
maintes fois regretter l'impossibilité
d'un dialogue plus fécond avec les
ministres présents dans l'hémicycle et
l'attitude souvent fermé de la majorité
à l'assemblée nationale j'ai compris que
cela allait évoluer changer tant mieux
mais nous avons d'autres interrogations
nous sommes ici vous le savez
l'assemblée des collectivités des
territoires
je vous donne acte vous l'avez rappelé
que ce n'est pas vous qui avait engagé
la baisse des dotations
ce n'est pas vous qui avez organisé
c'est gigantesque bazar qui ont pour
noms map tam nôtres malheureusement
c'est vous qui avez inventé ce mistigri
de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation est vous qui avez donné le
sentiment parfois d'un regard distancié
et cliniques sur cette france éloigné
des métropoles depuis deux ans les
signaux
se sont multipliées qui ont forgé
l'impression que collectivités et
territoires étaient les parents pauvres
des politiques publiques voire qu'il
faisait l'objet d'un certain dédain
jacopin il va falloir transformer
l'essai du grand débat et convaincre
définitivement nos territoires qu'ils
sont écoutés mais j'ai entendu vos
propositions et je ne doute pas qu'elles
seront largement comprise et en attendus
dans les territoires nous sommes
également la chambre de la continuité du
temps long nous nous souvenons ainsi de
l'engagement du président de la
république de réduire lorsqu'il était
candidat la dépense publique
en réalité nous n'avons jamais autant
dépensé et rien ne laisse entrevoir un
retournement de façon structurelle nous
le savons la démographie exercera vous
l'avez rappelé une pression à la hausse
sur les dépenses de retraite et de santé
il reste une inconnue le financement des
économies des mesures engagées par don
ou des économies à réaliser
vous y avez fait largement allusion
cette inconnue est souvent connue elle
s'appelle le déficit
si nous sommes attachés à la baisse de
la dépense publique ce n'est pas par
fétichisme mais parce que sont en jeu
notre indépendance et le fardeau que
nous laisserons à nos enfants nous leur
laissons déjà un monde au bord de
l'abyme nous ne pouvons pas en plus leur
laisser une corde autour du cou
vous auriez cependant tort de ne pas le
faire un peu les autres l'ont fait avant
vous mais je reconnais qu'au moins le
gouvernement ne fait pas semblant
nous ne pouvons pas faire semblant nous
de ne pas voir et de ce point de vue
malheureusement les gouvernements se
succèdent et emploie les mêmes recettes
enfin le scrutin européen a constitué
monsieur le premier ministre un
révélateur concernant les priorités
écologiques
cette révélation succède au spectacle
plus ou moins enjoué d'une course
poursuite entamée il ya quelques années
la course a commencé avec nicolas hulot
sur la ligne de départ
mais de même qu'une hirondelle ne fait
pas le printemps monsieur hulot à lui
seul ne pouvait pas faire le
verdissement son départ a d'ailleurs
prouvé qu'ils n'étaient pas l'arbre qui
cachait la forêt mais plutôt un palmier
qui masquait le désert la course
a repris avant les élections européennes
elle se poursuit aujourd'hui avec ce
qu'on appelle l'accélération écologique
cette accélération vous la traduisez par
des mesures auxquelles personne ne
saurait s'opposer qui peut être
favorable au gaspi au gaspillage qui
peut être favorable aux plastiques dans
les administrations qui peut encore
défendre les niches anti écologique
évidemment personne par delà ces
annonces
vous avez annoncé des projets importants
des projets de textes et c'est avec
impatience
évidemment que nous les attendons notre
premier combat est celui de la
bibliodiversité vous avez décidé
d'abandonner le projet de la montagne
d'or quand on sait ce que chaque mètre
carré de forêt vierge représente ce
n'est pas rien quant aux plastiques il
est l'un des fléaux qui menacent toutes
les espèces
vous avez décidé d'agir mais uniquement
sur la consommation alors que la
production est au coeur du problème
les industriels ont fait le choix du
plastique pour des raisons économiques
il va nous falloir les contraindre
intelligemment et il faut que les
alternatives existent le second combat
décisif est celui de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
nous adhérons pleinement à l'idée que la
meilleure énergie est celle qu'on ne
consomme pas nous soutiendrons donc
votre plan de révision des aides à
l'arrêt visite à la rénovation
énergétique
une réforme qui s'inscrit dans la droite
ligne du grenelle de l'environnement de
jean louis borloo
celle d'une écologie incitatives et non
punitive et moralisatrice mais compte
tenu des besoins énergétiques à venir
l'efficience ne fera pas tout une
question essentielle se pose peut-on à
la fois sortir des énergies fossiles et
réduire la part du nucléaire
simultanément nous espérons que l'examen
prochain du plan énergie climat répondre
à cette question
même en roulant sans l'éolien offshore
il sera difficile d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone
il nous faut ainsi clarifié notre
politique énergétique faute de quoi
l'accélération écologique pardon mais
plafonnera vite à 80 km/heure sur le
pénaliste
monsieur le premier ministre à
mi-quinquennat vous nous demandez de
soutenir votre déclaration et plus
largement l'action gouvernementale c'est
rare et au nom de mon groupe je salue
cette volonté d' écoute du sénat
puisqu'il n'est pas courant que le
premier ministre vienne ici solliciter
la confiance et parlait spécifiquement
d'un sujet qui nous tient à coeur les
territoires notre groupe valorise la
constance les deux années écoulées l'ont
démontré sur les ordonnances travail la
réforme ferroviaire la loi pacte là
l'homme la loi santé nous avons assumé
notre cohérence historique
le groupe centriste souhaite unanimement
la réussite de l'action du gouvernement
de toute façon le pays n'a pas d'autre
choix pour échapper aux des montils
démange
c'est pour cela que dans les mois à
venir vous nous trouverez à vos côtés
chaque fois qu'il s'agira de promouvoir
les réformes utiles au pays
comme vous nous avez également trouvé à
vos côtés avec beaucoup d'autres en
décembre lorsque la république semblait
en difficulté
il fallait éteindre l'incendié allumé
par les gilet jaune monsieur le premier
ministre est donc en fonction de ses
observations que nombreux seimat
sénateurs de mon groupe voteront
favorablement la proposition vous leur
faites les autres s'expriment ont par
leur abstention une retenue
bienveillante
je vous remercie merci
la parole est au président claude
malhuret pour le groupe les indépendants
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre et chers collègues nous
vous écoutons monsieur le premier
ministre au moment particulier est grave
ou un parti extrémiste vient d'arriver
en tête d'une élection nationale
encore avant nous la chance si l'on peut
dire en france où l'on apprend dès
l'école à révérer robespierre qu'à la
différence des autres pays où le
populisme et seulement d'extrême droite
il est chez nous partager en deux rangs
dans les chiffres en apparence moins
alarmant mais en apparence seulement
ce qui est incompréhensible c'est que
pour réclamer plus de démocratie des
électeurs votent pour le parti recorman
du népotisme et de l'opacité dirigé
depuis 50 ans par le père puis la fille
puis bientôt la nièce de pour dénoncer
un système qu'ils estiment corrompus ils
votent pour le parti recorman des rendez
vous judiciaires et que pour redresser
l'économie ils votent pour une
dirigeante qui a fait la preuve de son
incompétence absolu en la matière lors
de la présidentielle
napoléon disait en politique une
absurdité n'est pas un obstacle
nous le constatons tous les jours
si les partis extrêmes ne représente
plus que 30 % aujourd'hui ce qui est
tout de même considérable contre 40% il
y a deux ans c'est grâce à
l'effondrement du lider minimo de la
france soumise à cuba le corps sacré
auto claironné lors d'une perquisition
par l'homme au micro entre les temps la
disqualifier jusque chez ses proches
les casquettes d'exclusion ont délié les
langues et nous savons maintenant
comment avec son égérie ils dirigeaient
leur groupuscule après la défaite les
jeunes loups du parti estiment que leur
tour est venu du remue ménage en
perspective quand on sait que plusieurs
d'entre eux sont le genre de personne
qui entre derrière vous dans une porte à
tambour et qui en ressortent les
premiers
et malgré cela ce qui est incroyable ce
n'est pas que les filles soient passés
de 20 % 1 6%
mais qui lit encore en 2010 9 6 % des
français qui votent pour la révolution
bolivarienne
le deuxième coup de tonnerre de cette
élection et que la gauche démocratique
et la droite républicaine à la tête du
pays pendant 60 ans et obtenu ensemble
moins de 15% des veaux en ce qui
concerne le ps l'explication qui risque
de ne pas plaire et je m'en excuse me
semble largement partagé françois
hollande a mené avec constance une
politique qui ressemble à celle d'une
enseigne que j'ai vu l'autre jour sur la
route resteront ouvriers cuisine
bourgeoise
de l'autre côté nicolas sarkozy déclaré
le 26 mai dernier à 20h30
il n'y a plus de droite dans notre pays
je trouve le jugement expéditif nous
avons tous qu'il est rare qu'on meurt en
politique comme le dit un proverbe
cambodgien
quand l'eau monte les poissons mangent
les fourmis quand l'eau descend les
fourmis mangent les poissons
je ne crois pas que la droite soit morte
mais elle est partie elle a commencé à
partir le jour où quelques-uns de ses
dirigeants ont décidé que la reconquête
passer par l'adoption des idées les plus
raides et qu'ils ont cessé de tenir
compte des minoritaires le parti mon
parti ne pouvait alors que s'effeuiller
comme un artichaut une feuille à la
défaite de 2012 une feuille au match de
boxe copé fillon une feuille lors du
refus de choisir entre le pen et macron
au deuxième tour de la présidentielle
une feuille aux européennes une fois la
dernière feuille parti le 26 mai au soir
la droite s'est aperçu qu'un million de
ses électeurs n'avaient pas voter pour
son candidat mais pour celles dans
marche et 500 milles pour le front
national
pendant toute la campagne les
adversaires des manuels macro l'ont
accusé de prendre l'élection en otage en
réduisant son enjeu un affrontement
entre progressistes et populiste il
n'avait pas tort mais s'il n'avait pas
compris c'est que ce n'était pas
seulement un slogan de campagne
c'était aussi une réalité lorsque
presque tous les pays de l'est de
l'europe plus l'italie sont dirigés par
des populistes lorsqu'ils font 15 à 30%
partout en europe de l'ouest
lorsqu'on est entouré de poutine verdone
ou de clearing ping il est temps pour
les démocrates d'affronter les
populistes et non de leur courir après
le monde est devenu dangereux
[Applaudissements]
le monde est devenu dangereux et
compliquée avant vous étiez de gauche du
centre ou de droite et vous votiez en
conséquence cette grille contrairement à
ce qu'on dit n'a pas été remplacé par
l'opposition démocrate populis mais il
ya désormais deux axes de lecture l'axé
gauche-droite et lax démocrate populiste
je partage l'analyse du président sur ce
point mais je préfère de loin le terme
de démocrates à celui de progressistes
temps j'ai vu dans ma vie se produire de
catastrophes au nom du progrès la 10e la
liste renaissance est arrivé 2e le 26
mai mais vous êtes presque le seul à
l'avoir fait remarquer monsieur le
premier ministre
sa déroute était tellement près dit que
le reste du monde semble persuadée
qu'elle a gagné je suppose que vous ne
vous en plaignez pas mais si j'insiste
sur ce point c'est qui me paraît
important que quelqu'un et vous n'êtes
pas n'importe qui garde la tête froide
depuis quinze jours certains cris de
victoire un peu bruyant certaines
injonctions un peu appuyé certains
appellent un peu martiaux ne sont
peut-être pas la meilleure façon de
préparer l'avenir et de rassembler
vous vous rester lucide et c'est à
saluer l'acte 1 du quinquennat a permis
des réformes importantes la sncf le code
du travail l'école de la confiance et
d'autres la majorité du sénat les a
souvent soutenu souvent amende est aussi
l'acteur a aussi été marquée par une
grave crise sociale parce que la
disruption on peut trouver ça sympa mais
ce n'est pas toujours la vie de ceux qui
sont disrupt et vous êtes venus
aujourd'hui nous annoncer l'acte ii ici
même il y a deux mois je disais la
conclusion du grand débat c'est un peu
une lettre au père noël
le président a promis d'en tenir compte
et c'est heureux mais il va falloir
aussi pour une part qui lui résiste
c'est la raison pour laquelle la phrase
la plus importante de votre discours à
mes yeux c'est constance et cohérence
dans l'action
elle va susciter deux sortes de
réactions ceux qui diront que vous
n'avez rien entendu qu'il faut d'urgence
faire marche arrière et les autres c'est
mon cas qui vous diront que c'est en
restant immobile qui ont fait le plus de
faux pas vous nous annoncez une société
de la confiance et de la justice lever
les freins à l'emploi libérer des
énergies renforcer les collectivités
territoriales et décentralisé faciliter
la mobilité sociale renforcer l'égalité
entre les territoires qu'ils soient
métropolitain ou ultramarins redéfinir
le périmètre de l'état et vous avez
commencé par cela tout faire pour
laisser à nos enfants une planète
vivable
il n'y a rien dans tout cela qu'ils ne
puissent être approuvée mais qui doit
l'être avec vigilance car au delà de ce
que vous nous avez dit il y a deux ou
trois choses que nous aurions aimé
entendent ou tout au moins entendre plus
précisément des assurances si frais sur
le nom dérapage des finances publiques
dans la mise en oeuvre de ces réformes
des précisions sur le mécano fiscales
qui ne nous semble pas abouti et qui ne
nous rend pas certain que vous arriverez
deux siècles après à faire mentir
l'adage de benjamin franklin
il n'y a que deux chose certaine dans la
vie la mort et les impôts
quant à la baisse quant à la baisse des
effectifs de la fonction publique
elle ne semble plus si urgent ce qui
nous fait craindre que l'administration
continue d'être ce qui se rapproche le
plus de la vie éternelle
la réforme constitutionnelle repose
avant tout sur les engagements
réciproques et la loyauté de trois
personnes qui avaient beaucoup travaillé
et beaucoup échangé le président de la
république le président du sénat et le
premier ministre vous le savez je suis
de ceux qui pensent que ces engagements
auraient été tenus après avoir mobilisé
beaucoup d'énergie elle semble devoir
rester un certain temps dans le cloud
comme on dit aujourd'hui je lui laisse
donc nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler
lorsqu elle redescendra du ciel je
premier ministre un peu groupe très
majoritairement approuvera votre
discours de politique générale merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
madame dominique estrosi sassone pour
les républicains avaient la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues je
voudrais tout d'abord vous demander de
bien vouloir excuser notre président du
groupe
le président bruno retailleau qui
malheureusement ne peut être parmi nous
ce matin il est retenu dans son
département aux sables d'olonne pour
l'hommage national aux sauveteurs de la
snsm qui ont péris en mer vendredi
dernier
[Applaudissements]
nous sortons d'une séquence électorale
intense
les uns en sortent satisfaits d'autres
un peu moins
un peu moins beaucoup encore moins pour
autant monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
comptons bien continuer à défendre nos
convictions sereinement mais fermement
sereinement car la politique ce n'est
pas la guerre nous ne voyons sur les
bancs du gouvernement
aucun ennemi nous nous désolons même d'y
voir siéger
certains de nos ânes ce que vous tendiez
la main au maire c'est votre droit que
quelques-uns la saisisse c'est leur
choix mais que certains tape sur les
doigts de ceux qui auraient l'impudence
de ne pas faire de même
cela est inacceptable
les élus locaux ne sont les obligés de
personnes les seuls devant lesquels ils
doivent répondre ce n'est ni vous ni
nous ce sont leurs administrés et
puisque la constitution nous a donné
pour mission de les représenter de
défendre leur liberté
nous vous disons monsieur le premier
ministre ne cédez pas de nouveau à la
tentation de la toute puissance qui
attend abîmé le lien de confiance avec
les élus locaux du reste et je le dis là
encore avec beaucoup de sérénité
nous n'acceptons pas cette affirmation
selon laquelle l'intérêt du pays nous
serait étranger depuis deux ans le
groupe auquel nous appartenons a
toujours refusé l'obstruction un très
intransigeante au profit de l'opposition
intelligente nous sommes nous opposer
aux ordonnances du travail non nous les
avons voté parce que nous estimons que
même si elles étaient insuffisantes
elle allait dans le bon sens avant notre
tenter de faire échouer la réforme de la
sncf
non nous ne vous avons appuyé parce que
nous considérions que compte tenu des
carences de notre système ferroviaire
décor peau d'un bon corporatisme que
depuis trop longtemps le fragilise
l'exigence de réformes devaient primer
de même avant nous repousser la loi est
lent ou celle sur les mobilités ses
textes
loin de les rejeter nous les avons
amélioré parce que notre mission de
législateurs prime sur toute autre
considération parce que nous sommes au
sénat bien moins perméable aux patients
et aux agitations qui parfois dominés à
l'assemblée nationale et je pourrais
également évoqué les mesures d'urgence
décidées par le président de la
république au pic de la crise de l'hiver
dernier des mesures que nous avons voté
parce que nous considérions que compte
tenu de l'état de tension dans le pays
il fallait collectivement répondre à
l'urgence et mettre tout en oeuvre pour
que l'ordre et la sérénité revienne
nous n'avons jamais été dans une
opposition pavlovienne notre position
est claire et je crois qu'elle est saine
sur le plan démocratique quand nous
estimons qu'un texte est bon pour le
pays
nous le votons quand il nous paraît
qu'il ne l'est pas
nous ne votons pas car s'il peut y avoir
avec vous des convergences et nous en
avons trouvé
monsieur le premier ministre dans votre
discours la fin des régimes spéciaux de
retraite la réforme de l'assurance
chômage ou le débat annuel au parlement
sur l'immigration mais il ya aussi de
vraies différences non pas des
différences de forme mais les
différences de fond lorsque vous
annoncez des milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires sans indiquer
comment vous les financerait sinon en
rabotant ici ou là quelques niches
fiscales au lieu de présenter aux
français un véritable plan d'économies
au risque de faire porter sur les
générations futures la charge financière
de vos décisions
c'est une différence de fond lorsque
vous refusez d'indexer les aides
accordées aux familles et que vous
poursuivez l'entreprise de fragilisation
de la politique familiale engagées par
françois hollande c'est une différence
de fond lorsque vous engager notre
protection sociale vers un système de
moins en moins universel
c'est une différence de fond lorsque la
production de la protection de
l'environnement se traduit par une
fiscalité punitive
c'est une différence de fond ces
différences nous ne la revendiquons pas
seulement pour nous mêmes mais aussi
pour défendre ce qui nous engage tous la
crédibilité de la parole publique
tout d'abord car l'honneur de la
politique c'est de défendre des
convictions sans céder à l'esprit du
temps ou à l'opportunité du moment
l'efficacité dans la conduite des
affaires du pays
car aucun gouvernement aucune majorité
aucun pouvoir ne dispose de la vérité
absolue
j'en veux pour preuve la loi
anti-casseurs c'était comme vous le
savez une proposition notre groupe
porté par bruno retailleau vous l'avait
initialement écarté pour ensuite la
reprendre à votre compte
face aux violences urbaines auxquelles
vous avez été confrontés et nous nous en
félicitons aussi nous sommes en droit
d'attendre que le gouvernement ait la
même attitude constructive dont a fait
preuve le sénat et vous avez monsieur le
premier ministre
une nouvelle occasion de bénéficier de
la sagesse des sénateurs avec le projet
de réforme institutionnelle
oui une réforme est nécessaire pour
revitaliser
la démocratie française tant au plan
national que local pour ré articuler la
démocratie représentative
avec la démocratie directe et
participative oui une révision
constitutionnelle est possible elle est
possible si le gouvernement fait preuve
de cette ouverture que vous mettez
pourtant en avant autant nous saluons
votre décision d'avoir renoncé à
certaines atteintes au parlement autant
nous déplorons que sur la question de la
représentation des territoires et donc
des dans celle du nombre de
parlementaires
vous sembliez privilégier le rapport de
force voire la pression pour nous qui
portons la voix des territoires
ce point n'est pas secondaire il est
majeur car il touche à la justice
territoriale
il est juste que tous les territoires
soient représentés il est juste qu'il
n'y ait pas plus de 20 départements ne
disposant que d'un sénateur et que cette
garantie fasse l'objet d'une disposition
constitutionnelle
autrement dit c'est en partant de
l'exigence d'équité et de
représentativité territoriale que le
nombre de sénateurs doit être fixée à
bas et non pas à partir d'une logique
arithmétique
sinon technocratique n'ajoutons pas au
fracture géographique une déchirure
démocratique en éloignant encore un peu
plus la république des territoires dans
bien des communes rurales ou des villes
moyennes le sentiment d'abandon domine
la conviction pour ne compte pour rien
et largement partagée
elle fut d'ailleurs au coeur de cette
crise des idées gilet jaune que vous
avez dû affronter alors tirer tous les
enseignements de cette crise n'accentue
et pas cette désespérance en supprimant
après les services publics
le service démocratique cas sur les
parlementaires du reste cela fait un an
que nous avons exprimé nos exigences
préalables à toute révision
constitutionnelle qu'attendez vous pour
nous dire oui ou non au delà de cette
question majeure
nous souhaitons vous le savez renouer
avec l'esprit initial de la vème
république
je pense évidemment au respect du
bicamérisme au renouvellement par moitié
du sénat notamment pour assurer le
principe de la continuité des pouvoirs
publics
enfin ces différences que nous assumons
sont aussi nous le croyons un gage de
concorde et d'unité certains dans votre
majorité ont exprimé leur satisfaction
au lendemain des élections européennes
pourtant la réalité géographique et
civiques que dessine ces chiffres n'a
rien de satisfaisante mais exprime au
contraire une situation dont nul ne peut
se féliciter
celle d'un pays fracturé de deux france
profondément opposé vous vouliez
dépasser les vieux clivages
mais vous n'êtes pas revenue qu'à leur
substituer des clivages autrement plus
dangereux des clivages territoriaux des
clivages sociaux des clivages culturelle
et générationnelle même des clivages qui
en réalité épousent les lignes de cette
recomposition que vous poursuivez la
poutre travaille encore disiez vous
monsieur le premier ministre
prenez garde qu'à force de travail et
elle ne fracturé les murs porteurs de
l'édifice français prenez garde que dans
ceux nous et eux que vous avez installé
face au rassemblement national
la perspective d'une réconciliation de
tous les français ne s'effondre prises
entre des forces irréconciliables bien
sûr les fossés qui se creusent entre nos
concitoyens ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
mais c'est à vous qu'il revient de les
combler plutôt que de les creuser car le
grand défi que nous allons devoir
relever dans les années qui viennent
celui qu il vous incombe aujourd'hui
d'affronter c'est celui de l'unité cette
grande oeuvre française toujours à
recommencer cette unité ne pourra se
faire que dans la vérité parce que
toujours le mensonge divise les
illusions sépare
regardons les choses en face les deux me
vérité et les vrais mensonges n'ont fait
qu'accentuer la méfiance des français
ils ont conduit les uns à rechercher des
boucs émissaires pousser les autres à
s'enfermer dans leur vérité a abandonné
la raison critique pour les
raisonnements irrationnel pour recréer
les conditions de l'amitié civique
il faut avoir le courage de dire dire la
vérité sur l'état de nos finances
publiques sur la situation de nos
comptes sociaux qui de nouveau plongé
dans le rouge sur l'impossibilité de
soutenir artificiellement la croissance
et le pouvoir d'achat
entre-temps indéfiniment les déficits
dire la vérité sur le chômage les
paramètres actuels
qu'il s'agisse de dépenses publiques et
des déficits ne permettront pas
d'atteindre l'objectif de 7% de chômage
d'ici la fin du quinquennat
la conjoncture ne suffit plus à créer
l'embellie dire la vérité sur l'état de
notre institution scolaire sur la
nécessité d'étoffer la diversité des
parcours nous donner plus de liberté
pour recruter pour innover mais de
renouer aussi avec la transmission
celle qui permet d'échapper à la
reproduction sociale et surtout de
réaffirmer la valeur du mérite et du
travail en vous éloignant de la
tentation de la discrimination positive
dire la vérité sur l'immigration
également qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
régulé sur le communautarisme ou les
atteintes à la laïcité qui trop souvent
ne sont pas encore sanctionné dire la
vérité en somme surtout ses non dits sur
ces dénis qui ont frayé la voie aux
extrêmes partout dans les démocraties
occidentales
le sentiment d'insécurité culturel
progresse des questionnements
fondamentaux se font entendre sur la
nation sur les frontières sur le rapport
à la mondialisation ne pas offrir des
réponses démocratique à ses
interrogations légitimes rester
insensible aux angoisses et au sentiment
de dépossession qu'exprime bon nombre de
nos câbles compatriote s'est exposé la
république à des insurrections
électorale c'est nous exposer
collectivement aux aventures sans
lendemain dans lesquelles nous
entraînerait les extrêmes
si par malheur elle parvenait aux
responsabilités cette unité nous la
ferons que dans le cadre d'un débat
apaisé respectueux de chacun sait sont
les caractères caricature les anathèmes
manichéen
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
indiqué ne pas vous résigner au
rétrécissement du débat public
mais enfin qui depuis deux ans rétrécir
le débat a déposé des oppositions
binaires sans nuances qui n'a cessé de
dire qu'il n'y avait désormais les
progressistes d'un côté et les
conservateurs de l'autre les
représentants du monde d'avant et les
héros du monde nouveau ce n'est pas le
sénat
c'est le président de la république
c'est votre gouvernement nous nous vous
le disons calmement mais franchement le
progrès n'est pas une marque déposée par
la majorité
nous voulons tous le progrès accepter
seulement que nous puissions en avoir
une vision parfois différente de celle
que vous nourrissez et y aient
l'humilité de reconnaître que la
modernité n'est pas univoque que ce qui
est ancien n'est pas forcément datée est
dépassé c'est l'exemple d'ailleurs de
l'institution communale elle est sans
nul doute l'une des plus anciennes et
c'est d'abord à elle que nos
compatriotes accordent leur confiance
c'est d'ailleurs vers l vers les mers
que vous vous êtes immédiatement tourné
l'hiver dernier lorsque la situation
s'est enflammé après les avoir pourtant
tant méprisé les maires n'ont jamais été
autant décourager et vous devez tenir
compte de leur découragement
du reste nous pensons qu'à l'heure des
grandes ruptures et des changements
permanents
la politique doit être aussi un facteur
de stabilité s'il est essentiel de
changer ce qu'il faut il est tout autant
de préserver ce qui vaut de protéger ses
attachements vitaux qui nous tiennent
comme un seul peuple une seule nation
c'est aussi le message qu'on voyait
beaucoup d'électeurs lors de ce scrutin
européen
non les français ne sont pas des gaulois
réfractaires au changement mais ils
tiennent à leur souveraineté
ils tiennent à leur laïcité ils tiennent
à leur solidarité nationale
car ses attachements sont autant d'appui
nécessaire pour que nous puissions
prendre collectivement notre élan nous
projeter et nous imposer dans un monde
nouveau qui a besoin de la france
prenons le meilleur de la modernité et
donnant le meilleur de notre identité
voilà un an même temps qui pour le cours
pourrait rassembler une majorité de
français monsieur le premier ministre
c'est dans cet esprit d'unité que nous
voulons continuer d'oeuvrer l'unité
n'est pas pour nous synonyme
d'uniformité dans une démocratie adulte
la pluralité doit être vécue comme une
richesse et non comme un obstacle
nous avons des différences et nous
aurons encore peut-être des convergences
et c'est au nom de ces différences que
nous assumons et de ces convergences que
nous espérons que dans le cadre du vote
que vous nous demandez le groupe l'est
républicain s'abstiendra majoritairement
et cela pour deux raisons essentielles
d'abord parce que le sénat n'est pas
l'assemblée nationale il n'est ni dans
ses attributions ni dans ses missions de
renverser ou non tel ou tel gouvernement
ensuite parce que depuis deux ans nous
avons été trop habitués à ce décalage
entre d'un côté des mots forts et de
l'autre des actes faible autrement dit
cette abstention c'est tout sauf un
chèque en blanc
nous jugerons sur pièce au cas par cas
texte par texte ni opposition
systématique ni adhésion automatique
telle est notre ligne de conduite cette
ligne nous la tiendrons monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres nous le tiendrons parce
que au-delà de nos appartenances
il y à la france nous la tiendrons parce
que nous tenons à nos convictions parce
que nous croyons à ce que nous défendons
blais
la parole est maintenant président
françois patriat pour le groupe de la
république en marche pour 8 minutes sur
le premier ministre monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre vous vous
demandez aujourd'hui de nous prononcer
sur le chemin à parcourir et la méthode
pour y parvenir
la france est ainsi fait que les soirs
d'élection se projette déjà dans les
futures échéances
moi je préfère ici me contenait au
travail que nous avons à faire dans
cette période qui nous emmènera aux
prochaines échéances
et ce travail que nous devons conduire
activement à ce moment de ce quinquennat
monsieur premier ministre on pouvons
nous poser de question relate rassembler
ou nous mêmes le groupe la république en
marche
la première question avons-nous tenu nos
engagements
avant lui nous mis notre pays sur le
chemin du redressement avec tout votre
gouvernement que je salue ici
pouvons-nous être fier du travail
accompli pour notre part la réponse est
oui
la deuxième question devons nous encore
repousser les échéances refuser la
réalité et reculer devant les réformes à
faire
la réponse est non votre discours
monsieur le premier ministre a montré
avec fermeté l'important travail à
conduire maintenant vous l'avez fait
avec lucidité sans mésestimer les
difficultés à surmonter
est-il nobles comme je l ai entendue
hier à l'assemblée de parler de
programme cache poussière il respectacle
de s'opposer mes chers collègues
mais peut-on éviter les propos
outranciers
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
choisi de recourir à une disposition
prévue dans notre constitution sur
laquelle vous solliciter le vote de
confiance au sein de notre hôte dans
l'eau 3 s'assemblent et je m'en réjouis
cette démarche entend valoriser
l'institution sénatoriales et les élus
qui y siègent je sais bien que le
résultat du vote d'aujourd'hui ne sera
pas similaire à celui d'hier l'assemblée
faut-il pour autant renoncer dans un
sauna une couleur politique différente
celle du gouvernement
je crois que c'est courageux
cette démarche elle entre en cohérence
avec la volonté d'ouverture qui est
celle du gouvernement tant la situation
politique de notre pays est inédite
oui monsieur le premier ministre vous
avez raison le sénat ne doit pas être
écartée de la marche du monde
aujourd'hui vient le temps d'insuffler
plus que jamais l'espoir du dépassement
du dialogue et de l'ouverture
le dépassement mes chers collègues ce
n'est pas le renoncement à ses
convictions c'est d'accepter de partager
avec d'autres venus d'horizons divers
les analyses et les voie du redressement
moi même voix même j'ai gardé mes
convictions personnelles qui ne sont pas
les vôtres monsieur premier ministre
mais je pense que la justice sociale ne
peut advenir que si le redressement
économique est là le dépassement des
clivages qui permet de sortir des
rigidités et de réunir des progressistes
a permis de réelles avancées qui
commence déjà à produire leurs effets
les résultats de la france en matière
d'attractivité économique sont salués
par l' ocde qui confirme que les rues
des réformes vont dans le bon sens et
qu'il faut les poursuivre contrairement
aux affirmations de certains beaucoup de
mesures répondent à la quête d'une plus
grande justice sociale largement
exprimée par nos concitoyens
je pense aux plans pauvreté au reste à
charge 0 aux avancées en faveur des
personnes handicapées aux mesures
éducatives au travail qui paie à la
baisse historique du chômage avec un peu
d'objectivité
chacun peut faire le bilan des actions
entreprises
elles montrent surtout loin d'être une
simple formule le en même temps a été
réellement mises en oeuvre aujourd'hui
pour établir les solides fondations de
l'acte 2 du quinquennat il est
fondamental de l'accompagner ici au
sénat avec lucidité courage et
détermination
et vous l'avez dit hier avec civilité
face à l'urgence écologique social
démocratique et politique
réformer est ce que l'on doit réussir
ensemble notre pays a besoin de
poursuivre le chemin tracé avec
constance et cohérence changer des
méthodes oui
mais gardez le cap est nécessaire
présente la république porte un projet
d'émancipation qui parle au peuple et
qui parle aussi aux élus à travers le
grand débat nous avons entendu les
français ils veulent plus des coûte plus
de proximité plus d'ouverture plus
d'humanisme pour un plus large
rassemblement
c'est la méthode de l'acte 2 du
quinquennat
alors mes chers collègues faut-il oui ou
non réformer les finances des
collectivités locales faut-il oui ou non
baisser la pression fiscale qui pèse sur
nos concitoyens faut-il oui ou non plus
d'avancer écologique
faut-il oui ou non d'étendre la pma à
toutes les femmes ce premier ministre
nous soutiendrons les projets de loi qui
ont été énoncée hier dans votre discours
de politique générale reforme de
l'assurance chômage des retraites
les projets doivent bioéthique de la
programmation de la recherche et de
l'accélération écologie celui consacré à
l'engagement au j'ai lu que vous avez
évoqué ce matin nous paraît aussi
essentiel pour répondre à la crise des
vocations pour les mères ont le vent les
freins à l'exercice du mandat en
défendant la validation des parcours de
reconversion
d'autres chantiers majeurs doivent être
entrepris comme celui qui visent à
lisser les irritants de la loi nôtre et
je fais confiance à sébastien lecornu
pour le conduire dans le dialogue comme
il l'a fait déjà par le passé
faisons preuve de volonté et sachant
aussi prendre les risques et les assumer
mes chers collègues
quelles que soient vos choix ils sont
respectables
je vous incite aux plus grands
rassemblements comme nous l'avons
parfois fait car notre projet même si le
premier ministre vise à réconcilier la
france avec elle même nous avons
confiance à la démarche qui nous
proposait et ça n'est pas un scoop une
surprise le voc la république en marche
votre a largement la confiance au
gouvernement qui vous remercie monsieur
le président la parole est maintenant
madame la présidente eliane assassi pour
le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes
madame la présidente vous avez la parole
mais chez le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre a écouté
hier la lecture par monsieur de rugy de
votre discours de politique générale
tout en ayant quand même un oeil et une
oreille sur votre intervention devant
l'assemblée nationale
et je vais vous dire ce que j'en pense
avec sérieux car ici au sénat nous ne
sommes pas au théâtre
même si nous allons évoquer votre acte
de ce qui m'a d'emblée frappé c'est le
décalage avec le pays réel
après la séquence électorale des
européennes
vos partisans semblent avoir vaincu la
colère jaune domestique et la colère du
peuple qui a tonné si fort durant des
semaines est à son plus fort vous le
savez bien a fait vaciller votre vos
certitudes
erreur la colère est toujours là comme à
belfort à saint saulve dans les hôpitaux
les maternités dans la fonction publique
chez les élus ne vous trompez pas ne
vous y trompez pas monsieur le premier
ministre
faire une liste à la prévert des colères
ne suffira pas à les apaiser
vous n'en avez pas fini avec celles et
ceux qui sont majoritaires dans le pays
avec tous ceux qui aspirent à une vie
meilleure et digne à l'emploi un vrai
travail de stable à tous ceux qui
aspirent à garantir un avenir serein à
leurs enfants qu'ils aspirent à vieillir
dignement et en bonne santé qui sans
doute majoritairement ont déserté les
isoloirs le 26 mai dernier
ce qui ne semble pas vous préoccuper
dans votre discours vous avez une
nouvelle fois agiter les peurs vos peurs
l'insécurité le terrorisme l'étranger
mais la peur qui taraude l'immense
majorité du peuple c'est celle du
lendemain celle du chômage du contrat
précaire qui se termine des soins trop
cher et même de la faim et de tout cela
vous n'en avez pas parlé vous ne devez
pas oublier que vous n'en avez pas fini
avec les exigences de justice sociale et
fiscale
les vraies celles qui passent
obligatoirement par la répartition des
richesses pas par des aménagements
publics du système votre acte 2 a un
goût de réchauffé libérer les énergies
dites vous en écho premier ministre
alain juppé
nous sommes des réformateurs annoncé
vous en écho cette fois ci au mouvement
des réformateurs
fondé par jean lecanuet en 1972
pouvez-vous encore parler de nouveau
monde avec de telles références
certainement pas bien au contraire
vous êtes fidèles tragiquement fidèle
aux politiques menées depuis près de 40
ans mise à bas de mise à part de brèves
éclaircies qui font rimer réforme avec
recul social précarisation
appauvrissement vous avez dit hier que
vous étiez inénervable je suis bien
contente pour vous et donc
imperturbablement vous tracer la voie du
libéralisme le plus à qatar quels qu'ils
soient
malgré la colère soutenu massivement
durant des mois par la population vous
n'avez pas prononcé les mots isf smic
salaire et surtout pas les mots évasion
fiscale qui bien évidemment concerne
trop de soutien à celui qui demeure le
président des riches
vous n'avez pas plus répondu à
l'aspiration à une démocratie
profondément refonder à une irruption de
la citoyenneté votre discours n'est pas
disruptif mais bien au contraire convenu
destiné à sauver l'existant c'est à dire
une france où les riches possèdent
toujours plus et les pauvres toujours
moins une france où les inégalités se
creusent vous avez longuement parlé
d'écologie
comme vous l'avez dit personne n'a le
monopole mais il ne suffit pas d'en
parler
encore faut-il produire des actes en
s'attaquant aux plus grands prédateurs
de l'écologie et de l'environnement
or jamais vous ne pointer la
responsabilité dans la dégradation de la
situation de l'environnement du système
capitaliste lui-même et deux sur quoi un
système capitaliste mondialisé monsieur
le premier ministre
il faut écouter cette jeunesse qui n'est
pas réfugié dans une écologie naïve et
béate
mais dans une contestation profonde du
système économique qui génère la
pollution massive changer le système et
pas le climat n'est certainement pas un
slogan qui vous agréent on le voit bien
votre dessin c'est le mirage d'un
capitalisme vert propre
succédant à celui qui a abîmé notre
planète et l'humanité
or le capitalisme porte en lui la quête
du profit la mise en concurrence
l'exploitation des femmes des hommes
comme des richesses de la terre et c'est
en cela qu'il ravage la planète et doit
être être remis en cause pour envisager
l'avenir de toute manière vos actes
concrets nous donne raison et
contredisent vos bonnes attentions
par exemple allez vous continuer à
fermer les petites lignes de train
confirmez-vous la fermeture de la ligne
de fret ferroviaire perpignan rungis de
transport de fruits et de légumes
cadeaux insensé aux transporteurs
routiers
le service public la solidarité sont au
coeur du projet de transformation
écologique que nous portons monsieur
paul aimé me je les dis votre vieux
discours et formateur vis toujours et
encore à réduire les droits sociaux
arrachés parfois au prix du sang plutôt
que d'assurer le bonheur commun pour un
juste partage réduire le nombre de
fonctionnaires en finir avec leur statut
cette vieille lubie des libéraux
s'inscrit dans ce cadre
votre acte 2 c'est la remise en cause du
système de retraite par l'avènement du
système par points et la diminution des
droits des chômeurs futur vache à lait
de la sacro-sainte réduction des
déficits et dettes en tout genre vous
l'avez dit encore aujourd'hui les
salariés sont déjà contraints de
travailler plus longtemps que l'âge
légal pour tenter de s'assurer une
retraite digne
l'argument fallacieux de l'allongement
de la durée de vie ne tient pas lorsque
l'on a travaillé plus de 40 ans on a
droit au repos et on a droit de laisser
la place aux jeunes
en effet
quelle absurdité que d'enchaîner au
travail jusqu'à la vieillesse des femmes
et des hommes alors que 4 millions sont
au chômage et près de 10 millions en
situation de précarité
notre projet est diamétralement opposée
et d'une audace juste et solidaire il
faut travailler moins moins longtemps
pour partager le travail et nous portons
en ce sens la marche vers la semaine des
32 heures et le retour à la retraite à
60 ans votre politique économique et
industrielle monsieur le premier
ministre est à l'avenant vous avez
évoqué general electric à belfort
mais qui est responsable de cette
situation qui a supervisé les
négociations de soumission à
l'entreprise américaine
si ce n'est le secrétaire général de
l'elysée d'alors monsieur macron
lui-même vous vantez l'attractivité de
notre paix relancé de notre pays mais
elle s'effectue dans la dérégulation la
plus totale accompagnée d'une vague de
plans sociaux des exonérations massives
et d'une casse systématique du droit du
travail et d'une boussole votre boussole
la réduction de la dépense publique
alors huit minutes pour aborder fleuret
la situation difficile de notre pays
confronté à la déstructuration sociale
et démocratique
vous avouerez que c'est assez bien peu
nous ne voterons pas votre déclaration
nous ne soutiendrons pas ce projet qui
s'attaque en profondeur à la solidarité
nationale et qui n'est pas ni de gauche
ni de droite mais tout simplement de
droite
nous combattrons ce qui se dissimule
derrière votre flegme nous nous
élèverons contre l'autoroute à
l'autoritarisme qui sert votre projet
l'autoritarisme contre les manifestants
ou encore contre les journalistes qui
ont suivi le conflit au yémen
et puis monsieur le premier ministre
pour terminer je dois dire que vous
n'avez pas prononcé trois mots plutôt
trois lettres adp
sans vouloir vous énervez votre silence
est le reflet de votre profond agacement
enfin le peuple prendre la parole et
pasco d'air
celui de la privatisation d'un grand
service public national qui succède à
tant de bradage du bien collectif des
autoroutes au secteur de l'énergie alors
là la consultation a démarré cette nuit
il y à déjà plus de 100000 citoyennes et
citoyens qui ont qui participent à cette
consultation malgré des bugs mais nous
en reparlerons cet après midi et je
crois monsieur le premier ministre que
quoi que vous en pensiez je les les
français vont pouvoir librement pour peu
qu'ils en ont la possibilité
s'exprimer et briser les murs que les
puissants ont construit pour l'enfermer
et le réduire aussi merci madame la
présidente
la parole est maintenant président
patrick keller pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
[Applaudissements]
la parole monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre entre hier
et aujourd'hui je vous ai bien écouté
j'ai une crainte qui ressort j'ai peur
que vous ayez oublié la crise sociale
que traverse notre pays
le président nous avait dit que rien ne
serait plus comme avant
ils nous avaient fait le menu de la
france divisé et appauvri qui l'avait
découverte au gré de son tour de france
du grand débat nous aviez ici même
parler des leçons à tirer de la crise et
gilet jaune mots que vous n'avez pas
prononcé d'ailleurs hier dans votre
discours devant l'assemblée nationale
n'étions pas d'accord sur les remèdes
mais des constats étaient partagés et
aujourd'hui tout semble oubliée dans la
présentation de votre action politique
des prochains mois la présentation de
l'acte 2 se passe comme si la crise
sociale n'avait été qu'un entracte après
l'acte 1
vous êtes remonté sur votre nuage de
certitude hier et aujourd'hui nous
attendions un projet social pour la
france un contrat social pour les
français c'est ce que mon groupe a
demandé depuis décembre avec constance
notamment dans cet hémicycle et ce
projet social d'envergure nous ne le
voyons toujours pas vous auriez pu venir
devant nous pour nous expliquer que la
réforme des retraites se fera dans un
esprit de justice sociale etc aucun
reportage de départ est envisagé sous
quelque forme que ce soit alors nous
aurions pu entrevoir la remise en
question de vos choix antérieurs
au lieu de ça en contradictions du
discours tenu par jean paul delevoye
pendant des mois nous voyons poindre une
réforme paramétrique
le tour de passe-passe de l'âge pivot ou
d' équilibre à 63 64 65 ans ce sera
contraindre de fait les personnes aux
revenus faibles et aux métiers souvent
les plus pénibles et répétitif à
retarder leur départ à la retraite pour
maintenir le revenu à un niveau décent
pendant ce temps les personnes les mieux
rémunérés pourrons capitaliser de leur
côté pour s'assurer des revenus de
retraite supplémentaire et choisir de
partir avant l'âge pivot en compensant
le nouveau malus que vous vous apprêtez
à créer je le répète instaurer un nouvel
âge pivot c'est repousser l'âge de
départ uniquement pour les plus faibles
revenus
avec cet âge pivot vous contraindre et
les moins riches à travailler plus
longtemps
tout en laissant le choix aux plus
riches avec cette réforme paramétrique
qui n'a plus rien à voir avec la réforme
systémique annoncé vous aller creuser un
nouveau fossé entre les français selon
les revenus
vous allez affaiblir encore l'adhésion
au système des retraites y compris le
nouveau vous allait accélérer la perte
de confiance dans un système universel
et solidaire au contraire nous proposons
un retour des critères de pénibilité que
ces critères soit au coeur du calcul des
droits à la retraite et du nombre de
trimestres tout en conservant l'âge
légal à 62 ans et à 60 ans pour les
carrières longues
ces règles paramétrique peuvent
s'appliquer dans le système actuel où
même le système par points
ces règles permettent de ne pas
prolonger les carrières de ceux de nos
concitoyens qui ont les métiers les plus
difficiles et qui font fonctionner notre
société au quotidien
ce premier ministre ce sont les mêmes
qui ont l'espérance de vie la plus
courte à la retraite
ce sont eux qui ont créé leur désespoir
ces derniers mois
notre conviction est que leurs droits à
la retraite doit être garanti par des
critères justes voilà ce qui serait une
réponse solidaire à la crise sociale
vous auriez pu venir
aussi devons-nous nous expliquer que la
réforme de l'assurance-chômage
n'affaiblira pas les droits des français
ou même chose qu'elle l'ait garantira
que la mise en place du revenu minimum
se fera avec une enveloppe dynamique que
vous avez un projet pour l'emploi au
lieu de cela nous voyons arriver un
allongement de la durée du travail avant
d'avoir droit à l'allocation de retour à
l'emploi avec d'autres mesures sous
prétexte que le système actuel ne
citerai pas suffisamment la reprise
d'une activité durable
ce discours qui est tenu dans vos rangs
par vos ministres permettez-moi de le
dire est l'un des fondements du fossé
grandissant entre les français c'est un
discours tellement déconnectés de la
réalité de ce qu'est le chômage c'est le
discours de ceux qui n'ont jamais vu
qu'ils n'ont jamais eue à vivre éloigné
du travail avec des périodes répétées de
chômage et surtout des revenus sous les
1000 euros
c'est le discours de ceux qui n'ont
jamais été au chômage et qui ne le
seront jamais c'est parce que nous nous
opposons à ces arguments de mépris
social que nous défendons la bande mans
de la prime d'activité celle que nous
avons instauré parce que le nombre de
demandes de cette prime est la preuve
que les français préfèrent travailler
plutôt que d'être soi disant assisté
cette prime d'activité d'abord un outil
complémentaire
au retour à l'emploi et ne peut pas
remplacer comme vous le faites la
nécessaire conférence sociale sur les
salaires que nous appelons une nouvelle
fois de nos voeux usez et abusez de la
prime d'activité c'est faire de la
redistribution sans demander d'efforts
supplémentaires aux employeurs sert
creuser le déficit de la sécurité
sociale et ne pas répondre aux besoins
des hôpitaux publics au passage sur le
revenu minimum nous portons aussi cette
idée depuis la création de la prune
activités se devait être l'étape
suivante pour pallier le non recours aux
aides sociales c'est pourquoi nous avons
défendu et nous continuerons de la
défendre la proposition
d'expérimentation porté par les
départements à majorité socialiste
seulement votre volonté d'intégrer dans
son périmètre des allocations qui ne
sont pas du même niveau risque
d'affaiblir l'impact social de cette
mesure
surtout votre volonté d'une enveloppe
constante alors qu'il ya un objectif
d'automatiser la location est une autre
erreur c'est comme mettre une pointure
42 dans une chaussure du 39
nous défendons l'automatisation nous
défendrons donc une enveloppe adapté et
dynamique sur l'emploi mais ce premier
ministre nous réitérons nos inquiétudes
nos propositions d'abord sur les
contrats aidés
leur suppression a affaibli notre marché
de l'emploi et la baisse du chômage pour
les concitoyens les plus en difficulté
ensuite sur la politique économique
les annonces successives de fermeture
des usines sans la démonstration d'une
absence de stratégie industrielle
les privatisations engagé n'alimenteront
que faiblement le fonds d'innovation
alors qu'un investissement direct claire
assumé de l'état pour la transformation
de notre appareil industriel est
nécessaire voilà ce qu aurait pu être
une réponse salariale et économique à la
crise sociale vous auriez pu aussi venir
devant nous ce premier ministre pour
nous parler du coeur du problème social
de notre pays
la question du reste à vivre du pouvoir
d'achat appelé aussi dernièrement à
juste titre le pouvoir de vivre bien
au-delà du seul problème des niveaux de
salaires c'est l'augmentation des
charges incompressibles qui grèvent les
budgets de beaucoup de français de la
classe moyenne et qui accentue les
inégalités avec les plus hauts revenus
c'est là que se trouvent les causes du
populisme rampant dans notre pays ce
sujet mérite une action de l'état une
action résolue
les dépenses de logement doivent être
contenues dans les grands centres
urbains via des mesures plus volontaire
des pouvoirs publics
mais la crise des yeux les jaunes a
aussi mis en évidence le coût accru des
transports du quotidien pour aller
travailler
il existe des leviers sur ces sujets
comme l'encadrement des loyers ou une
fiscalité affectés au transport
collectif
vous ne les utilisez pas mais nous vous
ferons des propositions lors des
prochaines lois de finances avec une
attention particulière pour la situation
des outre-mer je peux ministre votre
annonce d' acte 2 manque donc
cruellement d'un grand volet social nous
le déplorons
pour autant nous reconnaissons que vous
vous projetez sur quelques nouveaux
sujets qui étaient bien trop loin de vos
préoccupations jusqu'ici j'évoquerai la
question des nouveaux droits comme la
pma vous l'annonciez depuis deux ans et
peut-être un jour cela se fera t'il
vraiment je veux ici vous dire que nous
vous accompagnerons sous réserve
d'inventaire naturellement comme nous
l'avons toujours fait quand il s'agit de
faire progresser le droit des femmes
dans notre pays
mais je voudrais aussi vous parler de la
question démocratique
nous avons entendu les projets
concernant le statut de l'élu
cette problématique est un serpent de
mer nous l'accueillons favorablement
comme étant un débat à venir la crise
sociale de notre pays se porte également
sur les élus de nos mairies qui n'ont
pas la reconnaissance qu'ils devraient
cette réforme pour réussir aura deux
impératifs que vous passiez par la
concertation avec les associations
d'élus vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
tant mieux et que vous écoutiez le sénat
qui a déjà beaucoup travaillé sur tous
ces bancs sur ce statut nous aurons
certainement dans le détail des
divergences de points de vue mais nous
devons enfin nous engager dans cette
voie d'une véritable reconnaissance pour
les élus locaux
cela contribuera à la respiration
démocratique dont notre pays a besoin
la question centrale de cette
respiration démocratique
restera ensuite celle de la
décentralisation comme dans les
précédents débats nous demandons la mise
en place d'un nouveau pacte de
décentralisation afin que les
collectivités puissent agir pleinement
librement avec des moyens propres sur
des compétences économiques
d'aménagement du territoire dgt
placement d'équipement le lien de
confiance avec les élus locaux passera
par là et par le retour au respect des
engagements de l'état respect des
engagements de l'état sur les projets
locaux
jusque là nous en sommes loin monsieur
premier ministre et permettait aux
sénateurs dès du nord et donc des hôtes
france de vous le dire le retrait
progressif et cynique de l'état sur le
projet du canal seine nord europe n'est
pas acceptable faire confiance aux élus
locaux aux collectivités à la
décentralisation c'est assurer la
vitalité démocratique du pays
mais celle-ci a besoin d'une autre
ressource et je voudrais terminer par là
l'aprue la pluralité politique
monsieur le premier ministre vous et
nous avons des divergences des
différences de vues des oppositions mais
nous avons en commun la volonté au moins
affiché de faire vivre notre démocratie
de promouvoir le projet républicain
cette pluralité est incarnée dans nos
assemblées elle est même présente au
sein de nos groupes
c'est une force pour nous tous alors
nous nous inquiétons d'une de vos
réformes à venir
la réforme institutionnelle et le totem
de la baisse du nombre de parlementaires
vous avez décidé manifestement de
reporter si médiers cette réforme qui
pourtant reste absolument nécessaire et
vous le faites en faisant porter la
responsabilité de votre décision sur la
haute assemblée gardienne de la juste
représentation des territoires
je pr ministre je dénonce cette
manoeuvre alors qu'un accord raisonnable
est toujours possible
je dénonce l'hypothèse de l'utilisation
du référendum instrumentalisé comme
sanction à l'encontre du sénat je
dénonce une attitude menaçante à l'égard
des élus de la nation parce qu'ils
auraient le défaut de déplaire au
château
sachez sachets accepté sachez accepter
ces espaces de respiration démocratique
ou d opposition structurée autour de
parties sont la garantie d'une
république vivante pour notre pays
couchepin ministre je reviens sur la
baisse de noms de parlementaires
vous risquez ainsi d'affaiblir la
pluralité politique qui ne peut pas
exister correctement dans un parti
attrape tout un parti unique en créant
de fait ou de manière assumée les
conditions d'une alternance politique
avec la seule l'extrême droite c'est
tout le leur dû et de droite et de
gauche qui hack écraserait tout sur son
passage
d'ailleurs permettez-moi de noter une
contradiction dans votre politique et
dans votre engagement sur le sujet vous
vous appelez à dépasser nos parties
peut-être que dans le mot dépassement ya
le mot effacement dans l'intérêt du pays
mais lorsque nous le faisons sans que on
demande d'amm jurés un quelconque
engagement ce comme sur les aéroports de
paris vous nous le reprocher permettez
moi donc de trouver vos injonctions à
vous soutenir quelque peu opportuniste
votre soi-disant recomposition politique
passe d'abord par la destruction des
partis politiques classiques
alors vous l'avez compris je termine
monsieur le président vous l'avez
compris nous n'approuvons pas votre
déclaration de politique générale sur la
base de l'article 49 alinéa 4
manifestement utilisés aujourd'hui au
sénat comme une trappe à soutien je sais
que l'un de vos ministres au moins est
en train d'envoyer des sms y compris à
mon groupe et j'en ai la preuve ce qui
est bien dommage en ce moment même comme
une trappe à soutien il se reconnaîtra
je n'en doute pas comme une trappe à
soutien et surtout comme une machine
électorale a stigmatisé pour les
prochaines échéances à venir
votre bilan de l'acte 1 vous amène un
acte 2 sans changer de cap
cette perspective ne nous convient pas à
la gauche du pays d'offrir maintenant
une véritable alternative
merci monsieur le président la parole
est au président jean claude requier
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique cesse et ceci à l'europe et
à monsieur le président la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mes chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre vous aurez
cette semaine devant le parlement l'acte
2 du quinquennat du président de la
république
l'écouté le dialogue et à notre sens les
premiers attributs d'un élu et nous
mettons à l'application
c'est avec responsabilité que nous
tirerons les conséquences
dans déclaration de politique générale
par notre vote en gardant constamment en
tête les besoins de tout le territoire
qu'elle est monsieur le premier ministre
sas profonde que nous donnons à notre
fonction d'élus de la nation incarnant
la démocratie représentative
loin des mirages du mandat impératif
avant toute chose nous savons combien
notre époque est celle d'un
bouleversement de nos repères avec un
monde en train de redéfinir les
équilibres géopolitiques en basculant
vers le pacifique avec une europe
politique
à la recherche d'un nouveau souffle pour
cinq quarts mais avec un modèle
économique qui est allé au bout de sa
logique ultra productiviste ce
capitalisme devenu fou dont a parlé le
président de l'admical genève avec une
transition écologique devenu une
nécessité absolue et qui doit dépasser
les clivages partisans
les français n'ayant montré leur
attachement à cette question lors du
scrutin européen
notre pays n'échappe évidemment pas à
ces mouvements profonds parfois
chaotique qui met à mal la promesse
républicaine d'égalité la crise des
liaisons andré seulement de justice
sociale mais aussi ses outrances
inacceptable année le symptôme
paroxystique que nous avons dit à cette
tribune
mon groupe pour sa part je suis en a
toujours de s'incliner devant la
pression de la rue
nous tirons notre légitimité du seul
suffrage universel c'est pourquoi nous
céderons pas au pessimisme bea des
déclinistes de tous bords au tueur et
faire du statu quo rien n'est plus faux
depuis 2017 nous sommes bien placés pour
savoir que de nombreuses réformes ont
été votés réformes sans cesse pendant ce
travail loi et la modernisation de la
formation professionnelle oui il ya des
signaux encourageants la france est
redevenue attractive pour les
investisseurs étrangers
les créations d'emploi progresse le
pouvoir d'achat s'améliore lentement
votre gouvernement sous l'impulsion du
président de la république a également
pris des mesures fortes et conséquences
pour les finances publiques afin de
répondre à une demande légitime
annulation de lance de la csg c'est de
retraite
repas des reports des eaux de carburant
des taxes sur l'énergie facilitation des
primes exceptionnelles
vous allez certes répondu la demande
urgente de revalorisation du pouvoir
d'achat premières préoccupations de nos
concitoyens comme l'a montré le grand
débat comme les cependant que ce n'est
pas suffisant
la souffrance qui s'est exprimée ne peut
rester sans réponse structurelle
monsieur bré ministère tient liste des
cultures de gauche et de droite vous
l'avez dit néanmoins vous le savez la
bipédie suppose un équilibre harmonieux
entre les deux hommes
celle de droite déjà b nourris et celle
de gauche
or notre pays ne peut plus se permettre
de codic et parce qu'une jambe serait
hyper trop rien par rapport à l'autre il
est temps de corriger ses déséquilibres
peut-être d'ailleurs ce que vous avez vu
signifier en déclarant que vous
souhaitiez remettre de la proximité et
de lui mettre dans votre politique
mais comment allez vous concilier ce
modèle de proximité que vous redécouvrez
avec la coastal c'est la cohérence que
vous avez rappelé peut-être est-ce aussi
pour cette raison que la semaine
dernière votre ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics affirmé vouloir le
site parler davantage au peuple
le principe ces réflexions ne peuvent
que nous convenir je vous le disais
d'ailleurs le 6 décembre dernier nous
sont avec vous pour soutenir des mesures
simples concrètes répondant aux besoins
de nos concitoyens
à rebours de la technocratie et rosé
notre pays oui beaucoup d'autres vont
dans le bon sens mais si elle ne manque
pas de susciter notre interrogation
quid du plan pauvreté qui semble au
point mort comment à vous allez vous
financer la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
toute parole ans à la péréquation
horizontale qu'elle n'est pas public
allez vous réduire pour financer les
baisses d'impôts quelle vision de la
laïcité souhaité vous portiez pour
combattre les factures communautariste
comment l'état peut-il mieux accompagner
les collectivités dans leurs projets de
développement et de soutien à les
génériques
je pense ici entre proposition de loi
relative à la jasse nationale de
cohésion des territoires
vous le savez c'est comme un gout matin
ce sont des actes forts pour nous la
promesse républicaine de l'égalité n'est
ni chimères n'est une relique
or chaque semaine nous voyons ce terrain
des femmes et des hommes en souffrance
des territoires victimes de fractures
ancienne et profonde
ce sont les zones rurales abandonné par
paris qui accumule ses aventures de
seysses public est facteur d'arc avant
ce sont les zones urbaines populaire qui
subissent et les retards économiques et
sociaux du pied trop longtemps ce sont
encore les zones périurbaines trop
excentré les métropoles pour profiter de
la richesse mais on doit vivre la classe
moyenne contre andy travailler malgré la
saturation des transports tous ses
citoyens ils ne réclament pas l'aumône
car le déclame prophétisé par seat n est
pas inexorable
ce qu'ils veulent c'est de la
considération le respect de leur dignité
ou pour le dire avec vos mots de la
civilité ne le rendent pas oublier par
exemple le triste épisode de la fin de
non recevoir opposée à la revalorisation
des pensions de retraite agricole
vous avez encore évoqué la défiance qui
se serait élevée
entre les français et leurs
représentants ou l'administration
vous apportez vos principales réponses
votre réforme institutionnelle dont une
grande partie ne soulève pas de
difficultés majeures
bien sûr la question de la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires et sensible non
pas par corpora qui sont comment
voudrait nous caricaturer pour mieux
nous stigmatiser mais bien parce qu'il
est question de représenter au mieux des
concitoyens et des territoires
monsieur le premier ministre le sénat
est l'achat mots résonnent les voix de
tous les territoires qu'il faut la
phrase toujours dans le respect et le
dialogue
je vous propose de poursuivre leurs
échanges avec le sénat en appliquant
cette méthode il sera toujours temps
s'il le faut de demander leur avis aux
français mais vous savez mieux que moi
que d'aucuns 6 a essayé sans succès pour
l'heure les votes derrière ce sont
divers
c'est notre liberté de ton certains la
majorité du groupe approuveront votre
déclaration de politique générale
mais n'y voyez pas un blessé d'autres
s'abstiennent mans car il attendait
vigilance que les engagements se
transforme l'acte les derniers 1 c'est
votre robe conte tout cas ils ne se
retrouvent pas dans notre ligne
politique
le
ne doutez pas n'en doutez pas cependant
que nous plaçons sommes tous la réussite
de notre pays au dessus des contingences
en résumé et en conclusion monsieur le
premie soins
restait à 80 à l'heure pour les mesures
libérales mais accéléré à 90 pour les
mesures sociales et territoriales
merci monsieur le président
je vais maintenant donner la parole à
monsieur le premier ministre pour qu'il
puisse répondre ou éclairer les orateurs
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs après un long
discours hier et un discours ce matin je
serai drêche voudrais remercier
l'ensemble des orateurs qui se sont
exprimés remercier plus particulièrement
le président patriat le président malgré
est également le président rock et qui
ont formulé un soutien général ou
majoritaire ou parfois existants
alors
et remercier l'ensemble de ceux qui se
sont exprimées à cette tribune hier et
ce matin j'ai choisi d'essayer
d'indiquer ce que nous allions faire le
calendrier que nous nous fixions la
méthode que nous entendions mettre en
oeuvre bien entendu en se fixant cet
objectif je ne peux pas détailler
l'ensemble des mesures et des
dispositifs qui seront inventés et
adopter pour une raison assez simple
d'abord qu'ils sont nombreux sont
complexes et que pour une grande partie
d'entre eux ils dépendront des
discussions qui se noueront soit avec
les associations d'élus s'agissant des
questions relatives aux collectivités
territoriales font évidemment sur tous
les sujets y compris cela avec les
parlementaires donner des dispositifs
arrêté alors que ils sont en cours de
préparation n'est pas possible et je
pense que chacun ici peut le comprendre
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne
rentrerai pas dans le détail des
remarques qui a évoqué le président
caennais sur le système universel des
retraites que nous voulons construire
je me permets simplement d'indiquer
monsieur le président que le haut
commissaire rendra ses préconisations en
juillet que ses préconisations
je peux le dire sont extrêmement
éloignée de ce que vous avez indiquée et
que nous aurons j'en suis certain
l'occasion de débattre dans le détail
d'une réforme qui est essentiel complexe
mais dont je veux redire qu'elle me
paraît juste et nécessaire
j'ai indiqué hier le souhait certains
l'ont doté d' inviter au dépassement
j'ai même utilisé à l'assemblée
nationale l'expression de changement de
ton je voudrais dire à l'ensemble des
membres du sénat comme je lé d'hier
l'ensemble des membres de l'assemblée
nationale qu'il ne s'agit en aucun cas
bien entendu d'une mise en accusation
mais bien d'une invitation que je
m'adresse à moi-même que j'adresse à
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
que j'adresse à l'ensemble de ceux qui
s'engagent en politique et même d'une
certaine façon à l'ensemble de ceux qui
s'expriment en politique
sphère médiatique comprise la qualité du
débat public de notre débat public
quel que soit d'ailleurs les idées que
nous soutenons mérite mieux que les
postures que les provocations que les
caricatures que les simplifications
excessives que les absences de
perspectives je le crois profondément
et si j'ai pu m'en rendre responsable
pour ma part je suis bien déterminé à
essayer de faire en sorte que cela ne
soit plus le cas
je pense que nous avons tous intérêt à y
gagner pas simplement le gouvernement
pas simplement le premier ministre
l'ensemble du débat public en france
nous avons évoqué et elle a souvent été
évoqué la question de la dépense
publique je ne vais pas rentrer dans le
détail de ce sujet mais peut-être
peut-être peut-être quand même indiquer
quelques chiffres pour planter le décor
la dette publique
la dette publique sur le pib 57 9% des
dettes publiques en 2000 en 1996 57,6 en
2000 64,4 en 2006 90,2 en 2012 98,4 en
2017 et 98 4 en 2018 nous nous renvoyons
à la face l'augmentation est le niveau
inégalé de la dette publique en france
ayant conscience que la progression
massive de la dette publique a été lié
aux quinze dernières années à la
réaction française à la crise financière
de 2007 et que depuis 2007 le rythme de
progression de la dépense publique et le
rythme de progression de la dette
publique n'a jamais était refroidi ou
chalmé jamais sachons le sachant aussi
que dans le calcul de la dette publique
pendant très longtemps j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire au sénat mais
j'insiste nous avons fait au fond comme
si il ne fallait pas tout content et
j'ai indiqué qu'un des éléments de la
réforme de la sncf que nous avons mis en
oeuvre étaient le fait que l'état et
donc la dette publique récupérer la
dette de la sncf
parce que depuis des années nous avons
fait comme si cette dette que supporter
l'entreprise n'était pas une dette
publique comme si comme si une
entreprise pouvait continuer à financer
comme à a fonctionné financièrement
comme la sncf si elle n'avait pas
derrière la garantie de l'état
autrement dit les dames et messieurs je
suis parfaitement d'accord avec ceux qui
ici considère que la dette publique
comme la dette écologique sont des
fardeaux que nous laissons reposer sur
les épaules de nos enfants je suis
convaincu de la nécessité de stabiliser
sa dette et de la réduire
convaincu je sais que ça n'est pas un
exercice facile je sais que ceux qui
disent la dépense publique n'a jamais
été aussi élevé en france disent vrai en
valeur absolue c'est évident mais alors
si on raisonne en valeur absolue on
pourrait dire aussi bien que le pit n'a
jamais été aussi élevé que les dépenses
sociales n'ont jamais été aussi élevées
que les dépôts
bien sûr en valeur absolue on peut
toujours dire cela puisque la croissance
année après année permet de faire
augmenter les chiffres ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le rythme de
progression de la dépense publique
rythme dont nous savons tous ici qu'il
est d'abord et essentiellement guidés
par le rythme de la dépense sociale de
la dépense de transfert dont nous savons
tous qu'elle est nécessaire
autrement dit faire en sorte que la
progression de la dépense publique soit
largement inférieure à la progression du
pib' est un exercice collectif
redoutablement complexe et je ne
l'abordent jamais avec facilité jeu de
la borne jamais avec des raccourcis
d'ailleurs si c'était simple c'est
exactement les chiffres inverse qu'on
dirait si c'était simple et si c'était
facile depuis 40 ans elle aurait
considérablement diminué et n'ignorait
pas de dette publique
vous voyez bien que nous sommes
confrontés tous ensemble à une situation
qui a parfois conduit les gouvernements
à faire des économies considérables sur
d'autres pour donner le sentiment qu'il
réduisait la dépense publique
si on veut faire de la réduction de la
dépense publique vite on utilise le
rabot c'est rapide
ça peut être efficace c'est rarement
malin si on veut réduire la dépense
publique dans la durée il faut faire des
réorganisations
c'est rarement rapide et c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus intelligent il
faut donc faire en sorte que nous
puissions réorganiser la façon de
produire un service la façon d'organiser
un dispositif d'accompagnement public
pour faire en sorte de maîtriser la
progression de cette dépense plus
intelligents mais c'est plus lent et ça
exige probablement plus de travailler
plus de travail collectif
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs certains attendent les
actes que j'ai annoncé d'autres les
redoutent
je voudrais dire à l'ensemble des
sénateurs y compris au président
marseille que j'ai oublié de citer tout
à l'heure et il m'en voudrais à juste
titre
et je n'en voudrai à juste titre et je
m'en excuse auprès de lui je voudrais
dire à l'ensemble des sénateurs ma
détermination et la détermination du
gouvernement à mettre en oeuvre la
méthode que j'ai évoquées hier devant
les députés
et devant l'ensemble du parlement à
mettre en oeuvre également les mesures
en matière d'urgence écologique de
justice sociale et de justice
territoriale qui sont au coeur de l'acte
ii de ce point de vue là mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
n'ayez aucun doute sur la détermination
du gouvernement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre c'est
na va donc procéder au vote sur la
déclaration de politique générale
article 39 alinéa 2 du règlement
conformément à notre règlement il va
être procédé un scrutin public à la
tribune c'est l'article 56 bis j'invite
nos collègues éric bocquet et dominique
de legge secrétaire du cedar a supervisé
à mes côtés les opérations de vote
voilà en attendant le vote de sénateurs
vous venez donc d'entendre cette
déclaration de politique générale du
premier ministre edouard philippe a donc
détaillé devant le sénat la feuille de
route pour la suite du quinquennat il a
précisé et c'était attendu ici à la
haute assemblée
le calendrier du projet de loi de
décentralisation et différenciation il
sera donc présenté à la force du premier
semestre 2020 en parallèle un projet de
loi pour favoriser l'engagement des
mères sera présenté avant la fin juillet
par sébastien lecornu ministre des
collectivités territoriales sur la
réforme des institutions le premier
ministre a redit qu'il attendait le
moment propice renvoyant la balle dans
le camp des sénateurs
il attend donc maintenant et bien ce
vote de confiance du sénat alexandre
poussard il a appelé on l'a entendu les
sénateurs à dépasser les clivages
anciens nous il est fini il a tout fait
dans son discours pour essayer d'obtenir
ce vote de confiance il a réservé aux
sénateurs les réformes territoriales de
l'acte ii de son quinquennat vous l'avez
dit ce nouvel acte de décentralisation
et puis ce projet loi pour l'engagement
des élus locaux et la démocratie de
proximité
alors il l'a dit clairement dans son
discours il est venu ce matin pour
obtenir la confiance des sénateurs
écoutez le
si j'utilise aujourd'hui l'alinéa 4 de
l'article 49 de la constitution pour
vous demander l'approbation de ma
déclaration de politique générale c'est
pour exprimer mon respect du
bicaméralisme du bicamérisme qui font
nos institutions est ma grande
considération chambre haute
cette procédure est rare dans l'histoire
de la vème république
j'ai choisi de l'utiliser par souci de
clarté de responsabilité dans un moment
de bascule de notre vie politique qui
nous invite à dépasser des clivages
anciens et derrière ces demandes de
confiance il y a un but à peine cachée
divisé la majorité de droite ici au
sénat après la défaite des républicains
aux élections européennes alors est-ce
que ce piège a fonctionné et ce qu'il a
réussi à diviser la droite et bien pas
vraiment le groupe est républicain va
rester unis dans l'abstention
écoutez la sénatrice dominique estrosi
sassone qui parlait au nom du groupe nr
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
comptons bien continuer à défendre nos
convictions sereinement mais fermement
sereinement car la politique ce n'est
pas la guerre nous ne voyons sur les
bancs du gouvernement
aucun ennemi nous nous désolons même d'y
voir siéger
certains de nos ânes ce que vous tendiez
la main au maire c'est votre droit que
quelques-uns la saisisse c'est leur
choix mais que certains tape sur les
doigts de ceux qui auraient l'impudence
de ne pas faire de même
cela est inacceptable
les élus locaux ne sont les obligés de
personnes les seuls devant lesquels ils
doivent répondre ce n'est ni vous ni
nous ce sont leurs administrés et
puisque la constitution nous a donné
pour mission de les représenter de
défendre leur liberté
nous vous disons monsieur le premier
ministre ne cédez pas de nouveau à la
tentation de la toute puissance qui
attend abîmé le lien de confiance avec
les élus locaux
alors du côté du groupe centriste qui
composent cette majorité au sénat et
bien les sénateurs centristes sont
divisés avec d'un côté les sénateurs qui
veulent faire confiance au gouvernement
et de l'autre des sénateurs qui veulent
s'abstenir en tout cas devoir philippe a
été bienveillant avec les groupes
politiques du sénat qui sont plutôt
constructif vis-à-vis du gouvernement à
savoir le groupe centriste le groupe les
indépendants le groupe rds eu évidemment
le groupe la république en marche voilà
le scrutin public a commencé ici dans
l'hémicycle à la tribune et 348
sénateurs vont voter individuellement
par ordre alphabétique alphabétique et
après ce vote on saura si l'abstention
des sénateurs sur ce vote de confiance a
obtenu une majorité
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes vos
précisions et à nous sommes ensemble et
bien ce matin pour cette édition
spéciale déclaration de politique
générale d'edouard philippe au sénat on
va continuer d'analysé est les gens les
enjeux de ce discours avec vous elles
nadia ce le goupe bienvenue à vous vous
êtes sénatrice centriste de la nièvre
alors on entendu votre présidence groupe
hervé marseille le groupe partagé entre
abstention et votre tour vous vous venez
vous ai bien de vous abstenir
oui absolument je me suis abstenu après
mûres réflexions et consultations et
bien évidemment discussions et débats ce
débat est très intéressant c'est tout à
l'honneur du président de la république
et du premier ministre surtout de nous
avoir donné cette occasion de nous
exprimer
moi à titre personnel je considère que
c'est indéfendable de s'opposer à
l'action d'un gouvernement
d'autant qu'il est dans une logique de
deux changements de renouveau est dans
une logique très positive et vertueuse
cependant il ya un gros mais je suis élu
d'un territoire très rurale qui savaient
pas de la nièvre
et nous avons encore trop souvent
l'occasion de sentir une différence
entre le discours et le projet est la
réalité de ce qui se passe sur nos
territoires
donc ça c'est la première chose je vais
pas obtenu de garanties en ce qui
concerne l'avenir des territoires
s'étaient pourtant attendus ici au sénat
ou chambre des territoires il n'y a rien
de nouveau eu six mais tout est verbal
il ya un tel décalage entre le discours
positif que l'on entend et ce qui se
passe concrètement dans nos territoires
avec le poids le premier ministre a
parlé des services publics qui se
rétractent mais chez nous le mouvement
s'aggrave
voilà on ferme les services publics on
ferme les services de santé
on ne ferme pas d'école mais en ferme
beaucoup de classe au camp voilà il faut
pas jouer sur les mots et nous sommes
constamment dans la bataille pour
essayer de défendre nos territoires
si bien que je ne peux pas pour
l'instant signé un blanc-seing danser
dans ces conditions donc attitude
d'attentes et on essaie en essayant de
garder l'espoir
et pourtant à dia c'est le groupe bien
edouard philippe est intervenu sur cette
question du statut des maires sur ces
élus locaux on sait que le gouvernement
cherche à les reconquérir je vous
propose de réécouter et d'infini nous ne
pourrons pas transformer le pays sont
les mères sans les élus locaux la
démocratie n'est qu'une coquille vide et
que nous disent les maires ils l'ont dit
et répété il paye le prix de baisses de
dotations et celui de la loi notre
notamment qui a pu conduire à la
création d'intercommunalité de taille
xxl et à des grandes régions qui sont
parfois encore contester et non pas
encore pas forcément contribué à
rapprocher les citoyens des lieux de
décisions j'en citerai un seul de
grand-bourg tu roules quand est-ce qu'on
arrête la machine à broyer la proximité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jeu
j'ai peut-être mes chers collègues
oublier de citer la date à laquelle ont
été adoptés les dispositifs législatifs
que je viens de mentionner
je crois que chacun s'en souvient
parfaitement ya une part de
responsabilité aussi des anciens
gouvernements c'est ce que semble dire
edouard philippe
oui oui bon ben voilà on n'en est plus à
l'heure de se rejeter les
responsabilités mais seulement moi
j'avais noté la même phrase à gérer mes
notes quand est-ce qu'on arrête la
machine à broyer la proximité et c'est
dramatique parce que on le sait en fait
le constat mais chez nous elle continue
on n'arrive pas à inverser cette
tendance
on est toujours toujours pas dans une
logique d'aménagement du territoire et
la proximité est dramatiquement
enfin voilà les broyer en effet chaque
jour davantage on va continuer
d'analyser les enjeux de ce scrutin je
vous rappelle que les sénateurs sont en
train de voter après la déclaration de
politique générale tentera lui vous êtes
avec le sénateur et l'air de la meuse
gérard longuet on sait que le groupe ait
l'air a majoritairement voté pour une
abstention parce que c'est son cas oui
qu'allez vous est ce que vous vous êtes
décidé monsieur longuet quel sera votre
vote on sait que la majorité du groupe
et l'air est bien devraient voter
l'abstention c'est ce qui a été dit hier
en réunion de groupe oui je moi je
défends l'abstention à l'égard du texte
d'edouard philippe on n'y a aucune
raison d'être contre la réforme des
retraites bien au contraire nous sommes
favorables à la réforme du financement
et de l'indemnisation du chômage
nous avons souhaité avec françois fillon
qu'il y ait un débat annuel sur les
migrations
on nous propose ce débat on va pas être
contre un discours de politique générale
de droit pour fait un discours de
politique dans lequel il ya des éléments
positifs il ya des incertitudes
j'en vois deux principales la première
c'est que tout ce qui a été annoncé par
le président de la république n'est
financé en rien et donc là il ya un
point d'interrogation énorme
pourrons-nous être au rendez vous des
contraintes européennes
on les savait la dépense publique c'est
la première difficulté et deuxièmement
sur la décentralisation sur la vie
locale il y a un intérêt ces nouveaux
tant mieux mais on demande à voir parce
que pour l'instant il n'y a strictement
aucune mesure concrète j'ajoute enfin
l'attitude un petit peu désinvolte de
deux d'edouard philippe sur la réforme
institutionnelle une wii wii le
président veut diminuer les effectifs
enfin ça dépend de vous alors si vous le
faites tant mieux si vous le faites pas
tant pis désinvolte
n'y at il pas aussi une forme de calcul
politique de dire qu'on attend que le
sénat soit d'accord ça ne marche pas ça
serait bien de la faute du sénat oui
c'est vrai savoir d'où nous avons une
position simple on est prêt à bouger à
condition que tous les départements
français est un sénateur au moins un
l'écart repose si vous voulez la
différence soyons clairs c'est entre 300
264 sénateur ou 286 je crois qu'il ya
moins de vingt sénateurs d'écart oui ces
266 et 284 il ya des gis sénateurs des
cas on devrait pouvoir s'entendre
vous avez parlé à aussi bien des mesures
en matière de décentralisation
effectivement il ya deux projets de loi
qui sont annoncées dans le discours du
premier ministre
le premier n'est t'il pas façonné
directement et bien pour satisfaire les
maires avant les municipales pour in
enfin je vous rappelle que la le sénat
vient d'adopter un texte une proposition
de loi sur le statut de mère disait le
gouvernement c'est le gouvernement
reprend nos propositions n'a aucune
raison d'être contre
et d'ailleurs vous savez les maires
organisent leur majorité en fonction des
équipes locales et certainement pas en
fonction d'un jambes sur nationale
qu'elle vienne de telle ou telle
personnalité de la république en marche
un petit peu de troupes autosatisfaite
l'objectif bretons ils ont quand même
perdu leur pari ils sont derrière le
front national
pour nous on est dans les choux mais eux
ont perdu leur pari vous êtes dans les
choux dites vous justement l'objet
provisoirement pour l ère pour le groupe
ici au sénat en dessinant l'abstention
c'est de ne pas trop se faire conter
comme on pouvait l'espérer blanc c'est
d'être conforme à l'attitude d'un homme
politique élu au sénat qui est de
représenter son territoire en étant
fidèle à ses convictions mais sans aucun
sectarisme ou bien merci beaucoup gérard
longuet d'avoir su jamais question merci
beaucoup et âme pour cette nouvelle
réaction on entendu nadia c'est le goût
à l'instant où gérard longuet parler
d'une attitude désinvolte du premier
ministre en ce qui concerne la réforme
des institutions je le dis
et renvoie la balle dans le camp des
sénateurs nous la présenterons quand le
moment sera venu quand il y aura un
moment propice gérard larcher refusant
d'endosser cette responsabilité quelle
est votre position
oui alors où en effet on sent qu'il ya
un jeu politique entre les deux alors
c'était une proposition de tous les
partis politiques donc voilà après
comment est-ce que surtout les électeurs
vont se retrouver dans cette espèce de
de jeu entre deux bons s'il ya vraiment
besoin de réformer la constitution c'est
ridicule de se renvoyer la balle il faut
attaquer le dossier par contre moi ce
qui me fait trembler c'est sur la
réforme de la constitution
exactement comme sur la loi de
décentralisation qui nous est annoncé
j'ai l'impression qu'on va fonctionner
toujours pareil c'est à dire avec une
calculette au nombre d'habitants et
comment est ce qu'on peut dire aux
territoires peu peuplés qu'on va être
entendu et défendu d'ailleurs on a
entendu dans les propos de monsieur
longuet en tout le monde réagit avec une
calculette
mais pour moi il n'est pas possible
qu'ils aient des territoires enfin je
prends encore l'exemple de ce qui se
passe chez moi chez nous on va perdre
50% de représentation nationale c'est
pas une diminution de 25% ses 50%
donc la copie qui est actuellement sur
le bureau du premier ministre nous elle
nous torpilles on ne peut pas l'accès
non 20 sénateurs puisque c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit le gouvernement propose de
161 le sénat 281 mais non mais le
problème c'est où
parce que si c'est avec une calculette
les territoires peu peuplés se font
étranglée voilà c'est où
voilà sont maintenant on arrive à
croiser et apprendre des critères croisé
qui sont des critères de démographie et
détendue du territoire et au quelqu'un
on aura notre place et y aurait une
vraie représentation soit comme à chaque
fois que ce soit pour les fermetures des
classes que vous comme pour la
représentation nationale
c'est au nombre d'habitants est en nous
étrangle et on peut pas s'en sortir
alors on a parlé justement de cette
révision constitutionnelle je vous
propose de réécouter le premier ministre
dire philippe et la réponse de votre
collection matrice dominique estrosi
sassone sénatrice et l'air
le président de la république a accepté
de revoir sa proposition de baisse d'un
tiers du nombre de parlementaires pour
viser une réduction d'un quart qui
permet une juste représentation
territoriale et l'introduction d'une
dose significative de proportionnelle à
l'assemblée
concrètement aujourd'hui il me semble
que nous ne sommes pas éloigné d'un
accord sur le projet de loi
constitutionnelle mais pas sur le projet
de loi organique et en particulier mais
pas seulement sur la question du nombre
de parlementaires le sénat a été très
clair sur le fait qu'ils ignoraient
d'accord sur rien s'il n'y avait pas
d'accord sur tout et c'est parfaitement
respectable comme est parfaitement
respectable je crois la position du
gouvernement qui ne souhaitent pas à
mobiliser du temps parlementaire si in
fine et ils s'exposaient aux désaccords
du cerf nous ne renonçons donc pas nos
ambitions qui nous le pensons sont
conformes à la demande de nos
concitoyens nous attendrons le moment
propice et la manifestation de volonté
du sénat nous pouvons aussi voté
seulement la proportionnelle à
l'assemblée sans changer nombre de
députés chacun jugera dans quelle mesure
il tient à résoudre les points de
désaccord qui demeure
chacun jugera dans quelle mesure ils
considèrent que cette réforme
constitutionnelle peut être un
instrument de renouveau démocratique et
de réconciliation nationale oui une
révision constitutionnelle est possible
elle est possible si le gouvernement
fait preuve de cette ouverture que vous
mettez pourtant en avant autant nous
saluons votre décision d'avoir renoncé à
certaines atteintes au parlement autant
nous déplorons que sur la question de la
représentation des territoires et donc
des dans celle du nombre de
parlementaires
vous sembliez privilégier le rapport de
force voire la pression pour nous qui
portons la voix des territoires
ce point n'est pas secondaire il est
majeur car il touche à la justice
territoriale
il est juste que tous les territoires
soient représentés il est juste qu'il
n'y ait pas plus de 20 départements ne
disposant que d'un sénateur et que cette
garantie fasse l'objet d'une disposition
constitutionnelle alors qu'on vient
d'entendre dominique estrosi sassone on
va peut-être d'en savoir plus justement
c'est ça la question de la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires avec vous au
thème traduit avec le ministre
l'agriculture didier guillaume et oui
effectivement parler on va parler de la
révision constitutionnelle mais plutôt
du package qu'il ya autour de la
révision constitutionnelle et notamment
la question de la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires
vous avez entendu la majorité
sénatoriale qui dit pour nous il est
essentiel de pouvoir la conserver une
représentation équilibrée des
territoires et donc on ne peut pas trop
réduire ce nombre de parlementaires vous
êtes d'accord oui bien sûr mais le
gouvernement est d'accord je pense que
la révision constitue constitutionnel
est quelque chose d'important mais en
même temps il faut que tous les
départements puissent avoir un sénateur
il faut que les territoires ruraux plus
être représenté donc il n'ya pas de l'y
a pas vraiment de différence entre le
gouvernement et le sénat vous dites
majorité sénatoriale mais il s'agit pas
de de parler à la majorité sénatoriale
il s'agit de parler au sénat de la
république est sec et le plus important
je pense que nous aujourd'hui on a
constaté que ça allait être compliqué et
appartements où c'est compliqué le
gouvernement a fait le choix de ne pas
mettre tous les textes maintenant ce
qu'on va pas perdre encore trois fa
perdra pas débattre pendant 3 mois s'il
n'y a pas d'accord au bout donc si on
sent qu'il peut y avoir un accord on
verra bien des choses comme elles se
passeront mais débattent pour débattre
il ya beaucoup d'autres sujets comme les
retraites comme l'assurance chômage
comme la loi sur la décentralisation qui
va démarrer en septembre au sénat qui
est également essentiel pour nos
territoires n'est pas non plus une façon
d'imputer la faute d'un éventuel échec
de cette révision constitutionnelle au
sénat veut dire si ça ne fonctionne pas
c'est à cause du sénat mais je crois que
c'est pas du tout ça l'état d'esprit
mais enfin si ça ne fonctionne pas c'est
parce que le sénat n'aura pas voté
n'aura pas pris sa part alors maintenant
l'exécutif est prêt à discuter c'est ya
aucun ya aucun problème nous verrons
bien
faut pas s'arrêter là dessus je crois
que le prémunit dans son discours le
global sur ce sujet il a fait beaucoup
d'ouverture ben on va suivre les choses
on a également et bien entendu à
l'annonce 2 deux projets de loi en
matière de décentralisation tu vois si
autour du statut du maire notamment
il faut se réconcilier aujourd'hui avec
les territoires après une première
partie de mandat difficile
oui mais ce n'est pas une première
partie de mandat difficile parce que
dans le précédent quinquennat c'était
terrible la relation avec les
associations d'élus notamment avec les
maires
que nous voulons réaffirmer suite au
grand débat c'est tout simplement que le
maire est comment dire le soldat de base
de la république les hussards de la
république et celui qui a qui apporte et
d'engueulades qui tous les jours
rencontre ses concitoyens il doit être
déjà largement gérard larcher l'a dit et
donc sur le maire doit être soutenu et
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement veut
déposer deux projets de loi un projet de
loi sur la décentralisation qui est
absolument indispensable sur la
différenciation on ne gère pas la lozère
et la région parisienne delà même de la
même façon il faut donner plus de
pouvoirs au maire et puis il faut le
voir revenir sur un certain nombre de
difficultés
il ya des intercommunalités xxl avec des
compétences qui ne correspond peut-être
pas à ce que souhaitent les gens tout
cela ça peut ça peut être bouger vous
savez nous avons entendu ce qui s'est
passé pendant six mois dans le dans le
pays
entendu la colère des françaises et des
français le président de la république
qui a répondu avec des plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'économies de
baisse de baisses d'impôts
la colère des maires et des élus le
gouvernement y répond nous sommes je
pense en phase avec la population
l'opinion publique les élus nous devons
travailler ensemble la deuxième étape
deuxième phase du quinquennat
dans le cadre du rassemblement et de
l'unité du peuple français
un mois l'ancien président du groupe
socialiste au sénat est ce que vous
pensez qu'un certain nombre de
socialistes peuvent voter pour et
approuvé cette déclaration politique
franc je ne crois pas c'est pas d'état
d'esprit du du groupe puis 6 s'il devait
y avoir des sénateurs qui ont voté pour
ben ils ne seraient plus de fait dans le
groupe je ne crois pas que peut-être
certains s'interrogent à s'abstenir
invraisemblablement salue aujourd'hui
tout n'est pas blanc tout n'est pas noir
tout n'est pas rose tous n'est pas bleu
je connais beaucoup de d'élus
socialistes qui se posent à ce nombre de
questions et aujourd'hui âgée été prise
dans un groupe dans leur scandé d'argent
groupe lorsqu'on y reste on demande à ce
que l'on suive un peu là la règle
générale mais dans un vote comme celui
ci il se peut qu'ils année quelques-uns
peut-être qu'ils s'abstiennent je ne
sais pas comme si j'ai bien compris sera
le cas dans tous les groupes
à part le groupe communiste je pense que
dans tous les groupes il y aura des
votes différents bien merci beaucoup
d'idées guillaume d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup pour cet
si on a entendu un patrick kanner qui
dit il ya des ministres qui envoient des
sms vous avez eu le sentiment de
dépression justement sur votre vote ce
matin ana dias allgoob au nom vous savez
le sénateur de la nièvre n'intéresse pas
grand monde donc je suis tout à fait
l'écart de tout ça par contre je
voudrais rebondir si vous permettez sur
ce qui a été dit à mon sens c'est zéro
département avec moins de deux sénateurs
parce que un seul sénateur sur un
territoire très étendu
c'est pas une représentation
satisfaisante tout le monde a l'air de
partir sur le tous les départements où
au moins un sénateur
mais c'est absolument loin d'une réalité
et pour voir faire un travail correct
sur le terrain à sénateurs ça peut
tomber malade
et puis ça peut pas non plus faire vingt
mille kilomètres par mois
moi je fais entre 5 et 6000 km par mois
on est deux sur notre territoire ont
fait la même chose tous les deux et on y
arrive à peine donc voilà il faut bien
mettre la jauge au bon endroit
et puis s'il faut les répartir autrement
sur le territoire alors il faut attaquer
ce chantier on a entendu également les
précisions d'edouard philippe sur le
calendrier de la décentralisation il y
aura un projet de loi avant la fin du
premier semestre 2020 projet de loi de
décentralisation et différenciation
c'était attendu ça fait ça vient à point
nommé justement sur de nouveaux projets
loin oui il est temps d'attaquer ce
chantier merci merci c'est très bien on
va en attendent beaucoup
il faudra pas que nos espoirs soient
déçus et comme je vous le disais le
projet de supprimer les irritations créé
par la loi nôtre a dit edouard philippe
alors là c'est très difficile parce
qu'en même temps les collègues élus ont
tellement souffert
et puis là ils viennent de passer quand
même à peu près après la loi note une
année à ne pas pouvoir rentrer ou très
difficilement dans vraiment une
politique de projets à ce qu'il en était
simplement à prendre des délibérations
administratives pour essayer de tout
calé entre les aspects fiscaux entre les
compétences donc là ils atterrissent à
peine je pense qu'ils aspirent aussi à
de la stabilité
par contre moi je pense qu'il nous
faudrait une ce n'est que justice est
logique
une évaluation chiffrée de ces
regroupements parce qu'on en avait quand
même vendu comme une mesure qui nous
permettrait de dégager des grosses
économies on nous a dit y avoir moins
d'élus on va faire un tas d'économies
maintenant on aimerait bien quand même
savoir où sont les économies et puis
qu'on ait l'honnêteté de nous le dire
avant de continuer ce débat on retourne
à salle des conférences puisque aller
naters en train de voter on voit savoir
dans quelques instants
eh bien le vote du sénat à ce que ce
soit un vote de confiance
on sait déjà que la majorité sénatoriale
de droite ici a choisi et bien
l'abstention tan traduit vous êtes vous
avec le président du groupe en marche le
sénateur de la côte d'or françois
patriat qu'at-il pensé cette déclaration
de politique générale au sénat et oui
qu'avez vous pensé de cette déclaration
de politique générale
et puis notamment de cette phrase qui a
fait réagir dans l'hémicycle lorsque le
premier ministre a dit quand est-ce
qu'on arrête la machine à broyer la
proximité ils reprenaient les mots d'un
élu à grand-bourg tu roules lors du
grand débat on le sait est bien
l'exécutif a été largement accusé
d'avoir vrai à cette fracture aussi avec
les territoires mais j'ai compris
l'averse ce que vous venez de me dire
quand les merdes 10 arrêtant le machine
à broyer de quoi parle-t-il
il parle de la baisse des dotations il
parle de la loi notre il parle des
grandes intercommunalités des grandes
régions de choses tous antérieures monde
a de la gueule matignon qui ont été
prises entre 2010 et 2017
donc s'il ya eu de l'éloignement s'il ya
eu des baisses pour les collectivités ce
que ne fait pas le gouvernement
aujourd'hui
eh bien c'est la responsabilité mais on
n'est pas dans ce jeu aujourd'hui de
porter les responsabilités
je trouve que de leur a donné cette
responsabilité au gouvernement actuel
c'est une contre vérité à temps pointé
du doigt ce quoi caractère distant son
dédain jacobins les attendait à kent
notes dans la première moitié du mois
j'accompagne le président souvent je les
accompagner dans la grande itinérance
c'était avant les jls
j'ai pu voir à quel point la proximité
du chef de l'état était réelle et
profonde avec les maires les heures
qu'il a passées à vendre en débat 1
c'est au mois de novembre - d'octobre
font des déplacements à chaque fois que
le président se déplace il rencontre les
élus il fait des réunions avec les
maires avec tous n'y a pas que le
président l'aimé français adrian et le
gouvernement donnait le gouvernement je
prends je prends le chef de l'état parce
qu'on la préfère parler de distance
s'était pas au gouvernement constat
dressé city à lui ou ou au chef du
gouvernement edouard philippe lui même
qui mère qui est un élu local connaît
les élus locaux qui les reçoit souvent
qui les rencontre souvent je pense que
ça aussi c'est une deuxième
contre-vérité certain nombre de faits
comme ça sur lesquels il faut revenir et
rappeler aux réalités en tout cas il ya
deux projets de loi qui ont été
annoncées un premier but au tour plus
tôt du statut du maire on l'a compris
qui est pour la fin de l'année
c'est aussi un projet dans vue des
municipales si on veut accompagner mieux
les maires remédier à la crise de
vocation faire en sorte que les me que
les mandats soient mieux assumer avec
plus de simplicité plus de proximité
avec on a intérêt à le faire avant les
municipales
ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens avant si on
veut redonner du sens à l'action locale
et aux locaux
vous allez le terrain il faut qu'on leur
donne des signaux forts et le faire à
travers un texte de loi me paraît être
la meilleure méthode
et quant au deuxième acte l'acte de
décentralisation qui est promis qu'en
attendre françois patriat la
décentralisation j'ai toujours entendu
des idées générales pas toujours des
idées concrètes
or là le premier ministre a évoqué ce
matin des points sur lesquels il fallait
éviter les doublons ferrand sort ce qui
est plus qu'une personne qui décide
données de la donner de la lisibilité de
la visibilité et de l'efficacité
je crois que c'est ce qu'ont pu attendre
de leur et fonde sur une centralisation
la merci à beaucoup françois patriat
pour votre réaction
bien sûr je ne vous demande pas votre
vote qui bien sûr positif à trois
groupes la république en manque dans sa
totalité à voter pour le soutien qu en
voulant nous merci beaucoup françois
patriat d'avoir de tendresse en question
exactement dans la nuit alain richard
qui nous a rejoint sur ce plateau parle
d'ailleurs d'un déferlement certains
sénateurs la république en marche du val
d'oise ancien ministre merci d'être avec
nous et jérôme bascher a également
quitté l'hémicycle le temps que le vote
se poursuivent sénateurs l air de l'oise
qu'avez vous pensé à la richarde cette
déclaration de politique générale
un peu différente c'est normal ici au
sénat de celle prononcée à l'assemblée
nationale il ya notamment via un geste
qui a été fait envers les territoires
c'était attendu et nécessaire
je lui dis franchement ce que je pense
de ce débat le président à engager la
france dans une vague de réformes pour
la rendre plus compétitive plus
productive plus innovantes
ces réformes sont difficiles il faut
toujours un peu de courage pour les
accompagner pour attendre les résultats
qui prennent du temps
ce que je vois dans cette déclaration
c'est que cette politique va être
poursuivie qui aura des aménagements et
des concessions ici ou là qu'on fera
surtout l'effort de dialoguer au maximum
avec l'ensemble des partenaires et que
cette politique va être poursuivi et
j'observe avec un peu de satisfaction
les oppositions restent les bras
ballants devant le développement de
cette politique
elles savent qu'elle est nécessaire pour
le pays elles savent qu'elles les
difficultés auxquelles sont tentés de
les exploiter
mais le jugement qu'elles viennent de
subir de la part des électeurs
les rangs aphone et ça se traduit par
150 abstention c'est la jambe est certes
je peux te fait la même lecture que
richard mais c'est normal
en fait on confond l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat et comme nous sommes des
grands défenseurs du sénat
nous n'avons pas approuver ou
désapprouver la politique le discours
politique générale ce n'est pas l'esprit
de la vème république et vous le savez
aussi bien que moi donc c'est dit-il
construire cette victoire c'est pour ça
qu'un article la constitution qu'il
prévoit oui mais n'a pas prévu que le
gouvernement était responsable devant le
sénat et il n'est pas nous n'avons pas
de motion de censure à le faire donc
c'est une petite mais interprétation
mais je suis sûr qu'ils ont à dire vais
juste un point pour revenir à votre
question initiale sur les élus locaux et
ce qu'ils ont été écoutés sans nul doute
est ce qu'ils ont été entendus j'en suis
moins sûr car que lorsque le premier
ministre nous dit à juste titre que la
dgf ne bouge pas la dotation globale de
fonctionnement pour les communes c'est
vrai le problème c'est que ça va à la
ville ça ne va pas à la campagne et eu
égard aux je crois je parle sous le
contrôle de la richard créer ça mieux
que moi aux 50 de critères qui est
présidente à la dgf et bien évidemment
personne n'y comprend rien mais y'a
critère qui est à peu près clair et qui
est compris par tous ces sujets de la
population ont fait vivre des communes
avec des charges fixes et on le réduit
leurs dotations
c'est cela c'est cela qui se base dont
les petites copines vous allez réduite
non mais il faut voir la réalité il y à
quelques communes qui gagne
il ya quelques communes qui gagne et il
ya l'essentiel les communes qui perdent
et ce sont ces communes là qui ont voté
front national se sont dit non parce que
le front national pour moi vous comme
pour moi c'est une menace et je le sais
mais hélas il ya des faits objectifs les
faits l'objectif c'est que la majorité
des communes voient diminuer sa dgf
c'est ça les fait aux objectifs et une
fraîcheur mission est bien donc une
proposition dans l'avion discuter
d'ailleurs ici il ya d'autres
propositions à faire et notamment de
stabiliser pour les communes leur
dotation mais pour tout et faire un vrai
gel et donc revoir ses 50 de critères
tout prix ne répond pas effectivement
qu'il ya un débat était maintenue et
qu'elle est stable est ce que certaines
communes bien le vivent notamment comme
une baisse de leurs dotations
comparativement forcément puisqu'on
augmente parallèlement leur mission
chaque jour il faut qu'ils en fassent
davantage
alors ils ont forcément l'impression
d'avoir au moins pour faire face à
toutes ces missions nouvelles qui leur
arrive
alors on va poser ce débat on le voit
qui vous passionne mais c'est mon retour
salle des conférences puisque la garde
des sceaux nicole belloubet est avec
thème traduit ce we à nicole belloubet
nous allons parler ensemble d'abord de
la révision constitutionnelle vous avez
terminé votre consultation auprès
notamment des présidents de groupe à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat pour
vous qu'est ce qui coince
aujourd'hui effectivement nous avons
avec marc fesneau reçu les présidents de
groupe cd réunion très constructive dans
l'ensemble thème qui nous ont permis à
la fois de voir qu'il y avait
globalement un accord sur le texte
constitutionnel qui vous le savez repose
sur trois piliers fondamentaux les
territoires la démocratie participative
et la justice le projet de loi organique
qui coince voilà et il y a effectivement
une loi organique et noah ordinaire et
c'est cela qui sans doute créer
davantage de difficultés notamment dans
les points d'attention sur lequel le
sénat nous que le sénat nous a fait
valoir
il y a par exemple la question de
l'entrée en vigueur de ces dispositions
que nous avons prévu en une fois et pour
lesquels le sénat nous dit que c'est une
ligne rouge qu'il faut absolument garder
l'idée du renouvellement partiel se pose
également la porte est fermée pour bien
sûr le renouvellement total en 2021 de
la part du sénat est clairement se pose
également la question de la
circonscription d'élection des sénateurs
qui pourraient être séduites mans du
sénat inscrite dans la constitution il
ya également le sujet du nombre de
sénateurs
bref un certain nombre de points sur
lequel axes sur lesquels actuellement
nous sommes obligés de constater qu'il
n'y a pas d'accord or les sénateurs et
c'est tout à fait normal le président
larcher l'a dit il faut un accord
surtout avant de pouvoir voter la
constitution donc nous constatons qu'il
n'y a à ce stade pas d'accord sur tout
pour autant nous allons évidemment
passer le texte en conseil des ministres
et le déposer sur le bureau de
l'assemblée nationale
et j'imagine que nous allons continuer à
travailler parce que le texte
fonctionnel contient de vraies ambitions
qui apporte des vraies réponses merci il
n'y a pas d'accord au final eh bien vous
pourrez dire que c'est la responsabilité
du sénat lorsque vous dit
qu'effectivement vous allez attendre
qu'il puisse y avoir un accord du sénat
sur le global pour continuer à avancer
ne pas faire perdre du temps chez vous
le dis à la fois nous allons engager le
processus conseil des ministres dépôt
mais pour le moment la corde n'est pas
totale donc nous allons attendre les
moments où c'est cet accord pourra être
réalisée je crois que c'est important de
montrer que nous avons la volonté
d'avancer
puisqu'il ya déjà eu des convergences
qui ont permis des rapprochements et
bien je suis sûr que dans un délai
raisonnable ces convergences
continueront à s'affirmer
nous avons beaucoup de travail
parlementaire et dans la tente de cet
accord nous aurons également la
possibilité de faire avancer un certain
nombre de textes fondamentaux sur la
fonction publique sur les retraites
nicole belloubet ya un autre sujet bien
sûr qu'il a été de nombreux sujets qui
ont été abordés lors de ce discours de
politique générale parmi eux il ya aussi
et bien la pma pour toutes avec un texte
qui serait présenté fin septembre vous
n'avez pas peur et bien de remettre sur
la table à un débat on s'est compliqué
très inflammables c'est un débat
compliqué nous ne nions pas c'est pour
autant un engagement que le président de
la république avait pris au moment de la
campagne des élections présidentielles
c'est une demande forte d'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyennes et donc nous
souhaitons aller en ce sens il y a
une fois que nous disons que la pma est
autorisé d'autres questions qui se
posent notamment autour de la filiation
de l'établissement de la filiation
ce sont ces sujets là qui sont très
sensibles évidemment que nous allons
traiter avec beaucoup d'attention
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion de faire
des présentations aux parlementaires des
présentations neutre pour les entendre
pour les sensibiliser au sujet je crois
que cela contribue à un débat que
j'espère apaisé sur ces questions et
bien rendez vous en tout cas fin
septembre un souriceau débat merci
beaucoup madame initialement répondu à
mes questions
merci beaucoup tam pour cette réaction à
alain richard on voit bien
le gouvernement sur la révision
constitutionnelle sur cette réforme des
institutions qui finalement renvoie la
balle dans le camp des sénateurs le
moment propice n'est pas venu alors est
ce qu'on va pouvoir parvenir à un accord
et voter cette réforme une bonne chance
je connais par viel en réalité les
sénateurs sont divers
l'opposition de droite est majoritaire
au sénat et se serrent copieusement de
cette situation majorité enfin nous
avons le droit d'avoir des opinions
différentes elles représentent ont des
positions différentes
donc cette opposition au sénat a exprimé
à plusieurs reprises qu'elle acceptait
l'idée d'une réduction du nombre de
sénateurs elle dit en revanche que le
nom de 33% de 30% et paraît excessif et
mon petit doigt me dit que même le
chiffre de 25% et par est sans doute
exagéré si le gouvernement souhaite
qu'on sorte de cette situation là tant
il me semble qu'il devrait poursuivre le
dialogue avec les leaders de
l'opposition de droite au sénat
voilà ce qui a réagi par communiqué de
presse il dit je ne comprends pas cette
position du gouvernement de quoi at-il
peur dit il il ya une demande et que
j'ai réaffirmée de dialogue
oui on a l'impression s'est bloquée pas
du tout il dit simplement nous voyons
nous avons des désaccords de chiffres
mais j'entends aussi des expressions
politiques de la part de sénateurs de
l'opposition qui contestent ouvertement
l'idée même d'une réduction du nombre
je pense que même les jours de
d'enthousiasmé vous demanderais qu on
augmente le nombre de parlementaires
donc il faut clarifier cette question là
il me semble mort évite avait dit pas de
caricature mais c'est pour ça que je
courais raisons j'avais mal entendu moi
je crois avoir entendu des gens qui est
qui contestaient totalement dans votre
camp politique
la réduction du nombre de sénateurs en
disant il faut que tous les territoires
sont représentés dont il faut des
sénateurs partout je crois avoir entendu
des territoires
dans tous les territoires etc mais
laurence pression est ce que tu es roche
puisque vous représentez cette droite
nos positions est-ce que je suis la
majorité sénatoriale a droit
d'opposition
la majorité sénatoriale et j'appelle ça
la droite d'opposition et sur la très
petite minorité de la vie lorsque cette
agression nous sommes dans la diversité
mais est-ce que sur une baisse plus
limitée du nombre de sénateurs vous êtes
prêt à conclure un compromis
tout le monde voit que c'est le seul
sujet parce qu'on rappelle un poids
l'instant les chiffres le gouvernement
propose 4 133 députés et 2 161 sénateurs
le sénat quatre cent soixante huit
députés et 280 un sénateur
ça fait une différence de 20 sénateurs
bâton compromettre et ces deux questions
sur le mariage c'est formidable mais
nous l'avons écrit le preuve d'ailleurs
vous savez si vous le demandez c'est
pour mieux vous savez nous n'avons pas
attendu la déclaration de politique
générale
gérard larcher a écrit au premier
ministre il ya huit jours
je peux que les chefs de seclin à bah
oui mais vous savez c'est faux et faut
demander à votre premier ministre nous
avons eu connaissance gérard larcher
nous la luge donc c'est une lettre du
parti
c'est une lettre du président du sénat
mais qui n'engage que ses amis ses amis
politiques
non ça c'est ce que vous dites c'est
bien de résumer j'aime beaucoup vraiment
que vous y bien entendu le premier
ministre lawrence est là aucune aucune
caricature
ils précisaient les conditions de la
réforme et sont connues et notamment la
juste représentation des territoires et
que tous les territoires oui tous les
territoires sont représentés et
notamment nos compatriotes ultramarins
car ceux là on les oublie cette réforme
à -25%
c'est réduire à rien les territoires
ultramarins
voilà la vérité des chiffres voilà et
oui vertige et insight relève regarder
il faut les regarder je les connais par
coeur mais la douleur vers des parker
met donc vous demander par omission à ce
moment là avec ça je ne veux pas le
croire
pas du tout vous savez aussi bien que
moi que cela constitue le conseil
constitutionnel a toujours admis que la
première tranche de population celle à
partir duquel on passe de 1 à 2 soit
plus basse que les autres
voilà par conséquent même avec 2 161
sénateurs
il est parfaitement licite il est
parfaitement conforme à la constitution
que on passe de la première à la
deuxième tranche à 250000 habitants ce
qui permet vous oubliez cette arme est
que je finisse de raisonnement non mais
vous oubliez les les grandes salles de
bains porte-voix pour lequel se tient
plus le prix nobel donc c'est plus le
c'est plus une première parce que c'est
la solution qu'a vous parlez du conseil
constitutionnel or la jurisprudence et
vous la connaissez encore mieux que moi
je vais vraiment m'incliner face à votre
connaissance
sauf que vous avez beaucoup d'oublier ça
je suis étonné de votre part lorsque
vous faites cela quand vous passez sur
les grandes les grandes grands
départements ceux qui doivent être
représentés vous créez là une grande
distorsion plus de sur les populations
venaient bien sûr soda le même temps
dans tous les domaines on va repasser
salle des conférences et non le thème
travail nous attend avec ceux ci le cul
pierre mal sénatrice communiste de la
loire pour une réaction c'est à vous oui
cécile cukierman est bien tout d'abord
votre regard sur ce discours de
politique générale d'edouard philippe
tout à l'heure la présidente du groupe
eliane assassi a bien dit il ya ce n'est
pas les 2 3 de gauche c'est bien
clairement un discours de droite
oui je crois que sans surprise j'ai
envie de dire le premier ministre
s'inscrit dans la continuité on nous a
beaucoup parlé d'un acte 2 finalement
qui sera assez similaire à l'acte 1 du
gouvernement la volonté en tout cas pour
lui de conduire et de poursuivre des
réformes libérales et d'ailleurs il ya
des grands absents je crois dans son
discours il n'a pas parlé de celle des
de ceux qui au quotidien souffre de
comment est-ce que l'on permet
d'augmenter les salaires dans notre pays
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat est
finalement d'assurer à chacune et à
chacun à chacun quelle que soit sa
condition sociale sa condition
territoriale de pouvoir vivre mieux
demain dans notre pays il ya eu tout de
même bien des annonces au niveau
territorial justement en disant qu'il
veut plus désormais de proximité n'y at
il pas un changement à ce niveau là un
acte 2 par rapport à un acteur un où on
pouvait le dire derrière les masaï a
parlé du dédain jacomin avait fait
preuve le gouvernement mais je crois
qu'effectivement on a eu notre cas ce
matin une entrée en matière un peu plus
approfondie sur la volonté territoriales
après je crois que maintenant on va on
va passer aux actes réels
la coopération pour dire que l'on va
rapprocher la décision et redonner leur
place aux élus locaux
encore faut-il réellement leur en donner
les moyens et leur en donner les moyens
ça passe bien évidemment par le projet
de loi qui devra garantir et sécuriser
l'action des élus locaux
cela passe également par des moyens aux
collectivités territoriales pour leur
permettre de mettre en place les
politiques qui doivent répondre aux
besoins notamment de service public
local
donc voilà c'est un ensemble et cela ne
peut pas se résumer à quelques articles
et je crois que vu là où nous en sommes
il y aura besoin de beaucoup pour
effectivement n'ont pas retrouvé la
confiance des élus parce qu'ils ont la
confiance et dans ce qu'ils font mais en
tout cas retrouver ce lien et ce
maillage indispensable entre une
démocratie locale et une démocratie
nationale qui est garante du bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions
un autre volet de ce discours de
politique générale fait beaucoup réagir
les sénateurs c'est bien sûr le volet
institutionnel
cécile cukierman est notamment et bien
le fait que le premier ministre dix on
n'est pas loin d'un accord avec le sénat
sur la révision constitutionnelle mais
sur le projet de loi organique ça
continue de points c'est au tour de la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
c'est manifestement là le problème est
la question la représentation des
territoires d'une représentation
équitable mais moi de toute façon
personnelle je ne suis pas pour la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires je
ne crois pas qu'on relève la crise
démocratique qui existent aujourd'hui en
réduisant le nombre d'élus il voudra
plus il faudrait rester aux nombreux que
ce soit parce qu'il y aura demain - le
parlementaire qu'ils seront plus
efficaces bien au contraire le savez
tous parlementaires qu il n 1 des
journées que de 24 heures de quoi ton
réduit le nombre de parlementaires
on réduira forcément à la fois la
présence territoriale et la présence ici
dans le travail législatif par m
certains députés à les roms qui dit ça
aujourd'hui la recontre jeu mais tant
mieux je crois que les idées quand même
fond du chemin non par contre je trouve
scandaleux cela a été dit hier et cela a
été repris repris ce matin c'est à dire
que le gouvernement est responsable
aujourd'hui de cette réforme
constitutionnelle c'était à lui de
l'assumer il ne peut pas prendre le
sénat en otage je crois qu'il n'y a pas
de chantage à faire ce n'est pas quelque
chose que l'on joue en jetant une pièce
en l'air une réforme constitutionnelle
la question de la représentativité
territoriale et citoyenne donc à
l'assaut nationale comme au sénat est
quelque chose d'important qui doit
accomplir assuré
fonctionnement de la république donc on
ne peut pas simplement venir en disant
jours senna sera d'accord on entamera ce
débat-là soit ce débat doit être sérieux
il doit être posé sur la table et nous
devons prendre le temps nécessaire à ce
que ce débat ait lieu et que des
propositions émergent soit sinon
effectivement il vaut mieux qu'il arrête
mais ce ne sera pas la faute du sénat
sera surtout l'incompétence d'un
gouvernement qui une fois plus a promis
des réformes qu'il ne fera pas bien
merci beaucoup c'est ce qui permet
d'avoir répondu à ma question
sans surprise je suppose que l'ensemble
de votre groupe votera contre ce qu
ensemble dans notre groupe a voté contre
effectivement la proposition de
confiance parce que nous n'avons pas
confiance je crois que j'ai bien dit
effectivement dans ce gouvernement comme
une grande partie des français
d'ailleurs
merci beaucoup c'est plus clair merci
merci à vous et âme pour cette nouvelle
réaction nathalie delattre nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour bienvenue
à vous c'est notre r&d ceux de la
gironde vous me disiez à l'instant vous
avez voté pour
vous avez été satisfait pas obtenu les
garanties souhaitées par le discours des
doors philippe ce matin écoutez comme
l'a rappelé mon président de groupe jean
claude requier ce n'est pas un blanc
seing mais effectivement nous verrons au
fur et à mesure mais le discours de ce
matin a permis de regarder de plus près
quelles étaient les propositions pour
les collectivités territoriales
et c'est vrai que les propos de de notre
premier ministre sont plutôt rassurants
bien sûr que les économies que nous
devrons faire sont un poids que nous
devons tous partager une responsabilité
que nous devons tous partager encore une
fois moi je pars du principe que le
sénat et ça a été largement dit
aujourd'hui n'est pas là pour renverser
la table ce n'est pas son rôle
mais là effectivement pour travailler
pour optimiser les projets de lois qui
nous sont proposés et le faire en lien
avec nos territoires cette proximité
je suis d'autant plus convaincu que de
toute manière renverser la table
aujourd'hui serait très dangereux il n'y
a aucun groupe politique que ça soit le
plr pardon que ce soit le ps qui puisse
relever le gant donc si c'est pour nous
retrouver face au rassemblement national
et avec un rassemblement national encore
plus fort je pense que non aujourd'hui
devons être constructif et nous devons
effectivement assurer de notre soutien
le premier ministre son gouvernement et
travailler à faire en sorte que la
france réponde aux aspirations des plus
défavorisés des plus démunis pourtant
nadia sollogoub on a entendu bien igor
philippe et puis d'autres collègues
c'est l'internaute à manger pense à
dominique estrosi sassone rappelé les
élus locaux ne sont les obligés de
personnes il ya ce sentiment parfois
d'être un peu sous pression de justement
devoir choisir son camp clarifier sa
position vis-à-vis de l'exécutif on est
pour emmanuel macron ont forcément on
est du côté est bien de l'ennemi c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'elle a dit le conseil
des doors philippe boyer vous parlez des
élus locaux
ah non alors les élus locaux il faut
réparer le toit de l'école ils se sont
pas du tout à ce niveau de l'engagement
et ils sont vraiment eux au service de
leurs concitoyens vraiment en première
ligne et je pense que ce genre de débat
les sénateurs ici puisque ce vote
justement certains ont pu voir un piège
jérôme bascher c'est ce que disait notre
président groupe bruno retailleau et ne
pas tomber dans ce piège qui reviendrait
finalement à nous diviser aussi nous
disait il hier on voit bien que s'il
avait fallu faire un ce vote il aurait
fallu le faire il ya deux ans il a été
oublié peut-être que on avait mal lu la
constitution je n'ose le croire
non effectivement c'était un piège mais
faut passer au delà d'ailleurs certains
nous disent oui à l'assemblée les road
contre ici vous votez nous ne sommes pas
dans les mêmes chambres nous n'avons pas
le même rôle ici nous essayons et on le
verra encore cet après midi il n' cmb
sur la loi des cols de la confiance
espérons qu'elle soit conclusive
nous avons travaillé nous avons sorti le
gouvernement d'un certain nombre de
difficultés que ce soit sur la sncf on
oublie un petit peu dans quelle
circonstance avait été fait en mai et
que c'est le sénat qui a permis de
sortir une épine du pied
et bien la majorité sénatoriale et la
république en marche et le rdse donc on
voit bien que on sait avoir des
majorités variés
au sénat on essaye sujet par sujet
c'était le sens de notre abstention nous
contrer ignorant à ne pas être céda
conclusion dominique estrosi sassone
mais ses propos de président de groupe
c'est pas de nom pas d'opposition
systématique et pas d'accord automatique
c'est le sens de cette abstention
ce n'est il faut en tout cas c'est une
assemblée dont le rôle est
principalement législatif et donc
qu'elle était conçue enfin moi je suis
mais ça il est très fidèle à cette
identité historique pour parfaire la loi
pas pour créer des chocs politique donc
que nos amis de l'opposition considère
que ce n'est pas le moment de se poser
pas de politique on passe sa vie à ça et
c'est pas toujours ce qu'on fait plus
utile mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
nos amis de l'opposition ont choisi de
mettre l'expression de leur position sur
un mode très modérée alors quand on fait
un geste comme ça on est toujours obligé
de la deûle à sortir de quelques
commentaires dépaysante et marty
malheureusement des décompensations
psychologique mais je pense que c'est
aussi le reflet du fait que la politique
qui est menée dans son ensemble au
service du pays
elle n'a pas d'alternative et que par le
moment en effet même les oppositions
considère qu'il faut appuyer cette
politique alors on sait que le vote est
bien est terminée on va procéder au
dépouillement dans l'hémicycle en
attendant la proclamation du résultat on
retourne salle des conférences avec vous
et elle traduit avec la sellette oui
samia ghali
vous faites partie des sénateurs
socialistes qui ont décidé de s'abstenir
sur ce discours de politique générale
pour quelle raison et je me suis à titre
personnel abstenu parce que je considère
que tout simplement dans ce qui a été
dit du discours général il ya plein de
choses qui me vont il ya des choses qui
ne me vend pas mais ça me laisse aussi
la liberté ensuite de pouvoir
m'expliquer mais je dirais de textes par
texte de loi par loi est de voir la
liberté de pouvoir dire ce que je pense
en fonction du texte de la loi qui me
sera présenté qu'est ce qui vous a
convaincu dans les annonces du premier
ministre aujourd'hui ian e
man u bien le volet sur la
décentralisation qui était détaillé
aujourd'hui goûter au delà de la du
volet sur la décentralisation il ya
d'autres volets sur la question
éducative sur la question notamment de
l'obésité sur la question beaucoup de
question pour moi qui était notamment
des questions sociétales
mais au delà de la question sociale
aussi qui a été évoqué pour moi sont des
signes sur lesquels je regarde avec
beaucoup d'attention ça me laisse aussi
la liberté de même de le critiquer ou de
dire ce que j'en pense je disais tout à
l'heure à la ministre de la justice
ô combien par exemple la question des
mineurs là aussi la responsabilité des
parents qui doit être avant tout un
enfant il a effectivement la naïveté des
fois de faire les choses sans avoir sans
y avoir réfléchi mais les parents n'ont
pas la naïveté de ne pas élever leurs
enfants voilà on quand on a décidé
d'apprendre par envoi jusqu'au bout
c'est donc pour vous et votre très
personnel mais vous n'êtes pas la seule
on nous parle d'une fête d'une dizaine
de socialistes qui seraient dans ce cas
il ya quand même des différences à
pardon excusez moi on va directement aux
séances il va y avoir la proclamation du
résultat le résultat du scrutin sur la
déclaration de politique générale du
gouvernement
nombre de votants 345 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 164 pour l'adoption
71 contre 93
le sénat n'a pas approuvé la déclaration
de politique générale du gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
nous allons nous retrouver à 14h30 pour
la proposition de loi visant à instituer
un médiateur territoriales dans
certaines collectivités
le sénat n'a donc pas approuvé la
déclaration de politique générale du
gouvernement après le discours d'edouard
philippe ce matin dans l'hémicycle alors
il y a le poids de l'abstention qui est
elle qui est à analyser avec 180
sénateurs qui se sont abstenus ces
abstentionnistes il
ils correspondent avant tout aux
sénateurs les républicains puisque le
groupe l'est républicain a appelé à
l'abstention il se déclare comme un
groupe constructif envers la politique
du gouvernement mais pas dans
l'opposition systématique et puis il ya
les groupes qui ont voté pour la
confiance au gouvernement
ils sont au nombre de 71 sénateurs et
ils correspondent à différents groupes
des petits groupes ici au sénat qui sont
plutôt favorables aux réformes annoncées
par edouard philippe parmi lesquels le
groupe les indépendants le groupe rds le
groupe évidemment la république en
marche et puis une partie des sénateurs
centristes qui ont voté pour la
confiance au gouvernement
et puis si on analyse les sénateurs qui
ont voté contre il y à la gauche du
sénat qui est unie avec les groupes
socialistes et communistes qui ont voté
à l'unisson contre la confiance une
partie des sénateurs
les républicains ont également voté
contre la confiance aux gouvernements
locaux finale le sénat n'a pas approuvé
cette déclaration de politique générale
et l'abstention arrive en tête avec une
forte majorité
merci beaucoup alexandre pour l'analyse
de ce scrutin alors qu'on voit edouard
philippe quitté l'hémicycle entouré des
ministres sébastien lecornu il a eu à
cet échange avec un club namur et le
président du groupe les indépendants ici
au sénat un discours qui était saluée
par l'ensemble de la haute assemblée
nadia sollogoub on voit donc finalement
ce vote sans surprise du sénat qui ne
m'accorde pas sa confiance mais il
faudra et alexandre boussard nous le
disait analyser dans le détail est
justement est bien le vote de chacun des
parlementaires
il ya quand même cette volonté de
travailler avec l'exécutif c'est ce qui
ressort ce matin pas ce qui ressort ce
matin surtout c'est l'énorme abstention
les normes position d'attenté voilà
c'est un poids pareil de l'abstention
est quand même
je pense le point principal a relevé
jean bassères c'est la majorité
sénatoriale qui choisit de ne pas se
diviser et de courir un risque réel de
division justement c'est le piège était
trop grossier je crois que nous avons un
peu plus d'habitude et d'expérience
alors sombrons pas dans dans les petits
pièges ni dans les petites phrases
d'ailleurs car il ya un vrai travail à
faire de réformes dans ce pays il ya des
réformes qu'il faudra savoir faire
rapidement et bien d'autres sur lesquels
il faudra concertée sans doute beaucoup
peut-être plus longuement ne pas passer
toujours par la procédure d'urgence
les sujets notamment sur de bioéthique
alors est-ce que ça va se résumer à la
pma pour tous où est ce qu'on va élargir
pour tout en l'occurrence est-ce que
aurait élargir à d'autres sujets c'est
des sujets de société
cela mérite mieux parfois qu'un
référendum on l'avait entendu sur
l'article rose donc il faudra entre
s'entendre sur ce conte mais voilà donc
je pense que c'est un souci d'apaisement
et nous tout ce qui va dans l'apaisement
nous va bien
en ligne de mire c'est pour ça que je
vais choisir monsieur j'attendrai
président du parti chez le spécialiste
de l'apaisement
comme cette phrase on a vu le jour alors
c'est qu'il raccompagnait edouard
philippe
ils se sont certainement échangé
quelques mots et toujours sur cette
révision constitutionnelle on sait que
ça a été rappelé hier 7 abstentions
ce n'est pas un blanc-seing il ya quand
même toujours cette petite menace de la
part de la droite sur cette année comme
juges à l'égard c'est une opposition qui
n'arrivent pas à s'opposer parce qu'elle
n'a rien à proposer
il suffit d'ailleurs d'entendre ce que
disait mon collègue qu'il parlait d'un
piège car le simple fait qu'on consulte
pour savoir si les gens soutiennent le
gouvernent
et poursuit approuve la poursuite de
l'action de réformes
ça n'est pas un piège c'est une
consultation politique qui vous paraît
légitime était prévue par la
constitution dans cette consultation
politique
les sénateurs de l'opposition de droite
et l'air et une partie des centristes
ont considéré qu'il ne pouvait pas ne se
sentait pas la force d'affirmer leurs
positions et jean choisi de la mettre en
rideau je trouve ça plutôt sympathique
nathalie delattre darche n'est pas
justifié cette demande devant justement
par souci de clarté je cite dans un
moment de bascule de notre vision
politique qui invite à dépasser les
clivages anciens c'est possible en
encore selon donc c'est moi le
commentaire que je ferai c'est la vie
continue je crois que vous l'avez
entendu gérard larcher nous invite à
14h30 a assisté à ma proposition de
l'ong je vais proposer
donc je crois que la suite c'est dans
l'hémicycle nous allons le construire
ensemble comme nous l'avons toujours
fait pour voter des lois pragmatique
bien sûr ces réformes indispensables
et je pense que le prochain match
puisque c'est ce que vous attendez et
notamment dans les billets assez le
projet de loi de finances notamment
et c'est celui-ci qui sera important et
ce sont ces votes là qui seront
importants à regarder je crois qu'il
faut regarder aujourd'hui ce vote comme
un épiphénomène
enfin c'est pas très important pour
notre vie sénatoriales et pour la vie du
pays or justement on va voir marc
fesneau 1 le ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement quelle
analyse s'est-il alice - quelle lecture
fait-il du vote du sénat tentera lui oui
marc fesneau effectivement quelle
analyse faites-vous de ce vote
71 vote contre 84,93 nord pendant 61
votes pour 84 ans contre c'est plutôt
pas mal pour vous d'abord c'est bien que
le sénat et puis s'exprimer sur le
discours de politique générale du
premier ministre que ses seins dans une
assemblée même si ça n'en porte pas
évidemment la démission du gouvernement
si un vote contre puisque la
constitution n'a pas prévu ça
mais c'est bien qu'on veut dans une
déclaration de politique générale le
sénat soit traité comme l'assemblée
nationale puisse exprimer par son vote
ce qu'ils pensent du discours de
politique générale je rappelle la
situation à laquelle nous sommes au
sénat 23 sénateurs
lrm qui se réclament de la majorité et
au sol nous sommes à 71 ça veut dire
qu'un certain nombre de gens qui ont
voulu montrer avec on est écouté
discours du président manu rées du
président marcel du président rockets
qui ont exprimé un certain nombre de
choses qui allaient dans le bon sens
pour eux des choses sur lequel il
fallait aller plus loin c'est je le
prends comme un signe d'ouverture d'un
certain nombre de gens qui disent on
veut la réussite du pays on veut qu'ils
aient des rassemblements qui puisse
s'opérer dans l'intérêt du pays on veut
être dans une stratégie du dépassement
ce qu'a dit le premier ministre et c'est
bien qu'on puisse franchir c'est celle
là je salue aussi ceux qui ont fait le
choix de l'abstention qui est une
position de réserve qu'on peut
comprendre personne ne demande à
personne ne renonce à ce qu'il est
personnalisé pas moi ça vous permet
d'avoir un petit peu donc le décompte
des troupes et donc 71 jeunes en
régiment de personnes il ya des gens qui
ont exprimé dans leur vote le vote
c'était la confiance ou pas la confiance
à la déclaration de politique générale
du premier ministre et c'est à dire de
plus c'est un acte de confiance et c'est
important dans la vie politique quand
des gens expriment un acte de confiance
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait aujourd'hui
mais moi je n'en régiment de personnes
je ne je ne ferme personne sur ce groupe
je regrette que dans certains groupes on
était dans une stratégie un peu de
l'isolément en disant il faut voter
contre parce qu'on est dans l'opposition
non on peut être dans l'opposition on
peut être un républicain on peut penser
qu'il ya des choses qui vont dans le bon
sens et que ont fait crédit à telle ou
telle quelle que soit son origine pour
essayer de faire avancer le payer donc
c'est un acte positif et d'ouverture qui
a été exprimé par beaucoup de sénateurs
j'y vois comme un bon chez nous pas tant
au service de la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale en avant une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale mais aussi un
signe d'ouverture de volonté de
travailler ensemble
assemblée et sénat d'ailleurs tous les
sénateurs l'ont bien dit il gardent leur
liberté pour les futurs projets de loi
qu'elle vous avez dans la balance non
mais dans la vie politique on a besoin
de gens libres mais on a besoin de gens
libres et qui pousse c'est ce qui s'est
exprimé aussi aujourd'hui l'intérêt du
pays et moi je trouve que c'est toujours
une bonne nouvelle en démocratie les sna
temps en tout cas ce sont très libres
sur la question de la révision
constitutionnelle sur laquelle vous avez
fait toute une consultation des
présidents de groupe depuis
à ce nombre de jours avec la garde des
sceaux nicole belloubet
c'est le nombre de la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires le sujet
vraiment qui coince aujourd'hui pour
vous et qui a chopé lance un coup des
secondes il est président de groupe au
sénat et à l'assemblée nationale c'est
vrai que c'est un tout c'est très forte
c'est une réforme institutionnelle avec
trois blogs l'a3 loi les sénateurs
divers organismes et constitutionnel les
deux prochains les deux dernières étant
lié à un vote conforme du sénat des
trois cinquièmes pour le coin de la
constitution et donc on n'avance pas sur
une défense à 100 est à peu près et
bordée sur l'idée que nous pourrions
obtenir un accord aujourd'hui on s'est
rapprochés d'un accord faut dire les
choses comme elles sont le produit nice
d'ailleurs l'air lui-même exprimé le
président larcher l'a lui même exprimé
nous ne sommes pas encore à la corde
donc pas la peine d'aller dans cette
confrontation là s'ils ne peuvent qu on
peut avancer sur le sur l'accord c'est
une histoire de vingt sénateurs
finalement pour vous l'annoncé pas une
histoire de vingt sénateurs c'est plus
profond que ça je pense qu'il faut vous
pourrez pas résumé le président larcher
ne veut pas le faire je crois pas c'est
pas une affaire de vingt sénateurs ce
n'est pas qu'une affaire d'arithmétique
qui n'est pas une affaire de philosophie
et donc je ne doute pas que les mois qui
viennent nous permettront aussi de
continuer à cheminer en douze mois il ya
beaucoup de chemin de fait oui je crois
qu'on s'est beaucoup investi les temps
encore non mais je crois qu'on s'est
beaucoup écouté et dans la vie politique
là aussi c'est bien de pouvoir s'écouter
de respecter les uns et les autres une
pas question pour nous de forcer la main
du sénat c'est une question de respect
aussi des équilibres et on a besoin du
sénat pour la révision courageuse est
cette fois que le chantage à l'égard du
sénat il les met dans la position
qu'elle chanta jeu mais c'est pas une
chance à chacun prend ses
responsabilités la crise
constitutionnelle chacun prend ses
responsabilités dans la vie politique on
peut avoir des désaccords
on vient de parler des accords ou de la
confiance qui a pu être fait par un
certain nombre de sénateurs on peut
aussi assumer qu'on ne soit pas d'accord
c'est pas un drame
il faut l'assumer que chacun assume ses
responsabilités et en démocratie c'est
plutôt sain merci beaucoup s'est
remarqué nous d'avoir répondu à ma
question
merci à vous non j'ai apprécié le
discours de marc fesneau il essaye
toujours d'apaiser nous sommes au sénat
plutôt dense et 1
je crois tout les sénateurs n'est plus
tôt dans cette dynamique là c'est vrai
que sur la réforme constitutionnelle et
institutionnelle dans la constitution on
le voit bien on est quasiment prêt à
100% quelques ses exigences supérieures
au sénat mais comme le fait que la
circonscription sénatoriales est le
département condition sinequanone
départements ou territoires à statut
particulier faut pas oublier justement
que l'aig et amis ultramarins on
s'approche d'une solution et c'est ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure je pense que
à 20% et donc c'est quoi une vingtaine
de sénateurs et une trentaine de députés
dont il s'agit ça serait bizarre de dire
ça mais si cela lorsque c'est bien s'est
jamais sait jamais des questions de
chiffres sauf que aujourd'hui c'est la
seule chose qui nous est reproché sur
renouvellement entier du sénat je
rappelle que la constitution n'a pas
prévu la dissolution du sénat or c'est
ce de cela dont il s'agit qui pourrait
attendre après les sénatoriales de 2020
ce moment plus propice plus favorables
là aussi c'est un calcul politique selon
vous l'alsace logo ben non je sais pas
si c'est un calcul politique enfin voilà
ça me dépasse un petit peu ce que je
suis très terre à terre est très ancrée
sur le terrain moi je trouve que marc
fesneau était tout à fait dans son rôle
son discours était très bon par contre
je reviens ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure il y à des territoires comme les
territoires ultramarins et des
territoires également en métropole qui
ont une vraie problématique de ratio de
nombre d'habitants au kilomètre carré et
c'est vraiment sur des critères croisé
qu'il faut aller si on veut une vraie
justice en effet c'est une philosophie
c'est pas uniquement en en arithmétique
pur qu'il faut réfléchir
on a beaucoup parlé de la réforme des
institutions aussi qu'on parle de ce
nouvel acte de décentralisation de ces
deux projets de loi qui ont été
présentés détaillé ce matin nathalie
delattre un texte sur le statut de l'élu
en quelque sorte pour favoriser
l'engagement des mères c'est aussi ce
qui vous a fait qu'ils veulent a poussé
peut-être à voter pour ce matin
justement cette réponse aux inquiétudes
des territoires cette crise de la
vocation des élus locaux alors sur la
réforme des institutions juste dire un
mot dire que effectivement j'ai un peu
de mal à adhérer et d'un côté et de
l'autre sur le fait que ce sont des
négociations qui se passe ce sont des
négociations de couloir moi j'aimerais
bien qu'on ait à un moment donné sous
une forme ou une autre
un atelier qui nous réunissent peut-être
qu'ils ne soient pas moins des bronzés
forcément débat en séance ce serait
peut-être trop solennel mais à un moment
donné je pense qu'il nous faut des
espaces où nous allons pouvoir réfléchir
ensemble parce que là on sent bien que
cela se fait dans les couloirs de
l'elysée dans les couloirs de matignon
ou dans les couloirs sans savoir ce que
je pense que en notre sang nous sommes
tous des représentants de nos
territoires et que nous avons tous à
relayer ce que nos élus ont envie aussi
de dire ce qu'ils ont perçu du de leur
terrain les prises de leurs intérêts les
présidents ont l'impression que les
présidents de groupes ont été reçus mais
ce sont des présidents de groupes
politiques tout le monde et moi je suis
bien placé pour le savoir au groupe rdse
tout le monde n'a pas une carte
politique
tout le monde n'a pas forcément mais est
encore une fois je pense que alors ça ça
devient très à la mode mais notre parti
c'est la france et la france dans notre
diversité elle a des choses à dire et
pas forcément parce que on a le
privilège d'être reçu par le premier
ministre ou par le porte parole je pense
que nous avons la maturité en tout cas
on l'a prouvé on le prouve sans cesse
nous avons la maturité au sénat pour
pouvoir en discuter
je trouve assez condé son nom le fait
que quand vous serez prêt vous vous
toquer à la porte
non je crois que c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe ça doit être un dialogue
permanent et constant il y à une
préoccupation des français
il faut que nous soyons plusieurs à
pouvoir en débattre en tout cas nous
avons été élus pour cela et je trouve ça
un peu supportable qu'on nous prive de
sur la décentralisation
oui je pense que en tout cas
politiquement on l'a exprimé laurent
hénart l'a exprimé dès le discours
d'hier c'est vrai qu'il mentait manquer
cette dimension dans le discours de
d'edouard philippe billard sur cet acte
de décentralisation
là il est allé un peu plus loin c'est
effectivement au delà des irritants de
la loi notre je pense que nous avons là
aussi beaucoup pas dire et
nous ferons le travail autour des
propositions de projets de lois qui nous
sont proposés il en a décrit plusieurs
c'est quelque chose qui nous tient à
coeur
je pense que l'on va aller beaucoup plus
loin que les propositions qui ont été
annoncés ce matin continuer sur ce point
retourne une dernière fois à celle des
conférences avec vous on est en train
d'y et puisque c'est le président du
groupe centriste
les sénateurs de s'énerver marcel quitte
à vos côtés c'est me hervé marseille
comment analysez-vous bien le résultat
de ce scrutin
71 vote pour 93 compte finalement la
différence est à 20 voix près pour
obtenir ou non la majorité
le vote de confiance du sénat t
oui je prends acte de ce résultat dans
mon groupe
un bon tiers des sénateurs ont rapporté
leur confiance au gouvernement
oui les autres ont manifesté par leur
abstention une retenue qu'on va
qualifier de bienveillante à l'égard du
gouvernement il ya beaucoup de textes
annoncé on va voir à l'aune de ces
textes
comment ça se passe et vous même hervé
marseille votre je me suis abstenu
justement vous avez parlé lors de votre
intervention de ce regard distancé
clinique avait eu le gouvernement à
l'égard des territoires vous avez parlé
aussi de prendre ce dédain jacobins est
ce que et bien les deux projets de loi
annoncé par le gouvernement en matière
de décentralisation et statut de l'élu
peuvent bien commencer à résoudre ce
problème et je crois que le gouvernement
l'a reconnu le chef du gouvernement en a
parlé hier et aujourd'hui la crise des
gilets jaunes a été analysé le grand
débat est passée par là et je crois
qu'il ya une forme de mea culpa et le
fait qu'il continue et intuitive
c'est vrai que le mandat précédent est à
l'origine de textes qui sont très
improbables la loi map tam la loi nôtre
on rapportait beaucoup de difficultés
aux collectivités donc le chef du
gouvernement je crois
à bien analyser les choses il a bien
compris le fait qu'ils deviennent au
sénat pour parler territoire déjà d'une
marque de considération qu'on n'avait
pas l'habitude d'avoir le fait qu'il
fasse les annonces ici pour les
territoires au sénat est une bonne chose
et puis voilà donc c'est une bonne chose
il faut savoir le dire quand ça se passe
et puis il va y avoir des textes ils ont
été annoncés c'est madame bourreau
monsieur le corps nu qui vont les
présenter on va travailler avec eux et
j'espère que ce sera profitable pour
toutes les collectivités de france parce
que c'est notre action à nous qui doit
pouvoir le garantir
la nouveauté aussi de cette matinée
c'est qu'il ya donc eu un vote du sénat
c'est très inhabituel y at il aussi une
volonté de compter les troupes notamment
bien sûr avec en visée la question de la
révision constitutionnelle qui pour le
coup semble encore lointaine
écoutez je ne sais pas si elle est
lointaine c'est un engagement du chef de
l'état il l'avait annoncé il l'a
confirmé il a assoupli ses positions
pour chercher la convergence avec le
céda je tirais en conclusion que s'il
veut il peut senna est disponible mon
groupe en tous les cas accompagnera
cette réforme et jean souhaite le bon
aboutissants de ce cas si ça n'aboutit
pas on vous dit que ce n'est pas la
faute du sénat parce que pour l'instant
c'est ce que dit l'exécutif
oui mais bon je veux dire là on est un
peu dans la danse des sept voiles on va
regarder ce qui se passe je pense que si
on se met sérieusement autour de la
table et tout le monde je recherche
l'accord on le trouvera merci beaucoup
aidé marseille d'avoir bien des
questions pour cette action jachère on
évoquer cette question du statut de
l'élu aura entendu edouard philippe
proposé de la formation une protection
juridique majeure prise en compte aussi
des situations familiales des
propositions finalement déjà fait par le
sénat oui mon collègue mais tu dois
faire
proposition et un rapport assez complet
sur le sujet alors j'ai entendu hier le
gouvernement dira qu'il s'inspirerait
des travaux du sénat
alors après plus il s'inspire du sénat
mieux c'est donc c'est ce sera faire
preuve de sagesse qui m'inquiète un peu
plus c'est le temps pris sur la
décentralisation et le tour 3
décentralisation car juste avant les
élections on fait vite pour le statut de
l'élu mais ont fait moins vite me
remettre fin du premier semestre il va
fin du premier 16 20 g ou bien écouter
vous savez et donc
juste après les élections municipales et
je pense que c'est d'abord le site de
démotivation de nos élus sur le terrain
les maires des communes les plus petites
ils ont plus de soucis
parfois sur c'est quoi encore de pouvoir
c'est quoi encore de pouvoir réel entre
le manque d'argent et des compétences
très partagés eh bien ils sont souvent
un peu perdu ça aurait sans doute été
assez cohérent là encore de présenter à
peu près les deux textes souvent les
grandes lignes pour justement motivé et
favoriser l'engagement des mères si on
ne s'engage quand on connaît pas
justement ses compétences à venir les
financements les élus locaux ont besoin
oui alors il ya vraiment une crise des
vocations que l'on va prendre de plein
fouet au moment des élections
municipales
hier soir nous avons échangé dans
l'hémicycle une proposition sur ce sujet
et je vais pas communiste voilà il ya
urgence à échanger sur ces sujets alors
on a malheureusement et beaucoup vous
posez la notion d'engagement bénévole de
l'élu de gratuité et le fait qu'il
éventuellement qu'ils puissent disposer
d'un statut et je pense que c'est un
faux débat parce que maintenant on est
plus dans la gratuité d'être élus
particulièrement de terrain dans nos
petites communes ça coûte
il ya tous les élus combat des unités et
des élus condé toute petite indemnité
qui sont pas du tout à la hauteur des
fringues s'engage il ya les élus qui
n'osent pas pénaliser les toutes petites
finances de leur commune en touchant
leurs indemnités donc les élus font sont
absolument pas indemnisés ils sont pas
il ya des aspects assurantiel et puis
ceux compatibles avec la vie
professionnelle la vie de famille tout
cela n'est pas pris en compte donc c'est
totalement dissuasif
et puis je pense qu'il faut pas opposer
les deux notions parce que les élus
locaux peuvent parfaitement avoir un
statut et continue à faire pleins de
regret parce qu'ils en font de manière
beaucoup plus il ya urgence très
rapidement nathalie de l'ajustement à se
positionner sur cette question du statut
d'élu oui c'est très important mais
alors contrairement à vous je j'ai
l'impression qu'elle approche des
échéances l'évocation reviennent dans
tout de même
j'entends quand même pas mal de
candidature et de candidats mais c'est
fondamental sera mental
ce qui est fondamental c'est aussi de
savoir avec quels moyens
effectivement pour répondre aux demandes
des administrés donc effectivement ça va
de pair et c'est vraiment quelque chose
que nous devrions voir ensemble ces deux
textes devraient être conjoint et bien
merci à vous nathalie delaître merci
jérôme bascher merci à dieu merci
d'avoir été mes invités ce matin on
reviendra cet après midi dans sénat 360
sur ce discours de politique générale
très bonne suite à des programmes sur
public sénat il ya tout à l'air 16h30
[Musique]